Die haben sich alle auf dem Hauptplatz versammelt. Dort wird der Weihnachtsmann das erste Weihnachtsgeschenk verteilen. Und wer bitte bekommt dieses erste Geschenk? Er wird einen von euch auswählen.
Darf ich, darf ich, darf ich? Ich will das in der Mitte.
Nur einfach nur Text und Hierarchie und drängen und droppen und fertig und Reihenfolge und ein paar Tastatur-Shortcuts und dann... Muss scheiße schnell sein, also instantan, Instant-Synch. Auch nichts ist ungesyncht. Nicht irgendwie einmal die Minute, synch ich dann mal, sondern es ist halt einfach, du änderst was und so bang, es ist irgendwie draussen, sofort. Und dann muss es sofort auch in alle anderen Clients sofort hinein populieren.
Also wenn du irgendwie noch dasselbe Dokument auf dem anderen Rechner offen hast, Paff, Geduld und ein Quäntchen mehr Demut würden dir sehr gut stehen.
Warte nur ein Weilchen.
Und du, Woddy, ein Beispiel an Entscheidungskraft, wie du so voller Zuversicht bist und voller Geist.
Du Teufelskerl.
Haben wir so eine Schelle, wie in diesem Weihnachtsgeschenk?
Wie in diesen Weihnachtspop-Songs? Aber ich bin, also auch im Fußball werden die Leute, die die Vorlagen liefern, viel zu wenig gelost.
Wir halten fest.
Roddy hat zu Weihnachten immer eine Schelle bekommen.
Was du heute so von hier gibst, vielleicht verdienst du ja noch eine Schelle. Ja, hallo, hier ist die Freak Show, 146. Ausgabe und ganz nebenbei die letzte des Jahres 2014. Ja, ganz nebenbei hier auch die letzte Produktion der Mittei-Ebene in diesem Jahr.
Du könntest doch eigentlich einem Sendezentrum machen. Ihr seid ja eh alle da, außer mir.
Wie, aber der 31. ist doch ein Mittwoch. Ich hab mir das extra freigenommen. Können wir reinfeiern mit einer 5-Stunden-Sendung. Extra long.
Ich nehm die beiden. Sagen wir einfach, die sollen das Zeug nochmal stehen lassen am 30. Dass wir noch eine Sendung machen können, ist natürlich. Oder bist du das Spieler in Berlin?
Achso, ja, ich glaub, das können wir verlängern.
In welchem Zustand bist du denn normalerweise so am 31.12.?
durchschlafen.
Ich hab auch schon ein paar Silvester verpennt nach dem Kongress. Bin nach Hause gekommen, Ohrenstöpsel rein, peng, und dann, als das große Gewitter losging, bin ich noch mal kurz aufgewacht, kurz aus dem Fenster geguckt, achja, gut, Ohrstöpsel wieder rein, weiter gepennt. Funktioniert wunderbar.
Man liegt so im Bett, merkt man, man ist voll müde und es ist eigentlich egal. Aber eigentlich müsste es jetzt doch gleich mal losknallen und dann guckt man doch mal auf die Uhr und dann ist plötzlich drei schon.
Also wenn Tim nicht zu Silvester einlädt, dann bleibst du zu Hause und fände.
Ja, nee, also Silvester-Party jetzt geht so mit Kongress in Hamburg einfach gar nicht zusammen.
Scheiße, daran habe ich nicht gedacht.
Ja, so ganz nebenbei, wir sind vollzählig hier. Roddy, hallo Roddy. Guten Tag Clemens, hallo Clemens. Ich weiß, du bist nicht auf dem Kongress, wir haben es schon eingepreist.
Ja, das kann ich jetzt da nicht mitlachen.
Ja, nee leider.
Das ist schade eigentlich.
Ich grine so vor mich hin, weil ich weiß wo ich bin und das ist alles gut da oben.
Sollen wir dir eine Kiste da irgendwo in den Dreck stellen, dass du ein bisschen so Kongressen Netz schnuppern kannst?
Ein Pie, ich kann euch einen Pie mitgeben, den er mir da ins Netz steckt. Ich hab ja immer so einen Sack voller Pies bei mir, den ich dann irgendwo, wenn ich ein Netz testen will, schmeiß die immer ab. Das ist mich ganz gut so zum Remote snoopen. Ich hab die so aufgesetzt.
Ernsthaft.
Heute verfeilt man so Pies.
Nee, ich mach das häufiger mal, gerade wenn ich so Sachen wegschicke oder so. Ich hab halt die Pies so programmiert, dass die sich irgendein Netz suchen, was es gibt und dann machen sie einen OpenVPN-Tunnel nach Hause auf, wie so ein Hardware-Trojaner oder so was. Den schicke ich dann immer mal mit, weil die Leute dann, was ich ihnen schicke, das Equipment manchmal nicht richtig angestöpselt kriegen oder sonst was, dann ist das halt gut, wenn man sozusagen einen Blick von drinnen nach draußen hat, als dass man jetzt zwei Stunden mit dem Firewall-Admin auf der anderen Seite diskutieren muss.
Clemens digitale Chemtrails. Du wirfst die Dinger wahrscheinlich so mit dem Flugzeug ab. Ich hab überall Netz.
Das ist echt ein recht erfolgreiches, was mir das schon an Lauferei gespart hat.
Ja, Huckel ist da.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, souverän. Und Dennis ist da. Und ihr seid auch alle da. Da freuen wir uns natürlich immer drüber.
Da sind wir jetzt im Hörermeter. Kommt das irgendwann nochmal wieder an den Start? Oder nicht? Da steht eins da oben.
Stimmt.
Ich kann dir sagen, das Jahr 2014 war hier in der Metaebene nicht das Jahr des Ausbaus der Infrastruktur.
Aber mit Reaper wurde alles besser.
Es wurde schon einiges besser.
Warum gibt es eigentlich keine höhere Anzahl im Reaper? Hallo, Herr Stockmann.
Was ist das für ein Scheiß hier?
Ein Eimer mit Profis.
Ein Eimer mit Profis?
Da müsste man in der Tat nochmal... Ja, es gibt viele Upgrades. Aber ich habe es jetzt immerhin noch geschafft, zum Jahresende IPv6 dann doch mal zum Laufen zu bekommen.
Du hast es doch eigentlich immer.
Was?
Wir hier, aber eher nicht auf seinen Servern.
Der Download-Server hatte schon ganz lange v6, aber auf... lange Geschichte, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall ist das alles v6. Das habe ich jetzt nur gemacht, um mich noch ein bisschen aus der Schusslinie zu kriegen, nicht, dass auf dem Kongress an irgendeiner auf mich zukommt und sagt, hier, aber v6 hast du ja nicht.
Die ganze Zeit labern.
Man muss ja vom Kongress schon so ein bisschen auf sein Leadness-Faktor achten.
Sicher, sicher.
Du bist aber, was deine Security angeht, noch ein bisschen behind, ne? Bis SSL haben wir es noch nicht geschafft. Oder TLS, Entschuldigung. Bis TLS haben wir es noch nicht geschafft.
Was im Wesentlichen an den bekloppten Webseiten liegt. Ich verzweifle jedes Mal wieder an so was wie Start, Kommen und diesen ganzen hol dir die Kategorie.
Das ist wirklich easy-peasy.
Was ja richtig schön ist hier für SSL, aber eben nicht so vielleicht für Privatkunden, hatte ich ja schon erwähnt. Dieses Digi-Zert finde ich ja nach wie vor. Selbst wo wir das bei WUGA so ein bisschen benutzen, ist es schon genau so, wie man das haben will. Also da klickt man und das schnickt und es schnackt und es bietet alle Optionen, die man sich so vorstellt und wenn man denkt, ah, aber jetzt hätte ich gerne noch das, da gibt es einen Button für und man klickt und es gibt alles.
Super. Ja, aber ätteren Preise kaufen kriege ich mir jetzt glaube ich nicht geklickt, das wäre mir glaube ich zu teuer.
Der kostet ja nichts. Die Zertifikate sind halt ein bisschen teurer. Also Enterpreise kaufen kriegt man auch so.
Aber nochmal, du machst eh bitte deine Zertifikate selber bei dir zu Hause mit dem ganzen Quack und Key generieren und lalala und gehst dann nur noch hin und das ist eine reine Copy-and-Paste-Geschichte. Du musst da nichts mehr hochladen und so machst du nur noch mit Copy-and-Paste. Da kommt dann so ein Fenster von denen und du sagst, hier hätten wir gerne dein Certifikat-Request rein, dann nimmst du den aus deinem XCA mit Copy, kopierst den da rein und dann singen die in dir den, der daraus kommt, nimmst mit Copy und schmeißt den in dein XCA und alles ist gut.
Das ist da zum Beispiel auch richtig toll. Da gibt es nämlich hier so Generate a CSR-Button und ich dachte schon so, machen die jetzt einen Key für mich oder was? Dann klickst du so die ganzen Optionen und es ist alles sehr schön. Dann klickst du auf Generate und dann poppt so ein Fenster auf mit dem OpenSSL-Commando mit allem schon ausgefüllt und du musst wirklich nur einmal pasten, Enter, Schnack und zurück.
Aber nochmal. Hallo, genau, Tim, du sollst OpenSSL nicht anfassen. Du suchst jetzt mal nach dem Open Source Tool XCA. Das gibt es sogar für unsere Windows-Hörer. Das ist ein schöner Open Source Tool, der hat eine schöne, ne, eine schöne ist die Oberfläche nicht, aber die funktioniert super. Das macht dir das alles. Das ist deine Security auf deinem Rechner und alles super schick. Dann nimmst du nur noch mit Copy das CSR da raus, schmeißt es bei Start SSL da rein, lässt es designen, machst anders und wieder Zeug.
Als ob das irgendwie eine ausschließlich Frage des Generierens eines Zertifikats sei. Ja, ist es, nicht?
Ist es.
Nee, da hängt leider nochmal ein Rattenschwanz von anderen Problemen.
Na dann sag mal.
Naja, in dem Moment, wo ich irgendwie HTTPS einführe, ändern sich halt URLs.
Kann das WordPress super mit ab, hab ich gerade ausprobiert vor drei Tagen. Ist ihm scheißegal. Es guckt nämlich nur nach seinem Hostnamen. Du darfst deinen Hostnamen nicht verändern dafür. Aber ob das HTTPS oder HTTPS ist, ist ihm scheißegal.
Zählt nicht.
Also, nächste Ausrede.
Das Ding ist, es gibt da in dieser ganzen Podcast-Infrastruktur noch ein paar andere Mitspieler, nämlich zum Beispiel diese ganzen Podcast-Client. Von denen schon mal so die Hälfte mit HTTPS-Feed-URLs nur so begrenzt klarkommt.
Dann erzwingst du nicht HTTPS. Nächste Ausrede.
Ja, dann hab ich aber sowohl HTTPS als auch HTTPS. Und dann hab ich sehr schnell das Problem, dass meine Feed-Adressen sowohl als HTTPS als auch HTTPS da draußen sind.
Du kannst ja deine Feed-Adressen als HTTPS lassen, weil das ist ja nur absolut zip.
Ja, dann muss ich ja quasi nur dafür eine Ausnahme machen, aber an der Stelle wird es einfach so, dass ich mir da vorstehe mit der Frage so, was bricht jetzt? Weil das Problem ist, wenn da erst mal so Weiterleitungen anfangen, sich weiterzuleiten und anderen Entitäten im Set sagen, jetzt ist es anders, dann ist das teilweise nicht so ohne Weiteres rückholbar.
Mit anderen Worten, deine ganze Potluff-Geschichte ist noch im Beginn seiner Designphase.
Das hat jetzt mit Potluff überhaupt nichts zu tun. Das hat einfach was damit zu tun, dass ein Podcast-Abo, da nagen und saugen einfach Programme aller Art und aller Qualitätsgüte, auch minderer Qualitätsgüte an diesen Feats.
Ja, aber du hast doch deine ganze Ressource. Man fummelst ja noch ewig an deinen komischen Subscribe-Button darum und so weiter und so fort. Dann könnte man doch bei der Gelegenheit gleich rausfinden, welcher von diesen Düsseldien-Podcast-Klienz da draußen in 2014, who's 2015 immer noch nicht in der Lage ist, HTTPS Orts zu bearbeiten und den auf die Fresse hauen oder die einfach aussperren und sagen, benutzen Sie bitte einen ordentlichen...
Das ist genau die Phase, in der ich gerade bin. Das ist genau gerade der Punkt. Ich versuche mir gerade darüber klar zu werden, wie es ist. Und es ist halt nicht schön.
Nee, dann mach es schön. Ist es dein Job?
Die Leute bezahlen dich mit Lebkuchen dafür.
Du mit Future, jetzt wir auch alle.
Aber kurze Frage zwischendurch, warum brauchst du überhaupt SSL?
Weil es inzwischen Leute gibt, die androhen, dass sie Browser rausbringen, die HTTP einfach rumschreien, als würdest du gerade auf ein falsches Zertifikat treten.
Das wird jetzt wirklich dramatisch. Auch Google bevorzugt ja dann auch in Suchergebnissen HTTPS gegenüber HTTP. Also wir befinden uns jetzt, ich weiß nicht, wie viel das mit Snowden zu tun hat, aber das hat sicherlich so ein bisschen eine Rolle gespielt.
Technischer Sozialdruck.
Wir haben uns ja auch im Club immer lange gefragt, warum macht denn das keiner? Abgesehen von den technischen Schwierigkeiten und diesen finanziellen Zwängen, die das ja mit sich bringen. Weil auf einmal musst du halt für etwas Geld bezahlen, wo du vorher nicht und das kann austimen. Und wenn es austimt, dann ist auf einmal von heute auf morgen alles ganz furchtbar. Also du brauchst da einfach eine ganz andere Obseq als Webseitenbetreiber, als wenn du da einfach nur so eine stinkige, unverschlüsselte HTTP-Nummer fährst. So und ich hab ja überhaupt nichts dagegen, alles über HTTPS zu machen, aber ich will mir halt auch wirklich total sicher sein, dass ich da einen Migrationspfad habe, der bei mir jetzt erstmal in meiner Installation nichts durcheinanderhaut. Das ist vielleicht noch leistbar, aber wo dann eben auch diese ganze Infrastruktur, ich schreib ja diese Podcastline-Developer an. Und ich sag denen hier, schön, dass das jetzt hier mit dem Subscribe-Button klappt, mach doch bitte mal nochmal die Änderung, damit ihr auch HTTPS-URLs macht. Und dann kommen so Antworten wie, wieso sollte irgendjemand seinen Podcast über HTTPS anbieten?
Ich kann dir jetzt sagen, warum. Du würdest zwar jetzt sagen, dass...
Ich kann dir das auch sagen, warum, aber die Frage ist...
Was du jetzt hier gerade machst, ist zum Beispiel Freak Show, ist ja theoretisch unproblematisch. Aber nehmen wir an, du machst mal eine Netzpolitik-Sendung oder irgendwas, wo jetzt Fies über Nordkorea oder sonst jemand herzieht, oder über die USA. Clemens, ich hab das verstanden.
Ich musste das...
Weil er erklärt dem Hörer oder dem Podcast. Da erklärt dem Podcast... Es geht jetzt weniger darum, dass man den Podcast irgendwie verschlüsselt, weil der ist ja eh öffentlich zu haben, aber das ist zum Beispiel durchaus interessant, dass nicht jeder weiß, wer alle deine Podcasts hört, vor allem die kritischen. Aber dann machen wir einfach keinen kritischen Podcast mehr.
Du wirst halt auch so nebenbei diese schmachmatischen Proxys los.
Du wirst alle Mühe los.
Ja klar, es ist absolut wünschenswert, aber es ist halt nur so, dass diese Infrastruktur da draußen nur begrenzt auf diesen Schritt vorbereitet ist.
Ja, aber du erzeugst einen großen Teil dieser Infrastruktur mit deinem Part-Love-Projekt.
Ja, aber wenn ich das jetzt umschalte und morgen kriege ich dann einfach pro Tag 50 Twitter-Nachrichten mit Mein Podcast gleich gleich gleich gleich abrufen, dann ist es auch nicht mehr reversibel. Das ist einfach dann...
Kollateralschäden, da musst du durch die paar 50.
Ja, dann sagst du, in welcher Podcast-Client ist das? Stern, Notierstern und dann bitte nimm den ordentlichen Podcast-Client.
Ich bin da flexibel, aber Menschen benutzen Software und wenn diese Developer, die reagieren ja teilweise noch...
Du hast ja nur Angst, Hörer zu verlieren.
50.
Du, das sind auch deine Flatterklicks.
Ich würde es nicht so sehr unter der Angst Hörer verlieren, abbuchen, sondern eher, ich will ja niemanden, ich möchte ja keinem Hörer zumuten, mich zu verlieren.
Aber du möchtest auch Zukunft jetzt. Du möchtest doch mal Zukunft jetzt. Du gehst doch hin und maulst irgendwelche komischen Kneipenbetreiber hier in Prenzlberg an, warum sie keinen V6 in ihrem Scheiß-Wlan haben. Ich möchte Zukunft Gäste anhaben. Dann kann man auch hingehen, sagen zum Podcaster meiner Wahl, das bist unter anderem du, und sagen, was ist denn das hier? Jede Sau kann sehen, was ich bei dir für ein Podcast höre.
Klar, ist kein Problem, ich schreib einfach jeden Internet-User an und sag ihm, dass es jetzt einfach mal stattzufinden hat.
Ich verstehe, es ist schon ein bisschen provokant, aber ich wende jetzt mal dieselben Argumente dir gegenüber an, mit denen du teilweise auch hausieren gehst.
Mich musst du überhaupt nicht überzeugen. Ich will das natürlich selbstverständlich alles. Ich hab auch angefangen, das sozusagen jetzt mal zu checken, was denn Phase ist, und es ist halt problematisch. Ich hab jetzt zum Beispiel mit dem Subscrib-Button, den wir jetzt ja quasi released haben, der jetzt im Publisher drin ist, das ist jetzt noch nicht so fett in uns, weil wir noch nicht die Doku fertig haben und so, und auch nochmal gucken wollen, wie sich jetzt so die erste Phase so anlässt. Und es gibt halt schon so ein paar Webseiten, die halt HTTPS fahren. Und die sagen dann ja irgendwie Error, Fehler, tra la la.
Ja, dann fang doch klein an, nimmst du Logbuch, Netzpolitik, dir gehört eh bloß Aluhüte, und dann zack, easy peasy.
Was heißt das für eine Aluhüte? Das ist einfach mal ein totaler Hipster-Podcast.
Ich hab heute ein Provokant gefressen.
Könnte man nicht dann sozusagen noch einen HTTP-Feed machen, wo nur noch drin steht, Alter, upgrade dein Client. Wenn du diese Nachricht siehst, ist dein Client scheiße.
Wenn du diese Folge hörst, hast du immer noch dein SSL.
Genau, das ist es doch. Du machst ein Feed, wo so ein Podcast rausfällt, wo es irgendwie eine halbe Stunde nur...
Genau, und all diese Dinge müssen halt erstmal, dazu muss man Zeit finden und dann muss man dazu kommen. Ich hatte, wie volatil das alles manchmal ist, das hatte ich jetzt gerade irgendwie am Sonntag. Montag sollte ein Podcast rauskommen. Da saß ich dann hier noch nachts, hab das Ding irgendwie durchgehört und hab irgendwie geschnitten, hab Shownotes gemacht und alles und Pipapo.
Wird hier werden Podcasts geschnitten?
Manche Podcasts...
Hier wird zensiert?...
erhalten. Ne, zensiert wird es schon immer.
Das kann ja sein Gesicht, oder? Kann ich heute echt spielen?
Kann ich immer nur so Dinge reinschmeißen?
Ich bin müde.
Ich glaub, ich muss hier mal meine Elbogen anspitzen.
Ich kann das ja verstehen. Hier ist uns was. Ist schon aufregend, oder?
Immer wieder.
Auch nach all der Zeit.
Wie lange bist du jetzt eigentlich schon bei uns, Clemens?
Weiß ich nicht. Ja.
Gefühlt irgendwie ewig schon.
Mach du mal die Auswertung. Dein Voice ist viel häufiger drin in der Orphonik-Auswertung als meine.
Du kannst ja mal die aktuellen Statistiken bemühen, wer hier sozusagen die meisten Leviten, wie heißt das, Meriten? Nee, nee, so einfach so Teilnehmer-mäßig, wer so wie oft dabei war.
An dieser Stelle...
Hab ich ja relativ akkurat hier erfasst.
Ja, gewinnt Dennis. Natürlich gewinnt es Dennis.
Na, ich gewinne das.
Huckel und ich sind gelegentlich... Ja, das stimmt.
Huckel und ich sind gelegentlich im Urlaub. Ich war bisher bei 145 von 145 Sendungen dabei.
No shit.
Warum eigentlich?
Ich finde es geil.
Nee, wir haben einmal eine Sendung ohne dich gemacht. Die hat Max gefahren. Da warst du nicht da.
Doch, da war ich per Skype mit dabei. Das ist ein Eintrag in der Retributertabelle und deswegen zählt es. Ich war Gast. Ja, ich war sogar auch mal alleine hier, weil keiner gekommen ist.
Die Home Alone Folge. Kinder aufgeturft von euch und dann saß ich hier, hab eine 1,5 Stunde alleine ins Mikrofon reingeredet.
In Berlin ist es nicht so groß.
Okay, Dennis, aber keine Kritik, du bist auf jeden Fall solide auf Platz 2.
Mit wie viel Sendung?
127.
Das ist schon gut.
18 Sendungen verpasst?
Ja.
Aber Dennis ist ja auch quasi original Crew, da ist er sowieso im ersten Sitzung. Die, die später dazukamen, da können wir ja nie rankommen.
Ach, naja. Also wenn Dennis noch ein bisschen...
Da ist mehr als zehn Prozent verpasst.
Ja, kannst mal sehen. So, dann dritter Platz.
Zu auf die Schwänze.
Max.
Immer noch.
Hallo Max.
Genau.
Der hat bestimmt langeweilig bei Facebook gehört zu.
94 Sendungen hat er hier beigewohnt. Genau. Weiß nicht, Max hörst du zu? Hallo.
Zuck mal mit in den Button.
Klick mal den Like-Button von meiner Freak Show.
Das hält's in der Diaspora. Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder es interessiert dir überhaupt nicht mehr, was in Deutschland abgeht. Durchaus denkbar.
Nö, er kommentiert das ja immer im Twitter.
Was, unsere Sendung?
Nee, aber was hier so abgeht in Deutschland.
Ach so, die aktuellen Gates. Und jetzt sozusagen ein bisschen außer Konkurrenz, aber durchaus auch erwähnenswert, mit 85 Kontributionen, David, unser Held des Previouslys. Auch heute wieder einmal, ja. Hat jetzt hier irgendwie sage und schreibe schon 85 Mal ein Intro geliefert. Das finde ich schon ganz schön solide. So, und dann kommt aber auch schon Hucke mit 84. Und Roddy hat 57 Sendungen im Tank.
So viele schon?
Ja, kannst du mal sehen. Du kannst schon einen veteranen Hemd anziehen oder sowas. Da bist du völlig von den Socken. Clemens hat 33. Und alles plus eins jetzt nochmal.
Aber das ist ja dann quasi heute.
Plus heute, genau. So sieht es aus. Und dann haben wir noch so, wie viele Gäste hatten wir? Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn, elf.
Warum haben wir heute eigentlich wen Gast?
Weil voll ist.
Konnte er ja nicht wissen.
Hat ja keiner abgesagt. Wir müssen ihn mal wieder am Stich lassen.
21 Gäste hatten wir schon.
Ist da Max dabei als Gast oder nicht?
Stimmt, wir hatten Max ja mal als Gast hier.
Ja, man kann Max dann auch noch mal als Gast zählen. Zum 22, dann können wir aber auch Clemens noch mal als Gast zählen. 23, du warst dann in der Hinsicht auch mal Gast.
Ja, da müssen wir bei euch aber auch jeweils wieder einatzen.
Und Hucke ja auch. Also insofern 25. Ja, stimmt.
Und mein Lieblingsgast, ohne die Leistung der anderen Gäste schmälern zu wollen, war glaube ich Falk. Das war auch sehr cool, weil der hat die ganze, der hat ja so viel erzählt, interessante Sachen die ganze Zeit.
Vor allen Dingen hat er den Papierkorb zerlegt.
Den Papierkorb zerlegt?
Na, hat den so niedergemacht, den neuen Mac Pro. Oder den aktuellen Mac Pro.
Ich finde eigentlich alle Gäste mal cool, weil da ein bisschen was anderes hier reinkommt.
Aber ganz oft, zumindest zuletzt, war es so, am Anfang unterhalten wir uns ganz viel mit denen und dann kriegen wir die nicht mehr ins Gespräch rein.
Das stimmt nicht.
Kommt auf den Gast an.
Das kommt immer so drauf an. Also hier Fabien hat irgendwie die ganze Sendung unterhalten. Vier Maschen pro Pixel heißt die Sendung. Sehr hörenswert. Ich sag nur, das Orchidarium mit Realtime-Wetterzuspielungen aus Costa Rica. Ja, da ging die Temperatur schon Richtung 0 Kelvin langsam. Genau, also wir bedanken uns einfach mal, wie das ganz angemessen ist zu dieser Zeit und am Jahresende und überhaupt bei allen, die mal hier waren und auch denen, die noch kommen werden. Ich schätze mal, das Gästemodell, das werden wir im nächsten Jahr mal ein bisschen fortführen.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich hoffe, dass wir uns jedes Mal erfrischen.
Genau, ich habe auch schon ein paar auf der Liste und weitere werden folgen.
So und zurück zum SSL-Thema. Du hast so schön gelenkt.
Wir waren da fertig und Tim hat am Anfang gesagt, er wollte das, damit er es nicht vergisst, gleich am Anfang machen, nämlich was?
Danke Dennis. Bisher bist du wirklich ein Veteran. Wir haben hier ganz viel, also ich habe eine Kritik, bei all dem Dank gleich eine Kritik. Wir haben viel.
Wir mampfen zu wenig in der Sendung.
Geh mit, du Scheiße.
Wir haben da jetzt sage und schreibe zwei Kisten voll mit Weihnachtskuchen.
Und wo ist jetzt die Kritik? Das gehört auch dazu. Du hast gerade die Samsung-Decke weggeschmissen.
Ja, hier gibt es eine Samsung-Decke.
Ist die Touch? Kann man damit touchen?
Nein, aber soft ist sie. Die Samsung-Pflüsch-Decke. Und das hier ist auch von Samsung.
Haselnüsse von Samsung?
Da muss ich mich jetzt noch mal besonders...
Ja, also...
Sehr kühl.
Ach, eine Hasennuss-Knacke.
Haselnuss, ist aber ein Hasennuss. Kein Haselnuss.
Ja, das sind alles so Samsung-Werbegeschenke. Die werden bei uns dann hier immer so entrecycelt. Dafür vielen Dank an Marco, der mir im Übrigen, du weißt wer du bist, sowieso immer eine ganze Menge hilft. So auch gerade eben noch mal hier kurz vor der Sendung. Das mit den Samsung-Werbegeschenken muss ich sagen, finde ich ein bisschen... Das hat ja was von Trollen. Willst du knacken oder was? Clemens wird zum Nussknacker.
So, jetzt rascheln die Decke nicht mehr.
Okay, also der Rest ist im Wesentlichen Lebkuchen ohne Ende.
In diesen Lebkuchen.
Und bevor ihr euch mit den Lebkuchen verdinkt, erinnert ihr euch noch letztes Jahr an die Kekse.
Ja, die waren gut.
Die waren gut und da gibt es jetzt nämlich wieder ein Update.
Revision 2.
Genau, ich hab das jetzt hier alles ein bisschen zusammengeschmissen und krieg das jetzt im Einzelnen nicht mehr zusammengedinkt. Also neben der ganzen Lebkuchenschwemme und der Samsung Werbegeschenk-Entlagung.
Ich hab sie ja von Nürnberger Lebkuchen.
Die anderen sind alle gefälscht.
Die Kekse sind gut, damit könnte man mal aufmachen. Außerdem gibt es hier noch ein Sonderpaket aus der Schweiz.
Ja, Schweiz ist auch gut. Die können das mit der Schokolade. Da steht mein Name drauf, ich sehe es genau.
Wir haben einen Hörer in der Schweiz.
Dennys, da hab ich überhaupt gar keinen.
Toblerode ist mein Middle Name.
Schweiz ist eine gute Einleitung für mein Thema.
Lass uns doch einfach mal alle durcheinander reden.
Machen wir doch schon. Wirklich.
Ich bedanke mich jetzt hier mal im Akkord bei Alex aus München. Der hat sich hier, oh Mann, geht das jetzt die ganze Sendung über so?
Könnte ich sein.
Marco, tu das nie wieder.
Tim hat gerade gesagt, er hätte gerne Sahnesprehdosen.
Darf ich jetzt?
Ich will jetzt erstmal hier meine Dankssagungen abmachen. Das komm ich doch hier. Die Sendung aus der Schweiz geht der Dank an Pascal, Kai, Robert und Dirk. Die hoffen, dass sich jetzt alle gemeinsam nebeneinander auf dem Sofa sitzen, ein Bierchen in der Hand und so und Freak Show hören. Oder so stelle ich mir das jetzt gerade vor.
Hinter der Schweiz auch, nicht?
Der Dieter Thomas Heckhahn ist schneller.
Ihm macht die Haare im Kuchen Kuchen, Kuchen, Räschli.
Der Dieter Thomas Heckhahn hat ja auch keiner dazwischen gequatscht.
Der hat mich nur nicht gehört, das ist alles.
Tim, wir machen jetzt CDMA, CD. Wenn du nicht auf... Wenn du offerst zu sabbeln, müssen wir halt dazwischen.
Ich mache euch gleich die Mikrofone aus. Äh, so hier. Noch mehr Lebkuchen von Peter, auch aus München. Irgendwie scheint es in München eine besondere Affinität zu geben. Genau. Die jährliche Kicks-Lieferung geht zurück auf Jan und Dagmar. Ich hoffe, das habe ich jetzt richtig gelesen. Als Motivation und Stärkung für den Kongress.
Fuck yeah.
Und wir sollen ja auch nächstes Jahr wieder weitermachen.
Darf ich trotzdem Kekse kriegen, obwohl ich nicht zum Kongress gehe?
So, hier werden triste Stunden auf der Autobahn versüßt von uns. Da geht der Dank an Klaus.
Keine Kekstüte.
Und?
Bis jetzt habe ich keine Kekstüte.
Muss ich mal etwa mit dir teilen?
Eine weitere Dosis erhalten wir von Christian aus Großheubach, wo auch immer das sein mag. Wir können das ja mal eruieren. Mal gucken, ob Großheubach schon in Google Earth in 3D ist. Ich habe nämlich festgestellt, dass ja der Google hat ja seine Google Earth Darbietung. Die Google Earth Performance irgendwann in diesem Jahr sichtlich verbessert. Mir ist das gar nicht aufgefallen, dass die jetzt diese ganze 3D-Nummer, das ist bestimmt schon eine Weile, oder?
Die Kabe Bauwerke errichtet im Herbst in meinem Landsitz. Die sind drauf. Also müssen und waren letztes Jahr im Herbst gewesen sein.
In 3D, oder?
Ne, 3D hab ich jetzt gar nicht probiert. Aber überhaupt, dass sie überhaupt Google Earth neue Fotos gemacht haben oder neue Fotos einspielen von oben.
Okay, ja, das machen sie.
Du hast Bauwerke errichtet. Sprichst du jetzt vom Vogelhäuschen, oder was?
So gut ist die Auflösung von Google Earth dann auch wieder noch nicht.
Ne, aber das Bemerkenswerte ist, dass sie jetzt dieselbe 3D-Gebäude, Hallo, dieselbe 3D-Gebäudetechnik verwenden wie Apple. Sprich dieses, wir fliegen mal schräg rüber und fotografieren alles aus allen erdenklichen Winkeln.
Aber Apple hat sich doch die Bude gekauft.
Na ja, das ist ja sicherlich nicht die Einzigen, die auf diese Idee gekommen sind.
Wassergeier wäre da...
Ja, aber wenn die Technologie erst mal erfunden ist?
Ja, vielleicht haben sie es ja lizenziert, ich habe keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall sieht das jetzt ordentlich aus, weil Google Earth war ja immer so ein wirres, so ein wirrer Misch aus Plattland plus irgendwelchen komischen 3D-Modellen und das ging ja gar nicht. Und wenn man sich jetzt mal so Berlin hier anschaut, wobei man sagen muss, die Detailauflösung scheint mir durchgehend nicht so hoch zu sein wie bei Apple. Also wenn Apple so eine Stadt abliefert wie Berlin...
Na, die müssen ja auch 100 Mal mehr Daten ausliefern.
Ja, das hat ja auf die Daten jetzt keinen Einfluss. Du kannst ja die Daten trotzdem hochauflösender generieren. Ob die dann auch wirklich angeflogen werden, ist ja noch mal eine ganz andere Geschichte.
Aber vielleicht hat Google eine höhere Cameridge.
Leute, ihr seid doch nicht so geil jetzt auf Haselnüsse, dass ihr jetzt hier wirklich die durchknacken müsst. Wird sie nicht nur geschmatzt, jetzt wird auch noch geknackt.
Die Kekse, die wir mal aufgepuppelt haben, sind ja auch schon wieder weg.
Mit so einem spitzbübschen Hacker-Gesicht.
Das war ja ein provokantes Frühstück.
Auf jeden Fall kann sich...
Pass auf, sonst legen wir die gleich deinen Finger in den...
Das ist C-Base, oder?
Ja, du destabilisierst Roddy. Na ja, auf jeden Fall über Berlin fliegen, das kennt man jetzt schon. Und ich habe auch zugespielt bekommen, dass unter anderem auch die Metropole, die international anerkannte Metropole Hannover, ebenfalls in dreidimensionalen Daten vorliegt. Das ist erstaunlich. Und ich bin immer wieder überrascht, was für einen unfassbaren Unterschied das doch macht, im Vergleich zu einfach nur plattesatelliten Bild mit so ein bisschen Höheninformation versus alle Details aller Gebäude.
Macht jetzt aber Hannover nicht besser.
Naja, ich meine, ich habe da jetzt quasi Bezucht. Du bist ja da als Berliner besser dran.
Weil wir keinen Bezucht haben?
Ihr seid ja alle Berliner, wa? Ja, sicher.
Naja, ich habe meine Schulzeit in München verbracht.
Nicht nur geboren. Nee, das meine ich nicht. Ich gebe dir eine offizielle Definition, wenn du wieder nach dem Stock im Arsch blutest. Gebürtig und geboren gibt ja noch einen Unterschied. Gebürtig bist du denn dort, wenn auch deine Eltern dort geboren sind. Sonst bist du dann nur geboren.
Meine Eltern sind ja nicht geboren.
Bei mir im ersten, zweiten Grad ist in Berlin... Ich muss zu Weihnachten nirgends wohin, außer von Bezirk zu Bezirk.
Na gut, dann sind jetzt alle unsere irgendwie erdenklichen Heimat- und Anwesenheitsstädte komplett in 3D.
Alle beide.
Alle drei.
Ich hatte es eben kurz beim drüber fliegen Dristen auf dem Radar. Haben sie das auch? Kann man da die Pegidas-Pralos sehen?
Du kannst ja unsere Teilzeit-Wahlheimat Hamburg noch.
Genau, ja Hamburg.
Hamburg, da kriegen wir gleich mal an.
Ich mach mal ein paar Kekse da raus.
Ich hab übrigens die Rolls-Royce-Tasten auch scharf geschaltet. Ihr könntet durchaus die Hörer etwas verschonen zum Ende des Jahres.
Sag Bescheid, wenn du knisterst.
Wir brauchen aber beide Hände, um das da rauszuprücken.
Jetzt schüttet euch halt ein paar von Kekse.
Ja, Dresden gibt's auch einen 3D-Kick an. Scheint ja ganz ordentlich ausgebaut zu sein.
Mach's mal ohne Tisch, dann ist es nicht so laut.
Schön fand ich ja heute die Forderung.
Wie war das?
Jetzt muss ich gleich nochmal kicken. So knacken ja nicht mehr. Auf Twitter fragte einer, ist eigentlich Mittelschichtler gegen Migranten und andere Mitmenschen schon vergeben? Das wär auch mal eine Demo, wa? Tja, also in Dresden gibt es auch ein 3D. Ich sehe aber jetzt hier gerade keine Demo. Wir erwarten uns etwas mehr Widerstand aus Dresden, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf. Jetzt wo ihr schon in 3D seid.
Wo ist denn Ihre Weltkultur-Aberkennungsbrücke?
Das ist die Weltkultur-Aberkennungsbrücke?
Hätte man auffälliger bauen können.
Ich finde das ja nicht so schlimm mit der Brücke. Die ist es ja. Ja, ist immer schön, wenn man so visuelle Eindrücke...
Die ist jetzt nicht so schick.
Noch ein bisschen Baustelle drumrum, aber es ist ja auch schon ein bisschen alt.
Ja, mittlerweile läuft es.
Und so viel schlechter als die anderen Brücken sieht jetzt auch nicht aus.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich finde ja auch Brücken und Kulturlandschaften, das geht schon zusammen.
Vor allem da hinten das blaue Wunder.
Also warum jetzt irgendwie dieses eine, das einzige Brückchen da, das blaue Wunder ist auch sehr hübsch. Das ist überhaupt alles sehr hübsch da.
Die Brücke heißt das blaue Wunder?
Ja, das ist das blaue Wunder. Weil die blau ist.
Weil sie blau ist.
Ein Wunder ist, weil das blaue Wunder war halt ein Engineering Feed, das hat irgendwie das blaue Wunder heißt.
Vor 150 Jahren oder was?
Ja, ich guck grad mal, wann die gebaut wurde. Lalalala.
Wir sind ja auch ein Podcast für Technik-Begeißete.
Äh, nee, Quatsch, warte mal, falscher. Blaues Wunder, genau, hier haben wir es.
Finde ich knackertoll, darf ich den haben?
1912.
Sag mal ne Zahl zwischen 1 und 100.
Und dann?
Ich wollte jetzt ja eigentlich den Kindern vermachen.
37.
Falsch, so. Hast du echt faire Chancen gehabt? Ich nehm den jetzt mit. Wie kleine Kinder? Die klemmen sich bloß die Finger dran. Guck, das ist voll der Fingerklemmer. Hier, da, da, siehst du? Das ist jeder Nusskacker. Das ist nicht zugelassen für Kinder.
Das ist auch für Tims Kinder.
Ja, Samsung-Kinder können sich die Finger dran klemmen, aber wir hier ist das verboten.
Ne, deren Finger sind zu klein.
Selber Schuld hättest du ahnen können.
Ja, wir klären das.
Du hättest es doch am Ende der Sendung rausholen sollen. Das ist Captain Heinzeit.
Aber wo wir sowieso schon mal dabei sind, also damit ihr wisst, was es alles gibt, es gibt hier noch eine Kiste. Wie muss man das jetzt aussprechen hier? Batons, Kirsch, Stängeli. Man könnte ja auch Pralinen dazu sagen in langer Form.
Oder ist da wieder irgendein Schmuddel drin?
Schuki mit Alohol, 64, zarte Schokolade.
64% Promille.
Flüssig gefüllt mit Schweizer Kirsch.
Na ja, wer will auspacken?
Jetzt ist hier noch mit rascheln erst mal kommen.
Ach jetzt ist es auf einmal ein Problem, nachdem man die ganzen Kekstüten schon aufgerissen hat.
Du hast gesagt, wir sollen die aufreißen.
Es geht noch schlimmer. Sie haben extra draufgeschrieben, sie hätten alles getestet vorher. Wahrscheinlich sitzen sie jetzt mit so einem identischen Set auf ihrem Sofa.
Erst mal getestet, was davon am lautesten ist.
Guck mal, das heißt Zweifel. Erinnert ihr euch noch an diese großartige Kunstinstallation auf dem damaligen Palast der Republik, als das Ding schon leer stand. Und dann war da so für ein Jahr oder so standen da wirklich oben fette Buchstaben auf dem Palast der Republik drauf. Da stand einfach nur Zweifel. Das fand ich die drittschönste Kunstinstallation in Berlin, die ich je gesehen habe.
Und die anderen beiden?
Blinkenleids.
Tim, die eigenen erwähnt man natürlich nicht, wenn man Gentleman ist.
Hätte ich jetzt auch nicht gemacht. Na du hast sie jetzt erwähnt.
Ich hab sie nicht erwähnt.
Da hier, Dingens, hier, Rept Reichstag fand ich groß.
Rept Reichstag war lustig.
Weil das war einfach top. Ich saß da selber davor und ich muss sagen, ich war echt verzaubert von dieser Installation.
Aber warte, ich war ja nicht vor Ort.
Ich dachte immer, was kann man sich da über so ein verpacktes Ding so freuen? Aber hast du auch gedacht, vorher dachtest du, was ist der Scheiß? Da bist du mal hin und willst dich zu überzeugen. Und dann plötzlich, wow, ist ja doch ganz geil, so ungefähr.
Och, ich hätte da jetzt keine negative Grundhaltung.
Aber so eine ist mir eigentlich Egalhaltung, weil es ist nur so ein verpackter Reichstag.
Ja, aber was interessant war, war eben das Gesamtpaket. Die Gesamtsituation mit den Leuten.
Genau.
Die das Happening draus gemacht haben, die die Party gemacht haben.
Erstmal haben sie es wirklich sehr gut gemacht. Also sie haben da nicht ja irgendwie Stoff draufgehauen. Sie haben da so einen ganz speziellen silbrigen, glitzerigen Stoff extra für ausgesucht.
Ich habe immer noch so ein Fetzen davon. Irgendwo habe ich noch einen.
Und sie haben das Ding auch perfekt eingepackt. Also es war jetzt nicht einfach nur so drauf geworfen, sondern es war dann auch so zugezucht und zugedings. Es sah einfach geil aus wie so ein dickes, fettes Weihnachtsgeschenk im Prinzip. Und das war einfach so absurd, weil dieser Reichstag war dann irgendwie weg und wurde ersetzt durch dieses Weihnachtsgeschenk. Da stand dann einfach so mitten auf der Wiese und dann haben sich irgendwie alle Berliner dort eingefunden. Das war einfach so ein krasses Happening, so richtig schön Berlin. Wir finden uns geil, setzen uns jetzt hier auf eine Wiese, grillen aufgestellt, feiern uns mit unserem Präsent hier, was einer hingeworfen hat und dann wird da gegrillt. Das war super und es war einfach geile Stimmung da. Das war einfach toll. Das hat einfach was bewirkt.
Naja, aber die Wiese war eigentlich immer Happening.
Es war schon anders. Also ich erinnere mich noch sehr gut, dass ich wirklich da bewusst rumsass und da dachte ich so, wow, hier liegt echt ein Zauber auf dieser Situation.
Und eine Wolke drüber wahrscheinlich auch.
Nee, es war ja auch super Wetter und so. Und es war ja auch eins der ersten Projekte, wo es so eine Dauerwebcam gab. Also sie haben ja wirklich das Ding über die komplette Zeit.
Es gab da noch so Sendung mit der Maus-mäßig Zeitraffer, wie sie das Ding ein oder ausgewickelt haben.
Das ist sicherlich noch irgendwo im Netz. Vielleicht kann der Chat mal gucken. Reistag und vor allem diese Animation.
Es ist ja verboten, Bilder vom verpackten Reispark online zu packen, oder? War da nicht irgendwas?
Na, es ist verboten, da Fotos als Postkarten zu verkaufen, weil blablabla, Urheberrecht und so weiter. Andere Diskussionen. Auf jeden Fall gibt es Chips. Chippes von Zweifel. Und außerdem gibt es Bier. Und ich habe auch schon das erste hier getrunken. Und zwar heißt das...
Hopfab. Würde ich das aussprechen.
Ja, stimmt.
Hopfab.
Also ich hätte es jetzt als Chopfab auch noch gedeuten können, aber CHOP.
Doppel...
Doppeloi.
Was heißt das hier?
Bauwerkstatt. Na ja, ist nett. Ist ein schönes Bier, ich kann das sehr empfehlen.
Was ist denn das von einer Sorte Bier her?
Ein Helles.
Ein Helles, ein Blondes. Gib da mal so ein Ding da her.
Ein kühles Blondes.
Ja, gib her.
Das steht aus Wasser, Gerstenmalz und Hopfen.
Ja, Typ Münchner Hell.
Fünf Prozent. Also sowas mag ich sehr gern.
Lettöl.
Die Kirschstängel sind auch sehr nett.
Wir haben jetzt aber ein Problem.
Was denn?
64 von diesen Stängel lassen sich nicht durch fünf teilen.
Du kannst es gerne, ich partizipiere daran nicht.
Ja, durch vier geht's.
Das sind für jeden 16.
Auf geht's. So, auf jeden Fall ordentlich was da.
Gib mal einen.
Jetzt riechen die gleich wie alte Oma hier.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie deine Oma so riecht, aber...
So wie du gleich.
Es gibt noch eine zweite.
Nee, nee, nee, das musst du jetzt machen, sonst haben sie wieder ein Problem, weil die 64 kriegen sie wieder richtig beigeteilt.
Da muss noch einer passen.
Ja, 63 und einer fällt unter den Tisch.
Es gibt hier noch eine zweite Biersorte, ganz exklusiv in Dosen.
Brandlöscher.
Dosenbier, seriously, die Leute schicken uns Dosenbier.
Ich habe auch Vorbehalte gegen Dosenbier, aber neulich war ich wirklich überrascht. Und zwar wusstet ihr, dass es Guinness in Dosen gibt?
Es gibt jeden Pollbier in Dosen.
Und wisst ihr, was der Clou ist?
Die Art und Weise, wie es irgendwie schäumt, wenn man es ausgießt.
Ja, aber warum?
Ich habe es irgendwo mal gehört, aber ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Guinness ist ja ein bier, ein englisches Bier, oder brittisches, irisches Bier. Ja, Insel halt.
Die Irn.
Ja, aber unser Teil, nicht der von den...
Ist egal, die Zapfmethode ist auf jeden Fall überall dasselbe auf der Insel. Das heißt, da wird dann die Kohlensäure erst beim Zapfen wirklich hinzugegeben. Das ist ja der Clou. Da fragt man sich natürlich jetzt, wie das bitte mit einem Dosenbier funktionieren soll. Der Clou ist, dass sie da so eine Plastikkugel reinlegen. Ernsthaft, also die Guinness-Dosen haben so eine Plastikkugel drin. Wenn du die Dose öffnest, gibt das Ding irgendwie kollabiert das Ding und gibt irgendwie die Kohlensäure frei und dann kriegst du in dem Moment einfach genau diesen Schaum-Effekt wie beim Zapfen. Und das ist so, dass das Guinness aus Dosen mit dieser Technik besser schmeckt, deutlich, als Guinness in Flaschen, von denen ich nicht sicher bin, ob es das noch gibt. Aber es gab es mal. Was irgendwie halt auch nicht richtig geht. Gibt es noch. Und das war also wirklich erstaunlich, was da aus dieser Dose rauskam. Es gibt da auch irgendeine Bezeichnung dafür, die habe ich aber jetzt vergessen. Floating Widget heißt das.
So groß ist die Kugel.
Das gibt es auch für Bierflaschen. Ach, guck an.
Warum gibt es das nicht für Cola?
Weil es bei Cola egal ist. Da kannst du das halt auch vorher reinpressen. Floating Widget. Also wenn du so die Dose in der Hand hast, dann macht die so klackadiklack. Aber ich glaube hier Appenzeller Brandlöscher ist eher klassisch. Löschmittellagerbier. Dieses Bier bekämpft Kehl, Brände, Schnelle und Wirksam. Das Ganze sieht aus so ein bisschen wie so eine... Das ist lustig hier.
Apropos Tim, hast du eigentlich einen Feuerlöscher im Studio?
Ja, aber ich habe den glaube ich falschen gekauft.
Hast du Schaum oder was?
Guckst du mal, wenn uns nicht das Wikipedia anlügt, dann steht da drin, dass die da Stickstoff drin haben unter Druck und dass du das nur dafür benutzt, damit das Ding in der Flasche rumzwirbelt wie Sau. Aber da ist kein Kohlendioxid drin, was dir dein Bier aufsprudelt. Da unten, beim Öffnen fällt der Druck in der Dose.
Lösch mit Lagerbier.
So, dass sich nun durch die Dose bewegt. Das heißt, dadurch wird viel cremiger Schaum produziert.
Ah, okay, ich habe Scheiß erzählt, egal. Auf jeden Fall schmeckt es besser. Ja, ich weiß. Ihr habt wahrscheinlich schon kommentiert, jetzt hört ihr diese Stelle, und der Kommentar ist schon freigeschaltet.
Ihr habt ja Recht.
Aber ich finde, bis zum Ende der Sendung kann man auch schlauer werden. Danach darf man draufbauen, oder?
Absolut.
So wie ich gestern letztes Mal mit der Final Cut-Trial. Aber mir haben ja Leute geschrieben, dass das noch nicht immer gab.
Und haben mich rehabilitiert zumindest. Wir sind ja eigentlich nur Informationskatalysatoren. Wir thematisieren irgendwas. Und durch unsere Gerede kommt dann irgendwann mal die Wahrheit raus.
Wir legen den Finger in die Wunde.
Genau, in unsere eigene.
In unsere halbwissende Wunde.
Wir ziehen die Themenkarte und der Hörer muss den Rest senden.
So, dann gibt es hier noch ein Päckchen Ricola. Da wird es auch richtig schön.
Das ist zum Wiederherstellen des Atems.
Hier gibt es noch was zum Verhindern von Banküberfällen. So dicke 400 Gramm Milch, Schokolade, Tafel.
Der zolltet eigentlich nicht beschlagnahmt.
Damit kannst du bestimmt ordentlich einen Dates geben.
Warum hat der zolltet eigentlich nicht beschlagnahmt? Haben die das direkt aus der Schweiz geschickt oder haben sie selber über die Grenze geschmuggelt und in einer deutschen Post aufgegeben?
Die sind aber einzeln eingepackt, insofern ist es nicht so schlimm.
Ja, passt schon. Dann müssen wir die jetzt alle aufessen, die auf dem Boden liegen.
Apropos Zoll, bei mir hat es die Post geschafft, den Brief vom Zoll irgendwie von einem Postamt in Berlin zu einem anderen Postamt in Berlin in zwei Wochen zu schicken. Und dann war ich am nächsten Tag beim Zoll, als ich ihn hatte, und da haben die das Paketstunden vorher schon wieder zurückgeschickt.
Und da du jetzt nicht beweisen kannst, dass die so lange gebraucht haben, geht das auf deine Kosten. Lass mich raten.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich hab noch nichts davon gehört, wie das. Ich hab mich erstmal bei der Post beschwert, und dann meinte er, ja, vielleicht kann man noch was machen, wenn das Paket noch nicht lange unterwegs ist.
Was teuer ist aber, was wirklich mich immer wieder in Verzückung versetzt, ist ja, wenn aus Übersee mit sowas wie TNT, FedEx oder UPS was verschickt wird und es einfach manchmal am nächsten Tag da ist. Das ist einfach so geil, wenn du sagst, hier übrigens deine Tracking-Nummer, guckst du, ist schon im Flieger, irgendwie wachst morgens auf, ist schon in Berlin und irgendwie noch mal einen halben Tag später im Fahrzeug und auf dem Weg. Da sitze ich jedes Mal da und denk mir, oh, geil. Das Beste war ja wirklich damals...
Kannst du manchmal selber nicht schneller machen, selbst wenn du hinfliegen würdest.
Ja, und irgendwie hatte ich ja auch schon mal vor Ewigkeiten erzählt, als ich mir so Free-Sample-Chips von Texas Instruments und so bestellt habe. Also, kann man ja immer machen bei diesen Elektronik-Bauteilherstellern. Da habe ich mir da was geklickt und die haben das per FedEx auch 24 Stunden am nächsten Tag, da hatte ich da meine LED-Driver in der Post. Das war irgendwie... Mich hat es nichts gekostet. Also, das ist wirklich... Dann könnte ich DHL was mal abschneiden.
Von einem Privattyp in Amiland gekauft, und dann hat es, glaube ich, zwei Wochen gedauert, bis es überhaupt erstmal in einer größeren Stadt ist, die man auf der Landkarte sehen kann.
Ja, wenn die das halt einfach mit US-Mail oder Priority-Mail schicken.
Ja, und die dann in so einem 100-Einwohner-Cuff leben, dann dauert das halt eine Weile. Ich sag ein großes Land.
Ich bin dann glücklich mit DHL.
Ja, die handeln aber zum Beispiel aus Übersee, wenn irgendwas dann, zum Beispiel Priority-US-Mail, glaube ich, kommt, öfters dann mit DHL auf der letzten Meile an. Und da, wenn die das, also TNT und die anderen, die kümmern sich halt vorher um den Zollkram. Die sagen ja auch schon per Mail, Achtung, hier so und so viel Zoll und wir kommen kassieren und haben das mal in den Cash-Stack.
Aber nur, wenn die auf der anderen Seite das auch so einreichen mit Wertangabe und so, ne?
Ja, aber bei, zum Beispiel, weiß nicht, die DHL-Jungs, da hatte ich das noch nie. Also was die machen ist, wenn du beim Zoll schon was liegen hast und du schickst dem Zoll, ja guten Tag, das ist das Gerät und hier ist die Rechnung, bitte schick das mal weiter, dann schicken sie DHL auf die Reise und kassieren das vor deine Kühe.
Ich hab ja früher so einen Dienst genutzt namens Border Links. Ist glaube ich auch eine DHL-Tochter.
Du hast auch zu Zeiten, wo es die iPhones nicht in Deutschland gab, da wurde das bekannt.
Ja, da hab ich es auch benutzt, aber ich hatte das vorher schon, hab jetzt lange nichts mehr drüben eingekauft, aber...
Das sind die Proxy-Adressen.
Genau, das habt ihr halt so eine Proxy-Adresse in UK und US und so. Wenn da irgendwas einschlägt bei denen, dann schreiben die mir eine Mail und dann mit so einem Link, dann soll ich da auf so ein Formular draufklicken und reinschreiben, was das ist, also selber deklarieren notfalls noch, was das angemachtet ist, Wertangaben machen und dann schubbeln die das hier durch. Irgendwie so verzollen und so und so und scharf.
Haben die Hörer eigentlich auch so...
Nein, haben sie nicht.
Siehst du, jetzt weißt du, warum wir HTTBS brauchen für den Chess-Win.
Noch Fragen?
Ich wollte auch noch an meine Geschichte von letzte Woche anknüpfen. Und zwar habe ich ja da von meiner Amazon-Misere erzählt, dass irgendwie die Wunschliste überhaupt gar nicht mehr ging. Und ich da so eine Stunde mit denen telefoniert habe. Meine Freundin hatte da auch ein bisschen rumgespielt. Das gleiche Problem hat aber einfach mal den Support angeschrieben. Der hat, ich glaube, relativ schnell eine Stunde oder ziemlich schnell auf jeden Fall zurückgeschrieben und meinte, ja, da musst du klicken, da musst du dann die Adresse für deine Wunschliste einstellen und bumm, dann geht's. Und so habe ich es gemacht und dann geht es. Das heißt, da wo ich die Stunde mit dem Support telefoniert habe, die mich auch schon weiter durchgereicht haben, die wussten das anscheinend nicht und ja, ganz schön traurig. Wunschliste geht jetzt auf jeden Fall wieder.
Kaum macht man es richtig, geht das auch schon.
Ja, es war ganz easy, sah aus, als wenn es schon immer so ging. Also ich weiß nicht, warum die das da nicht wussten. Vielleicht war es auch zu einfach und sie sind nicht draufgekommen. Jedenfalls ist jetzt eine Menge angekommen bei mir auch. Muss ich mich auch bedanken. Aber ich habe noch einen kleinen Vorschlag, weil da war einer sehr großzügig. Wenn man sehr großzügig ist, dann nicht viele kleine Sachen nehmen, sondern mal eine große Sache nehmen, weil sonst gehen die ja nicht weg. Das macht ja mehr Sinn. Ja, weil sonst große Sachen macht man ja eher selten. Und wenn dann schon einer so großzügig ist, dann eine große Sache. War natürlich trotzdem toll, ich will jetzt nicht rumnörgeln, aber ich wollte es immer gesagt haben.
Es gibt noch Optimierungsprojekte.
Seitdem ich seit der letzten Folge auch die Amazon-Wunschliste verlinkt hatte, kamen tatsächlich auch Sachen an. Also der Andreas Baum hier aus dem Abgeordnetenhaus, der hat mir auch ein sehr großzügiges Geschenk geschickt. Na toll, jetzt muss ich dir eine Mail schreiben und die fragen, warum ich nichts kriege. Ja, und dann kamen ja noch so ein bisschen kleine Zeichen, zum Beispiel auch, was ich schon länger auf meiner Wunschliste habe, was man auch nach Herrn der Weihnachtsmann-Sektion empfehlen könnte, einen Stromzähler hier zum in die Dose stecken und gucken, was so die Geräte verbrauchen. Das ist ja hier auch immer mal wieder ein populäres Thema. Da hab ich nämlich auch letztens mal geguckt, was es da Schönes eigentlich gibt und hab mir dann die Schönsten ausgesucht und dann kamen wir jetzt einer von an auch. Und auch dafür vielen herzlichen Dank.
Ist das so ein Teil, das dann auch gleich das irgendwie abstrahlt per Daten?
Ich hab das bei mir mit. Es gibt jetzt für die Hausstörungen, die ich benutze, ich benutze ja so Kombinationen, unter anderem eben HOMATIC. Und von HOMATIC gibt es auch so einen Zwischenstecker, der ist ja nicht so teuer, kostet 35 Euro oder so. Ist also so eine Steckdose, die ich da fernschalten kann, die aber auch Stromverbrauch misst, aber auch Spannung, Strom und Frequenz, der auch sagt. Damit hab ich jetzt mal das, was ich so in meinem Landsitz habe, mal so durchgepollt, so einmal Waschmaschine laufen lassen, was macht das, einmal Spielmaschine laufen lassen, was macht das und so. Hab das mal notiert, das ist ganz lehrreich. Den kann man fern abfragen, könnt ihr jetzt von hier abfragen, könnt ihr jetzt da einen Heizlüfter anmachen und dir sagen, was der in dem Moment verbraucht.
Genau, das Ding, was ich jetzt hab, das macht's halt ohne Fernsteuerung, aber ich wollte halt überhaupt erst mal so anfangen, so ein bisschen zu gucken. Was für ein Ding ist das denn? Ich suche ja grad schon den Link hier, und zwar das Kopielink ab in den Chat. BW1FAEH0, vielen Dank für deine Geschenke.
War das jetzt auch so ein Code, mit dem Terroranschlag rausgelöst wird?
Und der andere, die haben alle so komische Twitter-Namen, der war auch sehr lieb und hat mir was geschickt. Ich hoffe, ich hab jetzt keinen vergessen, verdammt. Habt ihr dazu, hast du jetzt den Link noch nicht geklickt? Klickt doch mal den Link.
Also ich hab auch schon seit längerem so ein Teil, allerdings das ist fast No Name, aber da gab's irgendwann mal von, ich glaub von der Testzeitschrift, gab's mal so ein Artikel über die Dinger, die hatten die getestet und viele von denen waren halt mehr so, ich halt mal den nassen Daumen in den Wind und das eine...
Die sind halt im unteren Bereich relativ schlecht, so unter 10 Watt sind die nicht so gut, aber darüber geht's eigentlich.
Nee, das Problem ist, dass die eigentlich nur für doof gemacht sind und obenste Leistungen nur vernünftig messen können. Wenn halt jetzt so was lustig geht, wie ein Schaltnetzteil da dran hast oder so was, dann ist es nicht notwendigerweise immer super akkurat, was daraus kommt.
Verstehe.
Was hast du denn noch mit Themen wie Wirkleistung, Scheinwirkleistung, lalalala...
Dann die mitten in der Welle wieder abschalten und so eine Sache oder wie?
Oder wenn du irgendwas mit Trafo dran hast, auch schon. Wie gesagt, eine omsche, Blindleistung, also omsche...
Omsche-pomsche.
Omsche-pomsche, ja. Der Tim hat auch sowas.
Ja, ich hab dieses Fritz Deck 200. Das ist diese über Deck schaltbare, aber eben auch von der Fritz-Box aus abfragbare Spekulose.
Die zeigt dir auch was.
Ist leider ein bisschen teuer, aber die haben wir jetzt nachgerüstet in den letzten Software-Versionen und zeigen dir da auch Stromverbrauch und Pipapo und alles an. Ja, das kann man sich dann irgendwie...
Aber noch eingeben, was die Kilowattstunde kostet, dann rechnet der gleich in Euro um.
Genau, das ist irgendwie ganz nett. Ich hab da noch nicht so richtig mit rumgespielt, weil das jetzt für mich mehr so ein Schalter ist. Aber...
Da stehen halbe V6-Adressen mitten im Chat.
Temperatur... Mister auch noch gleich, weil es so schön war.
Das macht der Kleint irgendwie irgendwas falsch da. Ja, ich wollte halt dieses Ding erstmal so haben, weil das eben auch diese ganzen Funktionen hat und dir alle möglichen Sachen da anzeigt. Und weil ich irgendwie... Ich hab ja mein Modem von Kabel Deutschland, als er das Netzteil irgendwann verschütt... Also, ist irgendwie durch, keine Ahnung. Dann hab ich ja so ein... Nee, so ein relativ fettes Netzteil, wo es auch bis...
Noch mit Spule zum Einstellen?
Nee, ja, geht bis 15 Volt hoch und so.
Und los einstellen.
Und mit Listerklemme das Kabel rein, dass du dir irgendwo an die Wand schraubst oder innen in den Schrank rein. Und dann dachte ich mir so, na ja, mal gucken, wie das jetzt eigentlich so ist. Funktioniert halt. Jetzt wollte ich halt mal ein paar Sachen auch im Haus. Weil das Ding ist, bei uns haben sie im Haus jetzt auch umgestellt, dass sozusagen der Stromzähler, dieser mit der Scheibe drin, der ist aus der Bude raus. Und das wird jetzt unten im Keller irgendwie alles da so zentral erfasst. Ja, vielleicht hab ich noch nicht geguckt. Ich dachte mir...
Weil sie einen kleinen Brief schreiben, dürfen sie nicht machen.
Ja, was?
Man muss als Mieter an seinen Zähler rankommen. Wenn die bei dir umbauen, dann musst du da rankommen. Alte Wohnungen sind, glaube ich, nicht betroffen. Aber wenn die das neu gemacht haben, dürfen sie dir den ja nicht einfach wegnehmen und du kommst da nicht mehr ran. Das geht nämlich gar nicht.
Was ich gesehen hab jetzt, aber es gibt so Stromzähler, die haben das Format von diesen Klicksicherungen, von diesen modernen... Ja, die du dir dann sozusagen davon...
Aber ich zu Hause baut mir nur keine ein, weil ich keine Hauptsicherung hab und ich hab da so 16 Quadratmillimeter Leitung. Und einer meint zu mir, wenn man da was falsch macht, dann fliegt einem das flüssige Kopf um die Ohren.
Du weißt, dass das Wichtigste ist? Immer eine Hand in der Hosentasche.
Ja, aber du brauchst da mit der Leitung auch nur irgendwas anderes berühren. Du musst ja nicht mal du selbst sein, aber wenn das irgendwas berührt...
Ja, lass das in den Elektro-Kanal.
Bei irgendwie 64 Ampere, dann wird alles flüssig.
Ja, da gibt's schon Lichtbogen.
Ich hab zu Hause so ein El-Tacu mit so einem kleinen Display drin, so schräg und kostet 40 Euro, glaube ich, oder ist das gar nicht so teuer?
Kommt darauf an, ob du einen Phasen- oder drei-Phasen-Zähler hast.
Nee, einen nur. Für einen Club, da haben wir drei Phasen, da haben wir gerade richtig teuer für 200 Euro oder so einen drei-Phasen-Zähler geholt, damit wir am Club jetzt mal ordentlich Strom messen können und da bauen wir dann demnächst noch eine Anzeige mit Energy-Gee oder so.
Ich hab ja folgendes gemacht, dass ich ja, ich wollte meinen Strom mal ablesen, aber ich hab gar nicht so viel Platz in meinem Sicherungskasten, auf meinem Landsitz, um da noch einen Zusätzzähler einzubauen. Hab jetzt auch kein Bock gehabt, da noch so ein Hutschiengehäuse uns danebenzusetzen, gerade in den Hauptpfad. Was das auch gibt, und das hab ich jetzt schon seit drei Jahren, über drei Jahren drin, und das ist relativ präzise, jedenfalls präzise genug, es gibt so optische Dinger, die kleben sich halt vorne auf die Scheibe drauf, weil die Scheibe hat ja so eine rote Markierung. Die zählen die, und das ist relativ zuverlässig, das Ding, was ich habe, das geht im Jahr vielleicht so 0,3, 0,4 Kilowattstunden falsch. Keine Ahnung, warum, weil es da reinbindet.
Aber wieso, wenn du schon dieses Scheibe hast, wofür brauchst du dann noch mal einen Zähler?
Nein, ich möchte es gerne elektronisch erfassen. Ich kann jetzt von hier auf meine Haussteuerung draufgehen, dir sagen, wie der Zählerstand ist. Und ich nutze das auch, um zum Beispiel zu gucken, ob noch...
Und den mit der Scheibe darfst du nicht selber ausbauen, um Platz zu kriegen.
Was bitte?
Den mit der Scheibe darfst du nicht selber ausbauen.
Das ist ja der offizielle, der offizielle Zähler. Der sitzt daneben, das ist der offizielle Zähler. Aber dadurch, dass das noninvasiv ist, weil du nämlich einfach auf die Scheibe oben drauf klebst, diesen Sensor, kannst du das auch mit dem offiziellen Zähler machen.
Es gibt noch diese Teile, die man um die Kabel selber klemmt. Ich weiß allerdings nicht, wie gut die funktionieren.
Ja, aber auch das ist wieder, dann musst du, erstens brauchst du ein bisschen Platz dafür. Also musst du auch ein ordentliches Stück Harm von dem Kabel, wo du Platz hast. Dann musst du diese Dinger, da musst du das auch alles auspacken, drum rumklemmen und so weiter. Das ist auch ein ganz schöner Film. Ich hab da lange überlegt, hab auch erst gedacht, was ist mit dieser Scheibe, wenn ich da mal Licht anmache an dem Raum, aber das funktioniert, wie gesagt, sehr gut. Der geht so, also der Zählerstand von dem offiziellen Zähler gegenüber meinem elektronischen ist so 0,3 oder 0,4 Kilowattstunde im Jahr geht der dann eben, das ist okay, da leb ich mit. So genau ist der ganze Zähler ja nicht.
Was mir gerade noch so einfällt hier zum Thema Wunschliste und Geschenke, hat irgendwie mir auch einer im Twitter kommentiert, hat irgendwie auf eine Folge von Vrindt verlinkt, wo Holgi meinte, er hätte gerade eine Steuersonderprüfung und muss die ganzen Hörergeschenke von seiner Wunschliste als Einnahmen versteuern.
Hört mal zu, um den nächsten Mal ein Flatter hier runterfliegt, wenn den Tim nicht schon links weggeräumt hat. Das ist zwar nett, aber das macht mir steuerlich mehr Arge als alles andere.
Kein Problem, ich kann ja meine eintragen.
Ja, ich persönlich finde das ja, also ich versteuere mein Flatter ja tatsächlich sogar ordentlich, weil dadurch kann ich halt auch wiederum auf der anderen Seite meinen ganzen Audiokram ja auch so absetzen und sagen, hier, ich habe ja hier, ich habe ja da Einnahmen drüber, ne?
Hast du denn eine Nebentätigkeitserlaubnis? Von deinem Arbeitgeber mein?
Alles. Ich habe sowieso diverse Nebentätigkeitserlaubnisse. Ich bin ja auch noch an der Uni beschäftigt. Also, das ist kein Problem.
Was du alles bist.
Macht ein Tipp dabei. Werder Bremensch wird jetzt so mit seinem Google.
Na, ich gucke halt gerade mal, wo Google Earth noch alles so dreidifiziert ist und Bremen gehört dazu.
Wir haben auch eine Podcast-Sendung hier, übrigens, Tim.
Ist noch live, oder?
Was ich übrigens noch sagen wollte, ist zwar aus der Dose, aber dieses Brandlöscherzeug ist gar nicht schlecht.
Dosenbier ist geil.
Es stand da auch drauf, da wäre alles getestet.
Das sagt Herr Dr. Winkenschürfel.
Herr Winkenschürfel sagt, alles supi. Ich bin auch schon hier mit dem Kirschtang auch schon ganz gut.
Darf ich jetzt mal zu meinem Schweizer...
Gleich fängt er an zu singen, Tim.
Darf ich jetzt mal zu meinem Schweizer Thema überdenken? Was? Ich hab ein Schweizer Thema.
Du hast ein Schweizer Thema. Eurovision. Wir machen sogar Schweizer Themen.
Ok, neues Thema, Kapitelmarke.
Für die Aussprache werde ich noch gehauen, oder?
Ich bin da vor ein paar Wochen mal drauf gestoßen, weil jemand von einer Schweizer Firma, von einem relativ kleinen, aber feinen Provider in der Schweiz, hat mal einen kleinen Vortrag gehalten bei einer deutschen Veranstaltung. Die Folien sind auch online. Nämlich jemand von der Firma namens Fiber 7, glaube ich. Ich weiß nicht, ob das Produkt Fiber 7 heißt oder der Provider. Jedenfalls ist das so eine Bude, die sich mal angekickt hat. Die sagt, wie sieht es eigentlich so aus in der Schweiz mit der Glasfaser? Und haben festgestellt, ja, da ist mal schon seit etlichen Jahren ordentlich Glasfaser gelegt worden. Weil die Schweizer haben nicht verstanden, dass das Infrastruktur ist, die man mal gut gebrauchen kann. Haben also schon vor zig Jahren angefangen. Sowohl die Gemeinden als auch die Stromversorger und wer auch immer, wenn wir schon mal eine neue Strip ziehen, dann machen wir doch mal ein bisschen Glas rein. Und diese Ernte kann man jetzt mal so einfahren.
Wir sollten noch mal ganz kurz die Bundesregierung zitieren, in den Stream holen.
Die Schweizer, die Festnetz oder so?
Die sollen ja einfach mal zuhören, die mit dem Festnetz.
Glasfaser ist doch Festnetz. Hat man dort seit Jahren schon mal ein bisschen Glasfaser verlegt und die wird natürlich schon sehr gerne eben auch vermarktet, so von Swisscom, teilweise auch genauso dämlich wie hier. Allerdings kann man die auch roh kriegen. Und das haben sich diese Fiverr 7 Leute, haben sich gedacht, das machen wir doch mal. Wir mieten doch jetzt einfach mal die letzte Meile. Von wem auch immer jetzt die Faser da gehört. Da gibt es eben auch so gleiche Zugangsberechtigung für alle, die da wollen. Und bieten jetzt ein Produkt an, wo Leute zuhause, Privatleute zuhause einen kleinen Internetanschluss kriegen über Glas. Und zwar mit, ohne Faxen. Das heißt also ohne künstliche Begrenzung im Downlink oder Ablink. Ein symmetrischer Gigabit-Link, der nicht künstlich ausgebremst wird. Da ist NatiWitv6 drauf. Man kriegt sogar noch eine IPv4-Adresse. Und netzneutral und tralala und pipapo. Und das Ding kostet 777 Franken pro Jahr. Das können wir mal kurz umrechnen.
Wohlgemerkt pro Jahr.
Pro Jahr. Wenn man jetzt so runterrechnet, ist das Thema. Darum sind das so 53 Euro im Jahr.
53 Euro im Monat.
Ist nur ein Gigabit.
In beide Richtungen.
Ohne Filter.
Mit niedriger Latenz.
Ist für mich sehr lustig, dieser Vortrag, weil er auch so ein bisschen beschreibt. Technik-Quatsch ist auch nicht nur so ein Werbeding, sondern er sagt halt eben, obwohl sie da ein bisschen Probleme und Widerstände noch mit haben, sie müssen ja natürlich schon noch ein paar Pops irgendwo hinbauen oder eben da zu Swisscom oder so was, Co-Location machen. Das dauert dann immer so vier Monate oder so, bis sie so ein Ding endlich am Start haben, weil da malen halt, ab Amtsmühlen und so. Aber es geht halt. Auch sehr nett sind so Anekdoten, wie, denn hat er die ersten Kunden drauf gehabt und die haben dann Speedtestnet angeklickt und die haben sich dann beschwert, warum das so langsam sei, aber daran liegt, dass es einfach keinen Speedtestnet-Server draußen gibt, der die irgendwie ordentlich behandeln konnte, diese Kunden. Deswegen sind sie dann hingegangen, haben einen gehostet von Speedtestnet bei sich im Netz, dass die Kunden nochmal sehen können, dass ihre Leitung wirklich das Gigabit hergibt. Und die fahren da jetzt herum. Und wie gesagt, die machen keine Faxen. Also nicht so dieses, ja, aber das darfst du nicht und ne, und keine Nutzung für lalala, sondern die sagen, hier hast du einfach Bits, shut up and give me your money und pff, fertig, so Punkt, Ende, aus. Das ist sehr interessant, auch wenn man das mal so beobachtet, machen die jetzt so seit ein paar Monaten. Sind bisher noch nicht pleite gegangen da dran, umgegentumt, denen scheint das ganz gut damit zu gehen.
Glaubst du das oder weißt du das?
Ich lese halt, ich lese das, was die so rumtwittern, aber ich krieg halt eben auch Zuschriften. Wir haben auch Hörer dort, die schon so einen Anschluss haben. Also ich hab auch schon Mails und Tweets und so gekriegt von Leuten von echt nicht.
Vielleicht live per Glasfaser übertragen.
Könnte sein.
Wir sind mal so modern, was?
Und jetzt denkt man, naja, die Schweizer, die... Letzte Woche war ich gerade mal in meinem geliebten Schweden und geschäftlich hatte dort für ein Projekt mich mal umgeguckt in der Stockholmer Innenstadt und auch in den Außenbezirken. Hab so diverse Locations besucht, die wir da für ein Projekt nehmen wollen. Und bin da immer in den Keller gestapft, hab festgestellt, oh, hier hängt ja auch immer Glasfaser an der Wand. Das hatte ich ja schon mal berichtet, aber es ist halt eben auch so, ja, das hängt da halt an der Wand, wie bei uns hier in den deutschen Kellern Spinnenweben an der Wand hängen. Und das ist halt schon, das heißt also, die Schweiz ist da kein bedauerlicher Einzelfall in der Bundesregierung.
Ist ja auch eine Art von Pfeilbar, ne? Kommt nur kein Internet raus. Oder die Spinnen behalten das alles für sich.
Oder so. Ja, wie gesagt, wer da mal klicken möchte, aber man muss sich als deutscher Kunde vielleicht vorher setzen oder so. Oder sich ein gutes Bier oder richtig einen ansaufen, sonst erträgt man das nicht. Sich das anzugucken. Äh, aber dafür bei Apfel. In Stockholm gibt es auch wieder eine andere Art und Weise das zu machen. Man sieht daran, wer das macht. Wie gesagt, in der Schweiz ist das ein Mix. Das sind verschiedene Leute. Das sind entweder Versorger, also Strom, Gas, Wasser, sonst irgendwas Versorger, oder die Gemeinden, oder wie auch immer, die erst mal die Infrastruktur schaffen, die zu gleichen Konditionen sozusagen anderen Leuten anbieten und dann halt eben Provider wie Fiverr 7 eben hingehen können und sagen, ja jetzt miet ich mir mal so eine Strippe und versorge damit Kunden mit einem Gig. Wohingegen hier die Politik ja immer sagt, ja bitte, macht die Industrie alles schon und wir schenken ihnen ja die Millionen, die sie uns bezahlen müssen für die Frequenzauktion, damit die da was ordentliches mitmachen. Oh, sie bauen ja doch Kupfer aus, dann wird Kupfer wohl Festnetz sein, ganz toll. Und in Stockholm ist das ähnlich. Also die ganzen Kästen, die ich da gesehen habe, sind von einem Versorger namens Stukap. Also, schreibt sich STO, KAB. Das ist auch, glaube ich, mehrheitseigner, auch die Stadt Stockholm, die halt einfach gesagt hat, wenn wir hier mal buddeln, schmeißen wir mal mit rein. Und das heißt, die liegen halt zumindest erst mal in den Häusern dort unten an, ob die jetzt in die jeweiligen Wohnungen oder Räume oder sonst wo auch immer hingehen. Ich hab jetzt noch eine andere Frage, wo du erst mal das Glas an der Straße und im Haus hast. Und die letzten 20 Meter vom Keller in deine Wohnung hoch wirst du auch noch gebacken kriegen.
Wem gehören denn die Kabel, wenn sie jetzt erstmalig in die Erde geschmissen werden? Sowohl in der Schweiz als auch in Schweden.
Der, der so verbuddelt, dem gehören die Kabel. Aber das wird halt teilweise eben auch gefördert. Also wenn zum Beispiel auf dem Land macht das halt eben auch viel Telia, also die ehemalige Monopolbetrieb, die da Glasfaser verbuddelt, aber nicht nur, aber da wo jetzt Garnisch ist auf dem Land, da buddeln die halt und legen das rein, kriegen dafür ordentlich noch ein Geld mit dazu. Übrigens auch aus der EU-Förderung, ja, nur nebenbei. Also wir zahlen das auch mit. Was ich sehr sympathisch finde, aber nur mal zum Erwähnen, zum Thema ist ja alles zu teuer, kann ja niemand machen, kann sich ja niemand leisten. Die müssen es aber sozusagen zu gleichen Konditionen anbieten. Die dürfen nicht selber auch vermarkten, aber das ist halt so, dass wie gesagt auf den schwedischen Fasern gibt es ja so irgendwie über ein Dutzend oder anderthalb Dutzend, zwei Dutzend Provider, die du dir dann auswählen kannst. Deswegen entstehen auch nicht so eine Situation wie in Deutschland, wo halt ein Provider sein Kabel verbuddelt und dann exklusiv darauf seine Produkte anbietet, was denn dazu führt, dass du auf einen Glasfaser in 2014 zwei Megabit angeboten kriegst. Roddy hatte mir vorhin mal geschickt, das ist jetzt nicht ganz so schlimm, aber trotzdem. Das ist von deinem, darf man sagen, welcher Provider das ist? Sag's doch einfach. dns.net Die haben jetzt hier auch irgendeine Phase an der Hand, da wo der Roddy hinzieht.
Die haben angefragt, ob die da ihre Faser im Haus versenken dürfen. Dann haben alle gesagt, ja macht mal.
FTTH, Internetanschluss mit Flatrate. Immerhin, das finde ich schon wieder okay. 100 Megabit down, Link gibt es nicht, steht nirgendwo auf dem Zettel drauf. Man weiß nicht, das musst du wahrscheinlich bei Brieftorben zurückschicken oder so. Aber down kriegst du 100 Megabit für 40 Euro. Das finde ich noch adäquat. Aber es ist trotzdem exklusiv. Das ist halt deren Kabel.
Friedrichshain.
Wieso da denn?
Ist so.
An den Ballermann.
Aus Gründen.
Sondern Nordfriedrichshain oder was?
Nördlich vom Ballermann. Aus Gründen, genau.
Da kann jetzt Tim gleich, der immer noch in Google Earth rumsurft, wie ein kleines Kind, aber sehr niedlich. Ja, so sieht es da draußen aus.
Genau, und wenn man 200 MBit haben will, muss man Fernsehen dazukommen.
Ach so, und dann wieder solche Spielchen. Das ist ja der ganze Punkt. Es geht mir hier um die Spielchen, die wir betrieben werden. Dann sieht man so schöne Sachen wie der Aufpreis für ISDN bzw. 3-10 Rufnummern beträgt 5 Euro monatlich. Jetzt muss man dazu wissen, dass die ganze Hardware ist alles schon da. Das ist nur ein Fleck, weil sie da Software kippen müssen. Aber da kann man dem Kunden nochmal 5 Euro monatlich für abnehmen. Kann man halt in Deutschland. Weil die Leute bezahlen, weil alle das machen, aber es gibt keinen Grund dahinter. Keinen. Das finde ich halt immer wieder so ein bisschen so... Göbel. Man kann jetzt sagen, das machen halt alle, aber dadurch wird es nicht besser. Zehntausend Millionen fliegen, fressen Scheiße, können ja nicht alle irren oder so. Aber das finde ich trotzdem ein bisschen meh. Ja, als kurzer Realitätsupdate.
Depressing. Wo gibt es das? In Basel. In Winterthur. In Zürich. Bratteln. Meilen. Bratteln.
Zug. Aber ganz gut ist Basel-Bollwerk, jetzt gab es weiter unten.
Basel, Lill, Lindauer, St. Gallen, Zug kommt alles jetzt im Januar, Februar oder Februar, März.
Berndauer ein bisschen längere.
Da müssen sie erst wieder irgendwas abschmeißen. Was dauert denn so, wo sie wollen?
Zürich, Wollishofen, November, Dezember 2017. Na ja, immerhin schon ein Plan drin.
Apropos 2017 fand ich ja besonders geil, als hier der Medon zurückgetreten ist. War das der Kurier oder die Bild oder die BZ, die gemeint hat, Medon ist fertig vor Bär, also vor dem Flughafen. Wie haben sie es geschrieben?
Hat fertig.
Medon ist früher fertig als Bär oder so. Stand ich echt da vor und musste auch ein bisschen schmunzeln, war ganz gut. Hat mal einer den richtigen Punkt getroffen.
Kann man ja nur noch lachen über das Thema.
Du kannst noch lachen.
Flugzeuge fliegen ja immer noch, ist ja nicht so, dass wir hier isoliert sind.
Also alle Hörer in der Schweiz, die in den genannten Bezirken wohnen, können ja mal schauen. Das scheint mir doch ein durchaus erstrebenswertes Produkt zu sein. Auch wenn wir es nicht selber getestet haben. Man muss ja dazu auch noch mal sehen, was bei uns 50 Euro Kaufkraft sind. Das ist da im Vergleich ja noch weniger. Aber ich meine, in der Schweiz kannst du schon nochmal 20-30% locker draufrechnen, ohne was falsch zu machen.
Ja, trotzdem. Würdest du 80 Euro im Monat für Gigabit zahlen?
Nein, was ich sagen will, es rechnet sich auf 50 Euro um, aber du kannst nochmal 30% abrechnen. Also für einen durchschnittlichen Schweizer Verdienst im Vergleich zum Berliner Verdienst, würde ich sogar sagen die Hälfte. Also gefühlte 25 Euro im Monat.
Jetzt muss man allerdings dazusagen, so ein Produkt würde wahrscheinlich in dieser Art und Weise in Deutschland gar nicht funktionieren. Weil der Typ hat auch in seinem Vortrag auch gesagt, naja, wie nutzen die Leute das denn? Die nutzen es halt vernünftig. Das heißt, wenn sie das brauchen, dann nutzen sie das. Wenn sie das nicht brauchen, nutzen sie das nicht. Meine Landsleute oder unsere Landsleute haben immer so ein bisschen die Angewohnheit, dass sie gerne Sachen, diese bezahlt haben, dann auch auf Teufel komm raus auch ausnutzen müssen. Das heißt selbst hier, das könnte ich mir gut vorstellen, dass es sehr viele Sprachlos gibt, die sagen, naja, bin zwar nicht zu Hause, aber lass dich mal meinen BitTorrent-Client laufen, weil hab ich ja bezahlt. Was ja im Prinzip auch okay ist, aber ich weiß halt eben auch viele Leute, die die Platte vollknallen mit BitTorrent-Musik oder einem Filmscheiß, den sie sich nie angucken, aber ist ja schon bezahlt. Mit so einer Attitüde geht sowas natürlich nicht. Also ganz ehrlich, ich finde es sehr gewagt von denen, dass sie das halt eben als Flatrate anbieten, das würde ich mich in Deutschland nicht trauen.
Du meinst die Schweizer, die benutzen kein BitTorrent oder was?
Nein, das habe ich nicht gesagt. Ich betreibe den Typ ja schon ein paar Monate und der hat halt so eine Statistik dahingelegt, dass er sagt, gibt mal jemand, der lädt auch mal ordentlich runter, aber der hat keinen Kunden, der jetzt das Ding auf Dauerlicht brennen hat.
Das ist das Problem halt, das geht am Ende einfach gar nicht so groß.
Es gibt ja auch gar nicht so viel Content, als dass man da mit Gigabit...
Ja, wenn du Gigabit hast, dann bist du ja auch in 0, X durch mit deinem Scheiß.
Vielleicht auch das.
Du hast ja BitTorrent doch irgendwie in zwei Wochen leergesaugt.
Vielleicht auch das, aber es ist, wie gesagt, ich bin ja kein Freund von diesen Flat-Rates, weil es halt ein... Ausgeben. Weil es immer die ISPs sozusagen dazu bringt, dir irgendwelche komischen Mischkalkulationen anzudrehen, die aber eben relativ zu fremd sind. Das ist dann für ein paar Power-User eine super tolle Sache. Aber für den Rest der Mannschaft, der Rest der Kunden, ist das halt so ein bisschen eher blöd. Deswegen bin ich kein Freund von Flat-Rates.
Wie wird es also die Internet-Wattstunde?
Nö, ich finde solche Mechaniken, wie die Provider sie untereinander benutzen, ich hatte das irgendwann schon mal erzählt, nämlich diese Patienten-Teilregelung finde ich durchaus okay. Dass man halt sagt, ich bringe einen Tacho an an deiner Leitung. Und wir nehmen oben noch so ein paar Werte weg, und unten vielleicht auch, ja, und nehmen dann das, was da sozusagen ein guter Mittelwert, was du da nutzt. Und wenn du wenig nutzt, dann zahlst du halt wenig, und wenn du viel nutzt, zahlst du halt viel. Weil man muss sich überlegen, jetzt bei diesen Fiber 7 Leuten, wenn die Kunden einen Gigabit anbieten, die haben zwischen ihren Pops, also zwischen ihren Routern und ihrem Core, haben die vielleicht ein, zwei, zehn Gigabit Leitungen. Du kannst 100 Gigabit, das ist immer noch so ein bisschen so eine Geschichte, das ist halt eben teuer und fragil, zehn Gigabit kannst du locker bauen, zehn, zwanzig, vierzig kannst du locker bauen, aber halt eben nicht ein Terabit mal so schnell eben liegen. Terabit irgendwo hinzulegen geht, kannst du machen, ist aber scheiße teuer. Immer noch, also im Vergleich dazu. So, das heißt, der Abstand zwischen dem, was die haben von ihrem Core zu ihrem Backbone und natürlich auch zu ihren anderen Anbietern, also die müssen ja mit anderen Leuten peeren, die müssen ja Verbindungen haben zu Internet-Exchanges oder anderen Providern, da ist jetzt der Unterschied, der bandbreiten Unterschied zwischen dem und dem, was der Endkunde jetzt hat, nicht so dramatisch wie hier, wo die Leute immer noch mit 16 Megabit surfen. Das heißt, wenn du da mit 10 Gigabit in den Pop rein gehst, da kannst du durchaus ein paar Hundert, paar Tausend Leute mit 16 Megabit anschließen. Aber nicht, wenn die alle selber ein Gigabit haben. Das heißt, wenn da 10 Leute ordentlich mal den Hahn aufdrehen, ist das Ding voll. So, und deswegen ist es da schon spannender, sich mal zu überlegen, wie man da seinen Traffic-Engineering macht.
Ja, aber gerade BitTorrent verteilt sich ja dann doch ein bisschen mehr. Also ich denke, das ist... Also gerade, wenn du sämtliche BitTorrent-Kunden hast, dann peeren die ja untereinander.
Ich muss trotzdem diese 10 Gigabit erst mal nach Bern schieß mich tot kriegen. In den Pop, wo der Switch steht, wo denn die Endkunden dranhängen.
Ja, die peeren aber auch nur, wenn sie alle im gleichen Straßenblock oder Stadtteil gerade denselben Film unterlagen.
Wird auch nur ein Moment, dann müsstest du auch dort in dem kleinen Kukagrode auch routen. Das tun die ja nicht. Die haben eine geswitchte Infrastruktur zu ihren Haupt-Core-Standorten. Wenn sie schlau sind, ist das mehr als einer und da fangen sie an zu routen. Alles anders da geswitcht.
Heißt die da auch Kukagrode?
Dollar, kleiner Ort Dollar. Das ist sehr das Interessante daran. Übrigens, was man sich auch klarmachen muss, dass die eigentliche Technik oder das, was da am Boden liegt, die Glasfaser, die zum Kunden rausgeht, ist genau dasselbe, wird das, was sie in ihrem Backboden haben. Sie haben zwar andere Optik darauf zu stecken, also was ein bisschen mehr Bums hat, aber das, was im Boden liegt, ist dieselbe Glasfaser. Übrigens, wer sich noch mal klarmachen will, oder wenn Leute mal sagen, das geht ja in Deutschland nicht, weil Deutschland ist ja so groß und es ist alles so schwierig oder so, dem rate ich mal zu gucken, es gibt ja in Deutschland das Wissenschaftsnetz. Die Leute aus dem universitären Umfeld wissen das ja vielleicht. Es gibt ja das DFN, Deutsche Forschungsnetzwerk, und die betreiben ein Forschungsnetz namens VIN, bzw. jetzt X-VIN schon seit etlichen Jahren. Und das ist öffentlich, wie sie das gebaut haben, was sie damit gemacht haben. Und die kloppen da wirklich ordentlich Bits rüber. In Deutschland. Die haben irgendwie mal ein Deal gemacht, dass sie jetzt doch mal dunkle Glas kriegen von diesem, jenen oder welchen, haben da eigene Technik da drauf und prügeln wirklich im Terabit-Format Daten durch Deutschland, mit Soße und Schaf. Und wie gesagt, auch teilweise mit 256 Lichtwellenlängen oder so was auf einer Faser und so Zeugs. Und das ist nur zum Thema dazu, das kann man auch in Deutschland bauen, wenn man denn will. Und die surfen so ein bisschen unterm Radar mit ihrem Zeug. Die kaufen halt das nicht ein bei der Telekom und so, deswegen sind die da weg. Die machen ihre eigene Technik auf den Glasfasern, aber hauen wirklich an Hunderte von Standorten in Deutschland, prügeln die nur so die Gigabits.
Ja, aber es ist doch klar, wenn ich meinen Bundeshaus irgendwie mit dem ehemaligen Staatsbetrieb sanieren muss, dann habe ich da politisch halt nicht so...
Ich sage, das ist Politik. Aber wie gesagt, es gibt immer wieder Leute, die da ankommen und sagen, ja, aber es ist doch alle, guck mal, die Schweiz ist so klein. Ja, oder... Das Schweden ist auch klein. Ja, erzählen wir denen, ja, in Schweden wohnen nur so wenig Leute. Ja, dafür ist das Land viel größer, aber ist egal. Es sind lauter vorher schon Argumente. Und wie gesagt, DFN ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür, dass man das auch ohne Weiteres einfach in Deutschland bauen kann, wenn man halt mal den Stock aus dem Arsch nimmt. Und die sind schon spießig beim DFN.
Absolut. Also ich interagiere gelegentlich mal mit denen. Ja, ich wollte zum Beispiel mal für die Fakultät da Zertifikate haben. Natürlich gibt es die auch vom DFN. Aber der Prozess, die Bürokratie, die Institution, ich habe es drei Schritte weit geschafft. Und dann beim vierten dachte ich, fuck it, ich mache mir selber einen Zert, komm, ist gut. Da muss ich zwar den ganzen Studenten sagen, ja, ja, der Police Officer mit dem Schlagstock in der Hand, im Browser, ist alles cool. Ich erkläre euch das mal. Ihr könnt da Trust klicken und weiter geht's bitte. Ja, aber...
Ja, wir wollen ja hier auch ein bisschen Weihnachten ins Auge fassen. Und ich dachte, wir können ja mal so ein bisschen unsere Lieblings-Weihnachts-Geschenke hier nochmal verkünden. Teilweise werden wir das auch schon gesagt haben.
Wie werden Geschenke verkünden?
Dinge, die man sozusagen gerne haben möchte.
Gerne haben oder verschenken sollte. Also, die andere Leute gerne haben wollen. Also, wenn uns jemand zuhört, der so... oder ein Nerd oder eine Nerdette ist, ist das eigentlich die korrekte weibliche Variante?
Frag unsere weiblichen Zuhörer.
Du meinst die Zuhörerinnen?
Im Chat, die jetzt gerade Zuhörerinnen, die jetzt gerade im Chat sind.
Ja, gute Frage. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall wollte ich mal was fallen lassen. Weil ich gerade wieder feststelle, wie entspannt es ist. Ich habe mir mal ein Gerät gekauft, das ich nur mit einem einzigen Programm benutzen kann. Und das ist Google Earth. Aber es ist einfach so entspannt, dass der Space Navigator von...
Wenn du ihn hochhebst, dann navigiert er schon.
Ja, 3D Connection habe ich hier vor Uhrzeiten auch schon mal vorgestellt. Ich habe dieses Gerät schon seit Jahren und ich genieße es. Ich habe die USB-Variante, mittlerweile gibt es das auch als Blauzahn.
Ah, ich dachte das Thunderbolt.
Thunderbolt 2, bitte.
Ja, das Tolle ist, das ist halt so, wie Lorio sagen würde, so ein Familienbenutzer, der steht hier sozusagen so auf dem Tisch. Space Navigator. Von 3D Connection mit Doppel X. Oder?
Lorio hätte Telegebäckchen gesagt.
1X.
Wie lange hast du gebraucht, bis du so moving kannst, wie du moves?
Ach, das geht relativ schnell. Das geile ist, du hast da oben diesen Schnupsi und du kannst den in alle nur erdenklichen Achsen drehen und schieben. Also du kannst nach vorne schieben, nach hinten schieben, nach links schieben, nach rechts schieben. Dann kannst du ihn nach rechts drehen, kannst ihn nach links drehen.
Kannst ihn einfach hoch und runter schieben.
Dann kannst du hoch und runter ziehen. Du kannst es aber auch nach vorne tilten und nach hinten tilten.
Also man hat, wie viele Axen waren das jetzt?
Ein Honeycross das Ding.
Flash-Blairs veraltet.
Und es ist, das war er schon immer.
Aber man nimmt noch Chrom, sehr Flash-Brauser.
Lass mich noch mal kurz erklären, also ich denke ihr schaut hier auch schon mal ganz verstört auf meine Flüge, weil ich liebe es, wenn das Ding richtig eingestellt ist. Also man kann hier so die Erde ganz, ich bin jetzt von der Erde ganz weit weg hier, so ein bisschen so Mond-Distanz.
Kannst du in Google Earth auf dem Mars rumfliegen, oder?
Ja, kann man auch. Ja, man kann hier irgendwie auch noch, irgendwo kann man ja noch umstellen, wo man fliegen will. Egal. Und es ist so ein bisschen wie Hubschrauber-Flug. Also man kann hier wirklich alle möglichen Perspektiven einnehmen und es geht einfach super schnell. Ich bin jetzt hier irgendwie gerade noch im All und jetzt fliege ich halt hier irgendwie so mal so nach Berlin, bin schon hier im Stadtteil, auf Straßenebene und hab es einfach so fein im Gespür, es ist einfach geil. Es ist einfach im Gegensatz zur Maus-Steuerung oder Tastatur-Steuerung, es ist einfach überhaupt gar kein Vergleich. Und so kann man halt so wunderschöne Flüge über Gebiete machen und ich mach das halt immer auch gerne, um so Orte anzufliegen, wo ich schon mal war oder wo ich vielleicht auch mal hin möchte.
Der Fernsehturm sieht ein bisschen angebollt aus. Fällt mir dann auf.
Na wie schon gesagt, die Teilschärfe der Google Earth-Daten lässt zu wünschen übrig, aber geht schon. Für einen Überflug ist es auf jeden Fall ausreichend. Space Navigator kann ich dir empfehlen, das ist einfach ein wertiges Teil, steht auch so richtig schön schwer auf dem Tisch.
Kann man damit auch Musik lauter und leiser machen?
Ja, das ist leider noch so ein bisschen das Blöde an dem Ding. Es gibt da zwar so einen Kontrollpanel dafür, wo man auch alles Mögliche einstellen kann. Also für jede Achse kannst du halt da irgendwie ein Mapping machen.
Reaper 64, du steuerst deinen Reaper damit?
Baltimore.
Ich habe das mal versucht, das wäre geil gewesen. Da wäre super, wenn Reaper da mal Support für hätte. Aber Reaper ist halt so aus der Windows-Welt und die kennen halt immer nur Cursor hoch und links, rechts.
Verstehe.
Das wäre super. Also in der Audio-Software mit dem Teil, das wäre wirklich der Knaller. Weil gerade so Zoom hoch runter, so ins Audio rein und wieder rauszoomen oder auch so mit links und rechts drehen nach vorne und hinten zu spulen oder irgendwie so gerichtetes Zooming oder irgendwie sowas.
Also das kann man nicht mappen da in diesem Panel, dass du sagst, ich hab's zumindest nicht hinbekommen.
Und ich glaube, Ralf hat auch schon mal was probiert. Da gibt es einfach die Hooks nicht dafür. Weil du musst halt schon... Das Problem ist, wenn das Programm nicht Space Navigator-Aware ist, dann kannst du es nur auf Tastatur-Kommandos machen. Und du kannst halt so ein softes, gefühlvolles Gzoome einfach nicht auf einzelne Tastatur anschlägen.
Vielleicht musst du einfach mal einen Kaufner nach England schicken und sagen, hier bitte mal unterstützen.
Wenn das das Problem ist, daran soll es nicht scheitern. Man kann sich da auch alles Mögliche machen. Ich sehe auch gerade hier gibt es wieder ein paar neue Features, die ich noch gar nicht kannte. Aber wie gesagt, nur für Google Earth alleine ist es schon geil. Also ich habe nie bereut, das Ding gekauft zu haben. Ich kann es wohl wissen, dass ich es selber nur für Google Earth benutzen kann. Es funktioniert natürlich auch noch in diesen ganzen 3D-Teilen. Hier CUT, Archicut und Cinema 4D. Es gibt hier auch Mappings für Excel und so weiter. Keine Ahnung, was sie da machen. Ja, frag mich. Vielleicht kann man da wirklich in Spreadsheets herumzoomen. Im Browser kann ich auch tatsächlich damit hoch und runter scrollen. Aber da merkt man schon so richtig, das passt irgendwie nicht. Es ist einfach ruckelig und funktioniert einfach überhaupt nicht so, wie man sich denkt. Das geht hier nur mit Rotation. Ich glaube, das ist auch nur so ein Keyboard-Mapping. Also es macht keinen Spaß.
Aber gut.
Was sehr schade ist.
Mit Lautzahn. Kann man nochmal kicken. Wo gibt es das?
Gibt es bei Amazonien. Da können wir einen passenden Link schmeißen. Ja.
Kann man sogar auf Dominanz schalten.
Kling, Kling, Kling, Kling, Kling, Kling.
Nicht gerade.
Auf Dominant.
Du hälst es gerne in Wireless, ja.
Ja, passt besser zu meinem Nutzungsverhalten. Ja, nee wirklich. 120 Euro.
Damals gab es es noch nicht in Wireless. Ich hab halt die USB-Variante. Und...
Gibt doch eine Education-Ware.
Ja, das ist so eine etwas merkwürdige Sache. Ja, die hatten ja früher... Gab es dann irgendwie auch so zwei Preise dafür. Es war immer dasselbe Produkt, je nachdem, ob du Company oder Private bist. Das haben sie glaube ich mittlerweile sein lassen. Also die Wireless-Version ist unwesentlich teurer. Du zahlst irgendwie 109 Euro für die USB-Variante. Und es gibt auch noch mal eine kleine Version. Die kostet aber auch fast das Gleiche.
Machen wir jetzt mal ganz kurz Stimmung hier. Weihnachtliche Stimmung.
Der knackt gleich 13 oder so.
Was geht das jetzt schon wieder mit dem Knappen los? Ist dir klar, dass jetzt wieder irgendein Hörer aufgewacht ist?
Erst schläfrig nabbern und dann mit dem Nacken wieder aufrecht.
So Leute, jetzt haben wir hier mal ein Thema auf dem Tisch. Sonst überfahre ich euch. Ich habe nämlich jede Menge.
Ja nee, jetzt ist erstmal jemand anders dran. Aber wo wir gerade zu dieser ganzen Internet-Geschichte und das Beklagen des allgemeinen Zustands haben. Ich habe immer wieder im Zug gefahren.
Du hast im Zug gefahren?
Ich sogar mit.
Ja, aber da bin ich alleine gefahren. Und zwar habe ich festgestellt, dass sie jetzt auch tatsächlich schon diese Nummer gestartet haben mit WLAN, kostenlos im ersten Klasse. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wann das losging.
Schwarz gefahren in der ersten Klasse?
Nee, ich saß im Speisewagen. Da fangen die Probleme nämlich auch schon an. Also ich hab mich sozusagen erst mal angemeldet und dann war erstmal noch ein, weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, welcher Reihenfolge. Auf jeden Fall irgendwann hatte ich so eine Splash-Capture-Portal-Seite vor der Nase, wo dran steht, Willkommen in der ersten Klasse, hier, kostenlos Internet, klicken Sie hier und dann musstest du irgendwie so ein Capture eingeben. Ich weiß ja nicht, was die glauben, was im Zug die Leute da sozusagen für Spam-Bots da...
Du, Windows, Laptops...
Die bringen ihren Laptop mit, ihren Windows-Laptop mit dem Standard-Trojaner, dem Russischen oder Chinesischen.
Aber ich mein, ja gut.
Hätte jetzt bei Capture auch nichts. Wie auch immer, man muss da ein Capture eingeben, also man muss beweisen, dass man wirklich ein Mensch ist im Speisewagen, weil ja immer auch alles voll mit Robotern und Automatisierten.
Bei Google musstest du jetzt nur noch anklicken, I'm not a robot.
Mit der Mausbewegung machen sie das jetzt.
Keine Ahnung.
Die werten die Mausbewegung aus, wie du da auf den Button zusteuerst.
Die haben halt ihre Hausnummern von ihrem Google Streetmap, da haben sie alle ausgewertet.
Na ja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall haben sie das jetzt gemacht. Erste Klasse soll kostenlos dieses WLAN bekommen. Da sag ich mal, okay, maletwegen schön und gut, super, toll, finde ich okay.
Was ist denn eigentlich der Speisewagen? Ist der erste Klasse oder zweite Klasse? Zweite Klasse. Du brauchst kein DMS-Set oder was?
Du brauchst zumindest keine 1. Klasse Ticket, um in den Speisewagen zu gehen.
Der ist ja zwischen der 1. und der 2. Klasse. Und du kannst von beiden Seiten rein.
Na ja, aber was ist er selber?
Das ist der Speisewagen.
Das ist die neutrale Zone des Schweizer Zuges.
Also ich saß da und hatte das Problem, dass ich genau zwischen dem Hotspot der 2. Klasse und dem Hotspot der 1. Klasse war und da halt die Telekom, und ich sag jetzt mal ganz bewusst nicht die Bahn, sondern die Telekom, beschlossen hat, sowohl das kostenlose Netz in der 1. Klasse, als auch das kostenpflichtige Netz der 2. Klasse über dieselbe SSID anzubieten, schaltet natürlich mein Laptop immer schön hin und her. Das heißt, ich hab irgendwie Netz und dann macht er, ah ja, hier der andere Hotspot, der ist ja irgendwie viel leistungsfähiger, dann nehm ich doch mal den, Roaming, und dann kommt wieder irgendwie Splash-Patreon, siehe, warum hast du dich denn nicht eingeloggt? Also ich werde permanent rausgeworfen, weil er mich die ganze Zeit zwischen irgendwie kostenpflichtigen, also anders konfigurierten Netz, du hast mich immer wieder als Alien festgestellt in dem Moment, wo ich wieder angerollt komme, immer hin und her wirft. Ich bin wahnsinnig geworden. Das war wirklich einfach unerträglich.
Das ist übrigens das Schmuddelkind aus der Telekom-Familie, was dafür verantwortlich zeigt.
T-Systems, genau richtig.
Die sind zwar auch Magenta, aber eigentlich sind sie eher schwarz. Ich meine, wer... Nein, nicht drüber nachdenken.
Doch, weil... Es ist einfach so ein Armutszeugnis, dass man einfach im auslaufenden Jahr 2014 einfach noch nicht mal hinkriegt, zumindest diese Zugangsrechner. Ich meine, ich rede ja gar nicht von Internet. Ich rede ja nur von dem Herstellen der lokalen Verbindungen und dem einmaligen absegenden, welcher Bedingungen auch immer, abgesehen davon, dass Catcher-Portals sowieso nicht gehen.
Diese Portals, überhaupt Portals gehen nicht. Das ist so das Schlimmste, was die... Und die stehen alle für euch dadurch drauf, weil es in Deutschland immer... Providerhaftung, nein, wie heißt das? Wo sie alle immer so dieses... Störerhaftung... Das kriegen sie dadurch mal total gut weg, wenn sie den Leuten welche Portale machen. Inzwischen fangen an, auf meinem Laptop 5000 Icons zu hopsen, weil mein Kalender nicht mehr mit seinem Kalenderserver reden kann. Mein iPhone findet auch total spackig. Mein E-Mail-Server kreischt mich an, damit ich auch erst fünfmal wegklicken muss. Gerade auf dem iPhone ist nämlich ein modaler Dialog hervorragend. Loggst dich irgendwo ein, versuchst, irgendwie was zu machen, kommt fünf, ich habe ja fünf oder sechs E-Mail-Accounts auf dem Ding konfiguriert, brüllt er mich jedes Mal an, weil er erst wegklicken muss, dass er sich nicht mit seinem E-Mail-Server verbinden kann und lauter so ein Scheiß. Und das ist alles wegen dieser Drecksportale. Also wenn der mal findet, der das Ding erfunden hat, dann sind wir mal um die Ecke. Und dabei gibt es längst andere Möglichkeiten, wie man das richtig machen kann. Tim schreibt das auch hier bei sich da.
Ja, also es gibt da eine ganze Menge. Also um noch mal Klatschen zu machen. Und da sind wir wieder schön bei diesem HTTPS-Thema. Ich saß da nämlich gerade, hab Feed-Checking gemacht. Dann hat mich gewundert, dass die ganzen konfigurierten Redirects auf einmal gar nicht so funktionieren. Da geht mir halt so ein Zwangsproxy dazwischen. Und der macht dann aus meinem schön konfigurierten 307 temporärem Redirect macht mir dieser Proxy ein 302-Redirect. Also, was erlaube, Bahnen, nee, TLS-Systems. Weil irgendwie, das ist vielleicht noch zu argumentieren. Also ein 307 auf ein 302-Mappen bricht nicht das Internet voll schädlich. Aber ich finde einfach mal, das geht einfach schon.
Klär doch mal dem Gemeinhörer den Unterschied bitte.
Ist das nicht illegaler Eingriff in deinen Datenverkehr?
Die greifen da schon seit Jahren illegal oder legal, scheißegal, greifen da rein und dann...
Ja, der Unterschied zwischen 302 und 307.
Erklär den Hörer nicht mal, damit sie wissen, warum das so schlimm ist.
Im ursprünglichen, das ist jetzt konkret nicht unbedingt so schlimm, weil der 302 ist so einer dieser etwas unterdefinierten Fehlermeldungen im Netz. Also es gibt ja 3.0, also es gibt ja, bitte?
Sorry, nicht wirklich ein Fehler.
So viel Zeit muss sein.
So viel Zeit muss sein. Also der HTTP Status Code 301 heißt moved und wird gemeinhin als permanent redirect bezeichnet. Das heißt, wenn ich auf eine Web-Ressource zugreife über eine URL und ich erhalte ein 301, dann ist da auch noch im Heller eine weitere URL, dann bedeutet das, es ist nicht die URL, mit der du angekommen bist, es ist ab sofort und immer jetzt diese.
Merkst du ihr Fälligst?
Schreib dir das hinter die Ohren. Das hat auch schon sehr lang gedauert, bis Zoffel mal gemerkt hat, dass sie sich das merken sollen. Dann gibt es 302, Found, was überhaupt schon mal geil ist. Found ist unterspezifiziert und heißt im Prinzip so viel, naja, du hast mir jetzt eine URL gegeben, die war es nicht, aber guck mal, ich habe hier eine gefunden, die ist es wahrscheinlich. Also das ist so, als ob du irgendwie in Mozartstraße 7 fahren möchtest und der Taxifahrer bringt die zu Mozartstraße 17, weil...
Sieben gibt es nicht, das ist ein Sportplatz.
Sieben willst du wahrscheinlich nicht hin, oder?
Kunden, die Folgen des nicht gefunden haben, haben auch von anderen Dinge nicht gefunden.
Ich habe dir auf jeden Fall mal was rausgesucht und das passt schon. Dieses wurde gemeinhin als temporärer Redirect interpretiert, obwohl es nicht wirklich so beschrieben war.
Ja, aber es ist doch kein Redirect, weil du kriegst ja keine ORM, oder?
Doch, doch, doch. Bei 302 Fond kriegst du auch eine Location und dann soll man halt die nehmen. Von daher funktioniert es wie eine temporäre Weiterleitung. Nur, dass das so semantisch alles etwas unscharf war. Und mit HTTP 1.1 haben sie diese semantische Unschärfe dahingehend aufgelöst, dass sie explizit noch den 307 definiert haben. Natürlich macht jetzt dieser bekloppte Proxy von T-Systems in der Bahn wahrscheinlich auch im Jahre 2014 immer noch HTTP 1.0.
Ohnehin der Performance tot ist, ne?
Und erlaubt sich wirklich, einen Status-Code aus dem Internet einfach umzuschreiben nach seinem Gutdünken. Das macht mich einfach aggressiv.
Das ist wirklich schon maximal scheiße einfach.
Die haben wahrscheinlich für Windows NT 3.5 irgendwann mal Lizenzen gekauft.
Das ist das Kompatibilitätslayer für die ganzen T-Systems-Firmen notebooks vielleicht.
Okay, also hier ist der Quick-Fix. Erstens, Proxy. Deswegen möchte ich auch alles gerne auf HTTPS haben. Gar keine Frage. Allein, dass man schon mal die los wird. Dann, bitte, dieser Unfug mit ein kostenloses, anders konfiguriertes Netz hört auf dieselbe SSID. Ich meine, dann machst du doch da First Class, schreibst du irgendwie rein in diese Scheiß...
Sagen wir mal so, ja und nein. Also die Idee ist, dass es ist durchaus legitim, mehrere APs mit derselben SSID und auch den Notfalls derselben Verschlüsselung sowas zu betreiben, wenn sich dahinter semantisch dasselbe Netz versteckt.
Ja tut es aber nicht.
Tut es an dieser Stelle nicht. Tat es mal, war sozusagen in der ersten und zweiten Klasse gleich teuer schlecht. Jetzt ist es sozusagen immer noch gleich schlecht, aber untergehtlich teuer. Das heißt, andere Semantik, das heißt, man gibt dem Ding gefälligsten anderen Namen.
Genau, weil sonst passiert nämlich genau das...
Geht aber übrigens nicht, weil sie Telekom jetzt mühsam all ihre Hotspots auf Telekom geeicht hat und es gibt ja sogar Apps auf dem Telefon, die das automatisch machen und sich dann mit deinem T-Hotspot-Log in den da einloggen. Und es ist nicht vorgesehen, glaube ich, dass die Telekom jetzt mehrere unterschiedliche SSIDs betreibt für ihre unterschiedlichen Hotspot-Füße.
Im ICI heißt das Ding Telekom ICI. Und sie haben ja jetzt auch eine neue Version von ihrer durseligen Hotspot-Software released.
Die meine ich gar nicht.
Die sich irgendwie in neue Hooks in IOS reinlässt. Ist auch so geil, wie das Ding jetzt heißt. Vorher hieß es ja so Hotspot.
Weißt du, wie es jetzt heißt? Online-Manager oder sowas.
Online-Manager.
Online-Manager. Online-Manager. Leute, geht's noch? Da will man doch wirklich sich einen Goldbar nehmen, den den Zitronenscheiben einhüllen und irgendeinem Penner, der sich so einen Scheiß-Trick ausdenkt, das Ding links und rechts in die Ohren hauen.
Du, ich glaube, der ist so schmerzfrei. Das hat keinen Sinn.
Dann lass dir einen Zitronenscheiben weg.
Chili-Schoten.
Dann soll das ja irgendwie durchgehen. Bitte, Online-Manager, wo leben wir denn? Das ist die 90er-Jahre rufen gerade an und wollen ihre Datei-Namen zurückhaben.
Aber, pass mal auf, dieses Ding hat eine total tolle Feature. Das ist so richtig user-friendly. Du musst ja, um deinen Tee-Hotspot-Zugang zu kriegen, eine Kurzbeteilung schicken an so einen Server von der Telekom. Mit dem Wort Open, mit dem schönen deutschen Wort Open. Open, jedenfalls. Wo muss man was hinschicken? Wenn du dein Tee-Hotspot-Ding benutzen willst, ich erklär dir gleich, woher ich das weiß.
Ich musste das aber nicht tun.
Du hast das vielleicht schon mal aktiviert irgendwann. Initial muss man mal Open an 9527 oder so was schicken, an so eine lustige Rufnummer. Daraufhin kriegst du einen mehrzeitigen Text zurück. Wenn sie Tee-Hotspot benutzen wollen, dann müssen sie folgenden User anladen. Und du denkst dir so, oh schön, so ein Username. Das ist deine Rufnummer als internationale Rufnummer, also als MS-STN mit 49 Tralala davor. Und dein Passwort ist auch so zwanzigstellig. Und du denkst dir so, oh fuck ey, das tippe ich jetzt alle mit meinem iPhone ein auf dieser scheiß Portalseite.
Vor allem zwei Sondestrings, damit du wirklich zwei nervige Copy-Paste-Tee machst.
Damit du mehrere Chancen hast, an dem Ding abzuprallen. So, Hotspot der Telekom. Ihre Zugangsdaten lauten Benutzername, hm hm hm. Es gelten die AGW-Preise zu Hotspot und da la la la. Aber du kannst jetzt folgendes machen. Du kannst diese Kurzmitteilung, die da zurückkommt, nehmen deinem iPhone, kopieren den kompletten Text mit dem ganzen Brabrabra drum herum und entweder in das Usernamen oder das Passwort-Fall von dem Online-Manager reinpasten. Und der fusselt von alleine auseinander und macht das alles richtig.
Das ist einfach mal einfach zu machen.
Das ist Deutsch with Engineering.
Ich glaube, das ist nur ein Hack, den sich die Developer gebaut haben. Genau. Da hat kein PM nachgefragt.
Das sagt aber die App selber. In dem Moment, wo du deinen Cursor draufstellst, pass mal auf, ehe du dich hier tot tippst, nimm einfach die Scheiß-SMS da, kopier sie hier rein und fertig.
Aber mit den Namen ist ja die Deutsche Bahn eh cool, weil gestern hab ich auch Bahn gefahren und stand da, dass die, ich bin jetzt aber wieder bei der Bahn, dass man sich in der ersten Klasse die Zeitung im Dispenser abholen kann.
Das klingt so nach Seife.
Das klingt so nach Zettel-Handtücher aus dem Klospender raus.
Jaja, nach Seife.
Klopapierspender.
Du musst, weißt du, Dispenser, dann liest du sie und dann tust du sie in den Disposer.
Vielleicht war es auch der Disposer. Aber jedenfalls sagt er auch immer, wer soll denn das verstehen? Ist vielleicht cooler oder passt er nicht hin? Vielleicht war das deutsche Wort zu lang. Ablage war wahrscheinlich länger als Disposer.
Aber er ist schön Magenta, der Online-Manager.
Das haben die bestimmt von Linux.
Gibt es nicht bei Linux den Network-Manager? Von wegen All Colors are Beautiful. Magenta ist eine Farbe, die geht einfach gar nicht.
Selbst die Meter-Ebene ist jetzt Magenta.
Bei John Legere sieht die gut aus mit seinem T-Shirt.
Was ist Magenta?
In dem Online-Manager zeigt er auch an, wenn ich in einem WLAN bin, selbst die Meter-Ebene ist jetzt voll Magenta. Du bist ja auch Telekom-Kunde hier. John Legere ist doch jetzt ein gutes Stichwort. John Legere ist ein gutes Stichwort.
Er hat auch immer so eine Magenta-T-Shirt.
Aber erst mal muss Tim zu Ende fahren mit dem Zug. Oder ist er jetzt zu Ende?
Na ja, wir sollten ja nochmal kurz erwähnen, wie man das eigentlich machen sollte. Vielleicht willst du das nochmal kurz ausführen.
Na, eigentlich macht man das so, dass der Kunde, gerade wenn man zum Beispiel eine Telekom ist, die SIM-Karten rausgibt, kann man das zum Beispiel so machen, dass das Netz seinen Kunden bei iPhones und so weiter und so fort einfach an der SIM-Karte identifiziert. Das geht nämlich. Man kann das so, wenn man nämlich beim Netz eine Verschlüsselung anmacht und da keinen Pre-Shared Key einsetzt, also nicht ein vorgegebenes, einzelnes Passwort, sondern manche Leute nennen das irgendwie WPA Enterprise oder WPA2 Enterprise, dann kommt ein Mechanismus zum Tragen, der nennt sich EAP, nämlich das Extensible Authentication Protocol. Und da reden nämlich erst mal Endgerät und Netz kurz miteinander, so, ey, was bist du denn nur, ich bin hier ein iPhone. Oh, iPhone ist geil. Da hast du bestimmt eine SIM-Karte drin. Ja, hab ich. Hast du Bock dich über die SIM-Karte zu authentizieren? Ja, meinetwegen. Und dann kann das sozusagen von alleine durchrasseln. So machen das zum Beispiel meine Freunde von Telia in Schweden. Die haben nämlich immer dort, wo ihre Hotspots hinhängen, haben sie einen Telia-Hotspot. Entweder heißt das Home Run, aber jetzt neuerdings führen sie auch Telia-Hotspot ein, aber hier ist Home Run das Produkt. Was wie üblich mit diesem kaputten Portal oder sowas ausgestattet ist. Aber es gibt daneben immer noch die zweite SSID Telia.1x. Und wenn ich mich da mit meinem Android oder iPhone oder sonstigen Teil, was eine SIM-Karte drin hat, da einbuche, dann sagen die einfach, klar, kenne ich, alles super. Ich weiß, wer du bist. Viel Spaß. Kein Portal, kein nichts, kein gar nichts.
Genau. Und es könnte aber auch mit so einem iPad gehen, wo einfach nur WLAN drin ist, dann gibst du halt einmal......gibt es einmal ein Passwort, gut ist. Und dann merkt er sich das und dann ist ab dem auch vorbei.
Super toll, alles verschlüsselt, Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt und funktioniert also auch, wenn man fremde Hotspot-Netze benutzt und so weiter und so fort. Sehr schicke Sache. Kann man sich übrigens angucken, wo wir wieder mit den Forschungsleuten da sind. Es hat ja schon mal glaube ich erwähnt, es gibt ja... In der Forschungsgemeinschaft gibt es ja einen Mechanismus seit Jahren, der nennt sich Eduroam. Das heißt, Universitäten und sonstige Forschungsbuden oder sowas, sogar der Flughafen Orlando in Schweden hat Eduroam, hab ich neulich gesehen, haben sich zusammengeschlossen und sagen mal so ein WLAN-Roaming-Verbund gemacht. Das heißt, als Nutzer an einer Hochschule, Student oder auch Lehrende oder wo auch immer, hast du eine Nutzerkennung für das WLAN deiner Hochschule, buchst dich denn dort ein und mit derselben Kenntnung kannst du überall an allen anderen Hochschulen in Europa oder inzwischen auch auf der ganzen Welt oder eben am Flughafen Orlanda oder auf dem ITF-Meeting oder wo auch immer, wo es so eine Ediromen-Dinger gibt, kannst du dich einfach einbuchen bzw. musst es selber gar nicht machen, weil dein Laptop findet dieses Ediromen-Netz, handelt diese Authentication aus, gibt sozusagen deine Login-Daten, wenn du so willst, Ende zu Ende verschaltet an deine Uni und deine Heim-Uni sagt, ja den kenne ich, der ist cool, lass mal mitspielen. Das heißt, da gibt es das alles schon, kann man auch bauen. Ist auch daher gut abgehangen, also ist jetzt nicht so, dass das High-End-Nerd-Technik ist, für die man irgendwas machen muss, sondern das halt so Laptop aufklappt, anklickt Netz, Username und Passwort eingeben, einmal, nicht einmal pro Stunde oder einmal am Tag oder einmal pro Stadt oder so, sondern einmal, was bei einer Uni, keine Ahnung, dein Studium ist oder wie auch immer und dann ist der Dropsy lutscht, fertig, peng. Und das finde ich schon irgendwie okay.
Es ist vollkommen unverständlich, warum das irgendwie unmöglich sein soll bei der Telekom. Vor allem, wie einfach das auf einmal alles wäre. Ich zuverlässig auch. Ich fliege in dieser ICE-Session da, ich bin zwei Stunden gefahren und ich bin, glaube ich, so zehnmal rausgeworfen worden durch diesen ganzen Scheißdreck, mit dem ich hin und her geschalte. Und auch selbst vorher schon, als es quasi nur dieses eine Netz gab, also nur das normale Bezahlnetz, wofür ich einen Account habe, auch da kommt ja diese Büchse am laufenden Meter wieder auf die Idee, dass man sich ja noch mal anmelden könnte, weil du hast dich ja erst vor zehn Minuten, also irgendwie habe ich in den letzten zehn Minuten so ein bisschen das Vertrauen verloren, dass du wirklich immer noch dieselbe Person bist.
Diese Crap-Bestattung. Das ist so schlimm. Ich hatte jetzt in Stockholm auch in einem Hotel, den musste ich ja noch ein bisschen chillen, die Kollegen, weil ich hatte ja eh mit der IT dort zu tun. Konnte mir aber klarmachen, dass ich dafür nicht gekonnt habe, sondern dass das andere sprachlos war von einem Provider. Das ist wirklich, teilweise haben die diesen Timeout so, dass wenn du fünf Minuten lang das Netz nicht benutzt, dann ist es der Meinung, du müsstest sie wieder neu authentizieren. Du benutzt jetzt dein iPhone und wachst es, auf Klo zu gehen, ohne es mitzunehmen und dabei zu twittern. Dann gehst du an deinen Platz zurück und denkst, oh, da muss ich mich jetzt schon wieder einloggen.
Dafür gibt es nichts der Raum in der Hölle, in der Netzhölle.
Genau, dafür gibt es nichts der Raum.
Das hatte ich jetzt gerade in Darmstadt bei dem Comet-Landing. Hab ich das überhaupt erzählt?
Nee, erzählen Sie bitte.
Weil da haben sie nämlich auch irgendwie einen Dienstleister. Dienstvermeider. Aber von Leistung war leider nichts zu sehen. Und ich ahnte das ja schon vorher, weil es einfach da irgendwie gab irgendwie keine ordentliche Lösung. Da kommen dann 150 Pressevertreter hin. Deren Aufgabe ist es, in Echtzeit von diesem Event zu berichten. Da landet einfach ein scheiß Roboter auf den Cometen. Da geht es einfach um die Minute, da will Twitter bedient werden. Deswegen laden sie diese Leute ein, damit die da einfach Bass machen, dass sie da einfach irgendwie aus diesem Raum in diese Internetwolke abstrahlen. Und dann wird da ein Internet angeboten, was halt fünf Minuten Timeout hat. Das heißt, immer wenn du dein scheiß iPhone mal kurz irgendwie so in Stromsparmodus gelegt hast, also was das ja selber die ganze Zeit tut, schalt's wieder ein, musst du halt wieder, kriegst du erstmal wieder eine Portalseite, wo sie natürlich dann auch immer Username und Passwort abfragen, als ob ich da einen Account hätte. Hab ich natürlich nicht, sondern ich krieg einfach nur zwei kryptische Strings, die da natürlich, also die man auch nicht mit einem Copy und Paste Vorgang und so weiter, die natürlich dann auch noch mit groß und kleinen Buchstaben und Ziffern und so weiter, also auch schön kompliziert, dass wenn man sie dann abtippt von seinem scheiß Kärtchen, was man um den Hals hat, sich auch noch fünfmal vertippt, weil das einfach bekloppt ist.
Ach Tim, wenn deine Freunde bei dir einfach nur jemanden gefragt hätten, der andere...
Auf so einem Kometenland ist halt easy so. Internet ist nicht so easy. Auf Kometenlanden ist easy, Internet ist nicht so easy.
Das ist genauso wie Drucken.
Das waren dann auch die Tweets, die ich irgendwie abgeschickt hab.
Das ist...
Und das Problem ist, die... diese Hainis, ich bin da natürlich sofort, bevor ich... Also ich wusste ja schon vorher, was mich in etwa erwartet. Ich bin da hingeh und hab gesagt, okay, wie läuft's? Ja, Portal. Und Username und Password. Ja, hier steht ja ihr Code drauf. Alles ganz einfach. Was ist der Timeout? Zehn Minuten oder so. Warum habt ihr einen Timeout? Ich hab dem das einfach gleich in die Klasse gehauen. Weil ich war überhaupt nicht bereit, da lange zu diskutieren oder das zu übertragen, weil ich wusste ja schon, was kommt. Ja, wegen der Sicherheit.
Aus versicherungstechnischen Gründen.
Und wegen der Sicherheit ist einfach so der Moment.
Wir haben keine Ahnung, heißt das.
Ja, das war einfach so ein Matrix-Moment. Also die komplette Umgebung um mich herum hat so gefriest.
Bullet-Type. Bullet-Type.
Wo ich so in Gedanken irgendwie so wirklich so in Zeitlupe so ein glühendes Brenneisen irgendwie aus meinem Köcher zog und sie einfach so wirklich mitten in die Brust gerammt habe.
Marked forever.
Und dann macht es so pop und dann war wieder die Realität da. Es war furchtbar.
Ob wir 10 Minuten wart?
Und ich konnte halt nur verzweifeln, weil ich wusste, ich kann mich jetzt noch so sehr beklagen und hier den Aufstand machen. Das wird sich halt an dieser Situation nicht ändern. Aber ich bin einfach verzweifelt, weil es einfach so... Und so war es dann halt auch. Ich war einfach den Tag über da, bis um... Wir waren da, glaube ich, zwölf Stunden vor Ort. Und man verbringt da einfach die Zeit. Und du musst dich irgendwie gefühlt alle 15 Minuten mit jedem Gerät anmelden. Und das ist ja überhaupt noch der nächste Punkt. Das müssen wir auch nochmal drauf rumhaken. Warum darf ich nur mit einem einzigen Gerät auf meinem scheiß Hotspot-Account arbeiten?
Warum?
Was soll diese bekloppte Limitierung? Menschen haben mehrere Geräte. Ich hab drei, mindestens. Und ich kann eigentlich immer nur eins gleichzeitig benutzen. Und selbst wenn ich mal drei gleichzeitig benutze, so what, ich brauche die Dienstleistung Internet.
Ich brauche diese Dienstleistung Internet.
Die wird nicht meinem Gerät erbracht, die wird mir erbracht. Und wenn ich das kaufe, möchte ich gerne natürlich das machen.
Aber nein, ich muss ja immer um mich hin und hin.
Indubio Contrario. Im Zweifelsfall gegen den Angeklagten. Weil das könnte es ja sein, dass du jetzt anstelle eines zweiten Accounts, der Geld kosten würde, einfach hingehst und eine von deinen Zugängen deiner Frau gibst. Ja, da sei Gott vor.
Man kann das ja beschränken auf den lokalen Ort, wo man gerade ist.
Das könnte ja sein, dass deine Frau neben dir sitzt. Schrecklich.
Wo kommen wir denn dahin, wenn Leute auf einmal mit ihren nächsten Verwandten solche Dinge ausdrucken?
Wir merken gerade mal wieder, dass wir live sind. Es gibt durchaus Mitarbeiter der Telekom, die uns hier zuhören. Wirklich? Ja, die jedes Mal schon mit Schweißperlen da sitzen, wenn ich anstimme. So schreibt mir einer von denen, hast du bestimmt schon gehört, aber das mit ERP und den Hotspots kommt bald. Nee, hab ich noch nicht gehört. Nee, hab ich auch nicht gehört. Würde ich jetzt auch gerne mal wissen, wann, aber da schweigt der Spion wieder.
Ist das so ein DDR bald?
Ist aber ein verifizierter Telekom-Mitarbeiter. Also der ist ein verifizierter Whistleblower.
Ist das dann auch eine verifizierte Aussage?
Nein, das glaube ich nicht. Es gehört übrigens mit zu meiner Hass-Liebe mit oder gegen die Telekom, die ich ja schon seit 20 Jahren betreibe, dass ich ja weiß, dass es da in dem Laden durchaus Leute mit Hirn gibt, auch gute Ingenieure, die ihren Job gerne gut machen wollen und so auch geiles Netz aufbauen und dann kommt irgendein Sprallo vom Marketing oder vom Produktmanagement.
Ja, die Online-Manager.
Ja, genau, die. Und das war's dann wieder. Deswegen kann ich den Frust von diesen Leuten durchaus nachvollziehen.
Wir auch. Wir wollen ja auch nicht irgendwie auf allen Mitarbeitern rumhacken. Wir wollen nur die Situation beklagen.
Nur Freunden.
Das ist ja natürlich wieder eine Bogus-Aussage hier. Moment, ich leider noch...
Nur die, die verantwortlich sind.
Kronen-Sommer.
Hier, für iPhone soll das mit dem nächsten Firmware-Update kommen, dass die ERP-SIM-Funktion nutzt. Hallo, iPhone kann schon lange ERP-SIM. Siehe Thälia. Du musst momentan noch ein Profile drauf spielen, dann macht die Telekom ja sowieso das. Du musst das enablen. Das machen sie extra so, damit nicht jeder Hotspot dir deine SIM-Karten rausmelkt. Sondern du musst explizit sagen, auf dem Netz darfst du ERP-SIM machen, aber das kann ich selber auch mit meinem eigenen Profil machen. Das geht schon lange. Zum Zeitpunkt hörte ich was ums Q2 2015 bis Q3 2015. Aber ich trau dir denn zu, dass es noch 2016 wird. Ich auch. Okay, so viel die Stimme des bangentafarbenden Volkes.
Hey, der Bim Bam da. Also wirklich.
Ja, wir haben heute leider ein bisschen Netzding. Tut mir leid, Bim Bam.
Wie geht's in deinen Bitcoins?
Bitcoins.
263 war vor zwei, drei Tagen auf 290 oder 280. Ne, 290 eigentlich. Also ist gerade ein bisschen im Tiefflug.
Ist der Bitcoin an den Rubel gebunden, oder was?
Ne, aber das könnte sein, dass der vielleicht steigt, der Bitcoin, weil der Rubel abstürzt und dann die Russen. Also sehr viele Russen haben in Bitcoin eine Mining-Hardware investiert. Also das kann man in den Foren mal sehen, sehr viele Russen dabei. Und die könnten den Preis wieder hochtreiben, so wie die Argentinier. Aber ich glaube, am Ende sind es dann doch nicht so viele, dass es so easy geht. Außerdem wäre der halt schon längst gestiegen, weil die haben das Problem schon. Es kommt ja nicht erst.
Ja, Apple hat jetzt den Online-Store für Russland dichtgemacht wegen dem fallenden Rubelpreis. Habe ich aber noch nicht die Story geklickt, was das eine mit dem anderen jetzt so wirklich zu tun hat für die. Aber hat das vielleicht schon jemand geklickt?
Nee, aber die wissen halt nicht, wie viele Rubels noch wert sind.
Die machen ihre Preise halt neu. Müssen sie halt.
Nee, ja, jetzt machen sie gerade keine Preise, sondern dann keine Preise. Sie verkaufen gerade nichts.
Haben zugemacht, den Online-Store für Russland.
Ja, weil sie halt jetzt erstmal...
Warten, bis sie sich wieder ein bisschen stabilisiert.
Ja, worauf auch immer sie warten. Aber auf jeden Fall müssen sie eine...
Also, den stört ja der schlechte Rubel nicht. Den stört er nur, wenn er halt fällt. Wenn er steigt, ist ihm glaube ich auch egal. Also nur feilen ist halt ein Problem, ne?
Ja, ich denke, dass generell jegliche Kursschwankungen halt...
Nee, da kann man seine Preise ja anpassen.
Ja, eine bestimmte Kursschwankungen haben die halt ohnehin drin. In ihrer Kalkulation. Aber nicht unbedingt so, dass das Ding tankt.
Wenn der Kurs so schnell schwankt, dann haben sie das Problem, dass du dir jetzt ein iPhone klickst für X-Rubel, du das aber erst bezahlen musst, wenn sie es dir schicken. Und wenn der Kurs sehr schnell fällt... Nee, das wird aber abgebucht erst dann, wenn sie es los schicken, wenn das iPhone wie jetzt zum Beispiel nicht verfügbar ist.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich.
Und du dann halt eben drei Wochen darauf warten musst, dann hast du jetzt für X-Rubel geklickt und sie müssen es dir in drei Wochen für einen Wert schicken, der dann ihre Kosten nicht mehr deckt.
Ja, aber solange ist ja das iPhone gerade nicht mehr, läuft ja wohl richtig gut gerade und sie können gut liefern. Nee, aber zurück zu den Bitcoins. Die News sind, dass Microsoft, was hatten wir vor zwei Wochen noch nicht, das ist was Neues, dass Microsoft jetzt Bitcoins nimmt, was ja eigentlich schon ein bold move ist, würde ich mal sagen. Leider ist es halt Microsoft und nicht irgendwelche anderen Bude, weil bei denen brauche ich jetzt wirklich nicht so viel.
Was heißt jetzt bei dem Store oder was? Der normale Microsoft Online Store.
Ja, aber ich glaube nur für digitalen Content. Also das heißt, du kannst ja deine Xbox-Spiele da kaufen und so, und wahrscheinlich auch deren OS, aber du kannst jetzt die Xbox...
Oder Word oder sowas.
Ich glaube, du kannst halt eben die Xbox selbst nicht kaufen, sondern den Content dafür. Aber es ist ja schon mal Anfang, und vielleicht werden die ja warm mit den Coinbase-Jungs, die, glaube ich, im Boot.
Also bei Modellkinder werden langsam erwachsen, ne? Microsoft ist ja immer in der Szene so ein Schmuggelkind.
Microsoft in letzter Zeit starten die wieder so ein bisschen durch, könnte man sagen.
Ich meine, sie zeigen auch gerne ihrer eigenen Regierung Stinkefinger, weil offiziell Bitcoin zu nehmen, was ja sozusagen der Regierungsgrößte Hass ist, ist ja A ein Stinkefinger, ja, und B.
Die Regierung ist ja eigentlich, die haben ja von dem Silk Road Typen, haben sie ja die Bitcoins versteigert, auch in den letzten Wochen.
Das heißt auch nicht, dass sie Bitcoin mögen. Keine Regierung hat Bitcoin.
Wenn sie Bitcoin nicht mögen und sagen, der Schrott ist nix wert, dann dürften sie sie nicht verkaufen, dann müssten sie sie vernichten.
Nee, geht nicht darum. Es geht darum, dass sie keine Kontrolle drüber haben. Deswegen mögen die Regierung kein Bitcoin.
Ja, mögen, aber verboten haben sie es nicht.
Es ist halt kein Fiat Money.
Aber eigentlich sagen die doch, dass sie es mögen, weil die Blockchain ist ja da.
Das ist eine andere Art von Fiat Money. Es ist auch kein echter Wert dahinter. Das Drumgemeine da, das ist ein... Ja, aber die Geldmenge ist begrenzt. Wie dem auch sei.
Fiat Money ist ja... Fiat es werde, wie Fiat Lux es werde. Es werde Geld. Geld entsteht daraus, dass du sagst, dass das jetzt Geld ist. Das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass die Menge begrenzt ist oder nicht. Sondern nur dadurch, dass du sagst, das habe jetzt Wert. Wenn sich alle darauf einigen, dass Bitcoin irgendwie Blödsinn war, dann ist er auch nichts mehr wert.
Ja, aber du kannst in unserem normalen Fiat Money wird halt auch weiterhin Geld einfach immer wieder produziert und neu erfunden und da gibt es überhaupt gar kein Ende. Bei Bitcoin gibt es halt ein Ende.
Ja, hast du recht, aber das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass es Fiat Money ist. Oder nicht?
Also bei richtigem Geld gibt es auch ein Theoretik, also Ende, wenn kein Papier mehr zum Drucken da ist oder Tinte alle ist oder so.
Ich habe da gerade einen Podcast zugemacht übrigens.
Wenn die Bitcoins alle sind.
Habe ich den letztes Mal schon erwähnt?
Nein. Du hast einen Podcast zugemacht.
Ein Bitpot. Kein CRE. Ein CRE zum Bitcoin habe ich ja schon vor langer, langer Zeit mit Andreas gemacht. Also zu elektronischem Geld unter anderem halt und vor allem natürlich auch Bitcoin. Ich habe hier für die Freunde bei O'Reilly, da mache ich ja von Zeit zu Zeit diesen Kolophon-Podcast. Und die letzte Ausgabe, die widmet sich dem Thema...
Diese kompetenziellen Medien.
Ja, O'Reilly Deutschland ist ja so ein netter Verlag.
Die soll man ja in den Store fixen. Der hinkt dem US-Store meilenweit hinterher. Die haben da immer noch ihre alte Perl-Installation am Laufen.
Ja, das ist halt auch nicht ein unmittelbares Kind der amerikanischen E-Alarm-Banking. Mit Jörg Platzer habe ich gesprochen. Der Owner von Room 77. Der ja ein Buch rausgebracht hat.
Auf jeden Fall ein sehr großer Bitcoin-Evangelist.
Absolut. Ja, also Microsoft nimmt Bitcoin, wie schön.
Oben77 auch.
Oben77 schon immer, ja.
Ja und Time Magazine jetzt auch für Abos und so weiter und für ihre Magazine. Aber haben wir hier wahrscheinlich nicht so viel von. Ich glaube Microsoft ist sogar auch nur bei den Amis. Und im Zuge dessen oder also passend dazu, das kann man vielleicht noch erwähnen, auch wenn es mit Bitcoin nicht direkt zu tun hat, aber Apple nimmt jetzt auch Geld von PayPal.
Ja, stimmt.
Und wenn PayPal irgendwann mal dann doch Bitcoins nimmt, dann kommen wir noch in den Rechner.
Hallo, meinst du, in Deutschland, ich hab bei Apple schon seit Jahren im US-Store mit PayPal bezahlt.
Also weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob nur in Deutschland, also ich glaube, das war eine Internetschnellmeldung.
Wer ist der sicher?
Also ich hab ja einen US-iTunes-Store, über den ich so Medien kaufe, schon seit Jahren. Und der ist durch meinen PayPal-Account durchgechannelt.
Vielleicht ging es um Apple Pay.
Nein, nein, eben nicht.
Aber es kann wieder so ein Deutschland-US-Thema sein.
Nee, es sind aber amerikanische News, die das hier listen.
Oder für, dass jetzt nicht der Apple Store...
Ja, United States and United Kingdom.
Ja, ist es der iTunes Store oder der Apple Store?
Apple now accepting PayPal through online Store. Apple online Store.
Also nehme ich mal an, dass sie jetzt auch Hardware darüber verticken.
Ja, was meinst du damit?
Was hast du damit bezahlt?
Ach so, ja das kann sein, dass die auch halt mit dem digitalen Content dachten sich, da ist ja mit der Garantie nicht so ein Problem, weil da müssen wir ja nichts zurücknehmen oder haben wir nicht so wirklich Verluste.
Kann sein.
Anders als bei den Raubkapiteln, das ist natürlich ein totales Problem, aber wenn es dann um sowas geht, dann ist es nicht so schlimm. Und jetzt aber auch für Hardware anscheinend bei Paypal. So und wenn Paypal dann irgendwann mal Bitcoins nimmt, was sie ja vorhaben, da gibt es ja so Gerüchte und die haben sie ja öfter geäußert und so, da ist ja vielleicht eigentlich eine ganz interessante Sache ist. Und irgendein Subunternehmen, von denen nimmt ja auch schon Bitcoins, aber nur halt so ein kleines Subunternehmen.
Fragen wir doch mal unseren residenten Ebay-Spezialisten, wollten wir das PayPal nicht eigentlich schon längst verkauft haben oder so? Da war doch mal was, dass der Ebay gerne seinen PayPal wieder verticken wollte oder wollte er den Skype wieder verkaufen, aber irgendeinen von diesen großen Einkommen...
Nein, den Skype haben sie ja...
Den Skype haben sie ja verkauft, stimmt, das ist schon eine Weile her. Das merkt man daran, dass er nicht mehr geht.
Sagen wir mal so, so was geht natürlich nicht von heute auf morgen.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt jahrelang den eBay-User mühsam darauf dressiert, alles per PayPal abzuwickeln, um die Bude dann zu verkaufen.
Dann werden sie ja weiter benutzen, oder?
Warum eigentlich? Da bin ich ein bisschen der Falsche, um den zu fragen. Alles, was ich weiß, ist, dass es da so ein Konflikt um den Investor Carl Icahn gab. Der das durchgesetzt hat.
Der will Geld sehen, verstehe.
Naja, der will diesen Split.
Der will ausgezahlt werden. Der kann nicht ausgezahlt werden, wenn eBay die Bude behält.
Und der jetzige eBay-Chef war da strikt dagegen und hat hochgepokert und hat halt verloren. Und wenn, ja, keine Ahnung, wenn die jetzt getrennte Wege gehen, geht er auch gleich noch getrennt weg mit.
Dein Amazio.
Also so mehr kann ich nicht dazu sagen.
Da gab es so viele Gerüchte, dass Facebook irgendwie WhatsApp gekauft hat, weil die Investoren von WhatsApp irgendwie mal ordentlich Geld sehen wollten. Und die auch, also die Investoren bei Facebook und bei WhatsApp Investoren waren. Und weil sie bei Facebook nichts rausziehen konnten, haben sie Facebook gesagt, ey dann kauft ihr doch mal WhatsApp. Und dann bleibt so viel Kohle übrig, dann kriegen wir so unser Geld. Und so kann der iKon das auch. Der kriegt, der hat sein Geld in Paypal. Und bei eBay ist es aber nicht so viel wert, wenn er es verkaufen würde. Wenn aber eBay mal Paypal verkaufen würde, würde es wahrscheinlich reichlich mehr wert sein. Und er würde mehr Geld kriegen. Deswegen sagt er, das stoßt ihm ab. Dem ist doch egal, ob die User bei eBay Paypal benutzen oder nicht. Der will seine Kohle haben.
Ja, es gibt noch einen anderen Aspekt, und zwar wächst Paypal viel stärker, als es eBay tut.
Okay, das heißt, wenn es verkauft wird, wird eBay es aber weiterhin benutzen.
Na ja, sagen wir mal so, momentan ist es halt so, dass Paypal teilweise eBay-Marketplaces mit quer finanziert. Weil die momentan nicht so doll wachsen.
Das mögen natürlich Investoren wie Icahn gar nicht.
Genau.
Die sagen, ich hätte hier gerne meine Dividende, ihr sollt nicht investieren, mit der Produktion verdienen, ich möchte die gerne haben.
Sie versuchen halt, das Filetstück rauszutrennen.
Na, denn Icahn, der war ja schon so lang, weil ich das an Apple investiert habe.
Das ist so meine Interpretation der Sache.
Ja, kann schon sein. Der sieht einfach mehr Potenzial in Paypal, als wenn es weiterhin bei eBay rum eiert. Ist ja eigentlich auch sein Job als Geschäftsmann, Potenzial zu sehen.
Geht ja auch hart um Cash. Ich meine, das, was der bei Apple macht, ist ja auch, dass er hingeht, sagt so, ich kapiziere so und so viel Prozent von euch. Wie viel Bargeldreserve habt ihr? Ach, guck mal an, ihr habt ja so und so viele Milliarden an Bargeldreserve. Davon gewinnen ja Endprozent mehr, die will ich jetzt mal haben.
Der kauft sich ein paar Milliarden ein und dann hat er Stimmrechte und dann kann er da ein bisschen Druck machen, kann dem Tim Cook Sachen empfehlen. Der Tim Cook wird sagen, ja nee, Apple hat ja hier schon einen Plan und so, aber am Ende sind die natürlich beeinflusst.
Ja, der scheust ja auch die anderen Investoren auf oder Aktionäre und sagt, hallo, der Apple hat hier Bargeldreserve X und die möchte ich jetzt haben, die sollen sie völlig auszahlen und nicht sich auf der Kante behalten.
Haben sie ja auch gemacht, also nicht alle, weil die machen ja den Stufen und so, aber sie haben es auch erhöht schon und der hat ja auch schon ordentlich Geld bekommen. Und die Aktien sind ja wahrscheinlich auch durch den Einkauf von Kaleiacon sind ja ziemlich nach oben geschossen, aber in der letzten Woche auch ganz schön runter wieder.
Naja, der ist halt auch an den Rubel gebunden, die Apple-Aktie.
An den Rubel?
Aber der Dollar scheint ja gerade voll abzugehen, das heißt im Gegensatz zu dem Dollar wird der Euro schwächer. Das heißt, es kann sein, dass demnächst die Apple-Geräte dann teurer werden müssten.
Ja, die Amerikaner haben ganz schön aufgeholt, was die Ölförderung anbelangt.
Weil sie so viel Fracking machen?
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Also die sind jetzt ziemlich in Reichweite dessen, was die Saudis und die Russen machen. Die sind alle so bei 10 Megabarrel pro Tag und das ist schon ordentlich.
Also weiterhin kein Piekei und ich kann wieder weiter ein ordentlich Gas geben, ne Huckel?
Naja, meine Interpretation der Sache ist, dass der Ölpreis, der war jetzt so lange so weit oben, dass es sich halt für viele Leute gelohnt hat, teure Projekte anzustoßen und das Geld ist halt jetzt draußen und jetzt kommt das Öl und dann musst du es halt nur noch pumpen und das kostet nicht mehr viel. Deswegen sinken gerade die Ölpreise. Aber das wird sicherlich auch ein Ende haben und wenn die Kurve dann wieder nach oben ausschlägt, dann wird sie nicht bei 100 Dollar bleiben.
Ja, aber wenn die da so viel Öl finden, dann ist auf jeden Fall nicht mehr Piekei, solange ich noch irgendwie gerade laufen kann. Hoffe ich. Solange ich noch auf zwei Rädern fahren kann, sagen wir mal so. Mein Rolli später, der fährt ja dann mit Akku.
Es gibt doch Elektromotorräder, so ist es nicht.
Ja, die sind alle noch Schrott.
Ach, Piekei kann ich gerne noch miterleben, Hauptsache nicht Piekinternet.
Piekinternet war schon.
In Deutschland ist immer Piekinternet. Sie überlegen hier erst Glasfaser, wenn das Kupfer so teuer ist, dass es sich lohnt, das auszuputteln.
Sie haben hier schon Glasfaser gelegt. Wann war dein größter Internetmoment? Da müsstest du eigentlich gewesen sein, als du von ISDN auf das eine MBit abgegradet hast. Oder von 64 Kilobit auf ein MBit. Oder bist du auf 768 oder so?
768.
Aber das war mehr als das Zehnfache. Wann hattest du das noch mal? Das kriegst du nie wieder, dieses Zehnfache.
Natürlich. Da musst du einfach nur mal hingehen. Und jetzt mal eine ordentliche LTN. Er fährt in die Schweiz, stöpselt sich dann Fiber 7 an. Da hat er eine 20-Fache.
Und er wird hier nicht von 50 auf 500 upgraden. Das wird der Tim in seinem Leben nicht mehr sehen. Keine Zehnfachsteigerung mehr. Die wirst du nicht mehr erleben.
Doch, doch.
Auch wenn die Telekom so weitermacht, schon.
Wo kommt jetzt gerade die Zehnfachsteigerung?
Von ISDN auf deine ersten 768 Kilobit PSL.
Und 64 Kilobit auf 768.
Ich hab da schon mindestens zwei Megabit an Schloss.
Ich hab da schon mehrere Übergänge gehabt.
Was gibts da noch für Zwischenschuhe? Hatste 384 oder was?
Ich hab ja damals in der Firma gewohnt, aber Artkom, da gab es ja 256 Kilobit. Ja, was?
Hatte ich auch bei Pixelpack 40 ein mit. Das zählt ja nicht.
Bei mir war der Übergang härter, weil ich vorher noch Modem hatte. Also ich hatte den ISDN Zwischenschritt nicht.
Ich überleg gerade, was meine Frage ist, ganz anders verstanden, was überhaupt so sozusagen mein interessantester Internetzugangsmoment war. So hast du doch eigentlich gefragt.
Aber ich mein schon den Schritt, wenn es schneller wurde, wenn man sich freut, wie geiler das jetzt als vorher ist.
Als deine Kinnlade runterklappte, als du die Download-Geschwindigkeit beobachtetest und dachtest, Download-Geschwindigkeit hat sich nie in dem Maße gesteigert.
Ich meine, diese Anschlussraten sind ja auch nur theoretisch.
Ich bin schon von ISDN auf DSL, war bei mir schon so, dass Latenz war besser, Speed war besser, es war einfach flutschend. Nichts mehr einwählen, Standleitung auch. Ja, ich auch, aber...
Latenz war am Anfang auch für den Arsch.
Aber es war trotzdem noch irgendwie so eine Leitung. DSL war so...
Dennis, Latenz war am Anfang auch für den Arsch. Bis sie dann FastPass eingeführt haben bei ADSL.
Ja, aber noch besser als ISDN.
ADSL klingt irgendwie auch wie so eine Krankheit, ne?
Also mein Kinnladenmoment war...
Da müssen wir aber was gegen machen....
wie ich Diplomarbeit gemacht hab, da hing ich irgendwie direkt am B-Win mit eigener IP-Adresse. Also netzweit, rutbar, erkennbar, guckbar. Und da hab ich damals irgendwie so eine Linux-CD irgendwie in wenigen Minuten runtergeladen. Als ISO, als zu Hause halt gerade mal so Modem ging. Und dann kam irgendwie Quake 3, irgendwie so die ersten Betas raus, dann hab ich das da installiert und hab irgendwie den ganzen Level aufgeräumt, weil ich der Einzige war, der eine ordentliche Pinkzeit hatte. Das war irgendwie so.
Aber ich hab auch Quake.
Bin da nicht so doll, aber da hab ich irgendwie alle plattgemacht.
Quake 3 Arena hab ich auch dann, als wir ISDN mal bekommen hatten, da hatte ich auch einen 20 Millisekunden-Ping und die anderen alle so mit 120 und so.
Ich glaub, ich hatte 5 oder irgendwie so was.
Also ich kann euch sagen, was für mich, man ist ja mal alles sehr relativ, man muss ja auch mal sagen, wo ist man? In Deutschland, finde ich, gibt es einfach nur langsames Internet, weil dafür, dass man eigentlich in Deutschland ist, finde ich, gibt es hier überhaupt gar kein schnelles Netz.
Außer in der Firma.
Außer vielleicht da Unis.
Ja, doch, oder das kannst du auch mit genügend Geld, kriegst du das auch so. Ich gehe ITF in Berlin, da hab ich auch ordentlich gestoßen.
Wenn du einen ordentlich großen USB-Stick hinten ins Auto wirfst und damit 200 über die Autobahn düst, hast du auch schnelles Internet.
Also ich hatte, Pinkzeiten sind aber von Anfang an.
Im Jahre 2001 habe ich nämlich mal Kuba besucht. Und ganz praktisch gesehen gab es in Kuba kein Internet. Also es ist ja auch heute noch nicht wirklich da.
Doch, seit heute. Hast du das nicht gelesen?
Ja, ich habe es gelesen, aber das ist...
Wieso? Was gibt es denn?
Hat Obama eine Fiber rübergelicht?
Obama will sich jetzt mit... Die wollen jetzt Peace machen.
Oh, oh, das gibt aber Ärger an Flöder.
Ja, aber ich glaube, da schreist er drauf.
Nee, weniger Ärger, weil die jetzt mehr Drogen haben.
Können wir die unqualifizierten politischen Kommentare nach hinten verlagern? Ich will mal eine Kuba-Geschichte erzählen. Also 2001. Erinnert ihr euch noch, wie das war? Internet 2001? Scheiße. Da war nicht so viel. Das ist jetzt irgendwie 13 Jahre her. Und man war schon froh, wenn man überhaupt Internet hatte. Und ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich zu Hause hatte. 2001, da muss ich so auch ISDN, glaube ich noch, oder vielleicht war schon das DSL da.
Ich hatte eine der ersten DSL-Leitungen damals, als Tester auch mit. Noch selber mit eigener ATM-Geschichte oben, also richtig mit ATM selber drauf gemacht und so. Das war auch so ein 6-Megabit-Anschluss, irgendwas.
Ja, aber erst mal in Mexiko. Und in Mexiko gab es halt mal so Modem-Stroheim-Internet am Strand, was irgendwie ab und zu mal ein bisschen eine Webseite auf dem Bildschirm gemalt hat. Da konnte man so ab und zu mal ein bisschen spawnklicken und das war's.
Da waren die aber auch noch alle nicht so Video- und Flash-verseucht.
Nö, aber es war ja trotzdem alles, sagen wir mal, eher so schnarchnasig. Es gab da schon Fotos und so und man konnte zumindest so in etwa in Verbindung bleiben. Und dann war ich in Kuba und es gab Internet in Kuba. Und das Lustige ist, ich bin da irgendwie ganz unvorbereitet hingekommen eigentlich, aber ich hab dann halt so einen Typen getroffen, der konnte dann irgendwie Deutsch. Der hat sich irgendwie in Kuba nur durch Touristen und Spiegellesen Deutsch beigebracht. Der sprach wirklich fantastisch Deutsch, war wirklich unfassbar, also unfassbar gut. Also hat sich richtig Mühe gegeben, das ist ja auch ein Überlebensmodell, so was gut zu können.
Ich dachte, sich richtig Mühe geben.
Naja, ich meine, wenn du da halt ein korrektes Leben führen möchtest, das ist auch heute noch so, aber es war auch 2001 schon so, dann musst du halt sehr flexibel sein in Kuba. Und zwar jetzt nicht unbedingt nur dem System in Arschkriechen flexibel, sondern halt mit den Ressourcen, die halt da sind und die einzigen Ressourcen, die halt so ohne weiteres zugänglich sind, sind halt Touristen. Das heißt, du musst halt da irgendeine Dienstleistung aufbringen, die halt Touristen mögen. Und die meisten Leute bieten dir halt entweder Rum oder... Sex? Zigarren oder Sex. Das ist im Wesentlichen so das Produkt-Spektrum, was mir so angeboten wurde und das um 20 Sekunden abscheint. Das macht einen total, also das war wirklich furchtbar. Also Kuba ging mir so dermaßen auf den Sack in so kurzer Zeit. Das war einfach unfassbar. Obwohl es also ein geiles Land ist irgendwo, aber das ist wirklich mega anstrengend gewesen. Na ja, da hab ich dann so meine Maßnahmen ergriffen. Der Real Life Spam war da wirklich ein bisschen krass. Na ja, auf jeden Fall sprach sich dann irgendwie so ein bisschen so mein, wie soll ich sagen, meine Computerszene, Vernetzung sprach sich irgendwie rum. Und über diesen Freund, der das irgendwie seiner Schwester erzählt hat, die an der Uni war, kam dann irgendwie auf einmal so der Request, ich sollte doch mal an die Uni kommen und irgendwie mal ein bisschen erzählen. So hier mit CCC und so, das wussten die irgendwie. Ja, dann fand ich mich dann halt irgendwann an der Universität von Habana wieder und hab einen Vortrag über GPG und Kryptografie gehalten. Das habe ich mich einfach mal kurzfristig so durchgerungen. Ja, die so, ja, und war es nicht lustig, irgendwas zu erzählen, nicht so, ja, lasst mal über E-Mail-Verschlüsselungen gehen.
Da hast du aber auch Glück, dass du nicht im Knast gelandet bist, oder?
Naja, das war echt ganz lustig, weil ich nämlich, es war natürlich klar, also ich war dann irgendwie da und hab einen ganzen Tag quasi so ein bisschen Seminar gemacht. Obwohl ich da ja eigentlich nur so Rucksack-Tourist war. Aber am Vormittag saßen da halt die Studenten da und es war halt auch klar, dass da halt diverse aus dem Apparat saßen. Ich glaube so zwei Leute, würde ich sagen, vielleicht waren es drei, aber auf jeden Fall mindestens zwei, die halt so zur Beobachtung gekommen waren, um mal zu schauen, was der Herr aus Deutschland da so, den Studenten da gerne mitteilen möchte. Das ist ja so ein bisschen, kannte man ja auch, war ja so ein bisschen wie DDR, halt bloß warm.
Und mit Zigarren und alle 20 Sekunden Sex.
Sexzyklen in der DDR-Zeit waren mir jetzt nicht so bewusst. War glaube ich nicht so einfach, aber warm war halt eh nicht. Wie auch immer, ich war mir also diese Situation bewusst und habe aber trotzdem irgendwie über Verschlüsselungen erzählt und mein schlagendes Argument war, ist so lustig, wie das heute klingt, ja ihr müsst halt irgendwie eure E-Mail verschlüsseln, weil die Amerikaner sitzen auf eurer Leitung und wollen euch zuhören.
Dabei wissen wir heute, dass du total unrealistisch bist.
Und dann haben die alle gefragt, E-Mail, was ist das?
Nee, das war so meine Argumentation, warum halt jetzt irgendwie E-Mail-Verschlüsselungen für die da irgendwie ein wichtiges Thema ist, ein Public Key, ein Private Key, ich bin ja kein Krypto-Experte, aber ich habe halt so die Prinzipien erläutert.
Das ist schon eine gute Methode, um die zwei, drei Specials in ihrem Raum sozusagen sich in Glück wiegen zu lassen, aber trotzdem eine coole Message rüberzubringen.
Ja, und die waren nach der Mittagspause, waren die weg.
Das war das Geile, ja.
Also ich habe die wirklich ausreichend überzeugt von meinem zersetzerischen, anti-imperialistischen Grund-Pathos. Und als die dann weg waren, da war ich dann halt mit den Studenten irgendwie alleine, dann habe ich ihnen halt noch ein bisschen andere Sachen erzählt. War ganz lustig.
So, subversives Element.
Und die hatten da Internet. Und zwar, die hatten das ganze Internet. Also die hatten das vollständige Internet. Kubas wandelte dort an, an dieser Uni. Und es waren 256 Kilometer. Und die hatte ich für mich ganz alleine. Also ich saß da, ich war der King. Ich hatte sozusagen die vollständige Bandbreite Kubas auf meiner Tastatur. An einem Ort, wo ich eigentlich davon ausgegangen bin, dass ich überhaupt nicht ins Internet kam.
Ich kenne ja jetzt manchmal so dieses Gefühl, der macht jetzt neulich in Honolulu, da hatte ich ja auch dieses, ich habe ja das ganze Hotelnetz übernommen für dreieinhalbtausend Zimmer. Das ist schon mal okay, wenn du so denkst, so hmmm, mit Usern drin. Da musst du dir überlegen, sind es auch schon so sieben, achttausend Geräte, haben wir auch mal so, feel the power.
Ja, lass dir nicht so viel das in den Kopf gerichten, sonst wirst du auch noch mal so mit die Telekom.
Ich bin ja schon auf die dunkle Seite der Macht drüber gewechselt.
Welche meinst du jetzt, Metaimne?
Nee, ich bin jetzt so richtig magentafarben. Ich hab meine Seele verkauft. Ich hatte einfach von meinem Revoluzzer-Tum bei Kongstar die Nase voll, weil mich das genervt hat, dass die zwar ein geiles Netz darunter haben, nämlich das von der Telekom, aber immer hier und das geht nicht und das darfst du nicht und nein, Multicard gibt das nicht und Visual Voicemail sowieso nicht und wir bremsen dich aus auf 7 Megabit und du hast ja noch einen alten Vertrag, aber pass bloß auf, dass du ja nicht dran wackelst und nehmen wir die LTE auch noch weg und dann hab ich neulich mal in einem, keine Ahnung, ich weiß, ich hab mich total drüber amüsiert, die Telekom hat doch jetzt zur Funkausstellung diese Tarife wieder mit noch blöderen Namen als vorher eingeführt. Was, noch blöder? Magenta Mobil und Magenta Home oder Magenta 1.
Schlimmer geht immer.
Immerhin auf Deutsch.
Magenta 1, ne, weißte nicht, Magenta One. Und ja, also jedenfalls sehr schräg. Und dann hab ich mir aber gedacht, keine Ahnung, wieso, und ich klick da jetzt mal drauf rum, was das eigentlich ist. Einfach mal gucken, auch mal über die feines Observation machen, mal drüben gucken, was da so geht. Und habe dann in der rechts unten Abteilung, bei der Telekom, einen Tarif entdeckt. Kannst du mal klicken. Ne, nicht Magenta 1, da komm ich gleich dazu. Geh mal mobil. Tarif und Optionen. Ne, telefonieren und surfen. Nicht Premium-Tarife. Premium-Tarife heißt bei denen bloß, wenn du den dauernd in welche Handys abkaufst. Guck mal, jetzt gibt's da, Moment, was hat? Nein! Guck mal, wenn die Seite aufgebaut wird, siehst du dort SML. Völlig unspektakulär, wie üblich teuer, mit irgendwelchen obskuren High-Speed-Volumen.
Super Medium und Length.
Pass auf, jetzt klickst du oben auf L-Plus und schiebst es drüber. Jetzt siehst du L-Plus, da ist es, Telefon, SMS-Flat, ja kenn ich, hatte ich bei Kongstar auch, Internetflag, LTE Max, ja toll, aber nicht für 71 Euro, 5 Gigabit High-Speed-Volumen, naja. Aber der Hit steckt in dem nächsten Ding, was da drunter ist, was die anderen nämlich nicht haben. In dem schönen Wort Inklusivleistung. Moment, die fangen erst mal harmlos an. Also kriegst du jetzt erst mal dieses Hotspot-Flat, das ist das Ding, worüber wir geredet haben, im Zug oder im Hotel mal klicken und so WLAN sich einwählen. Okay, ist jetzt auch nicht dramatisch. Multisims gibt es jetzt gratis dazu. Also kannst du jetzt zu deiner Hauptsim noch zwei extra haben, die du auch benutzen kannst, auch gleichzeitig benutzen kannst. Also insgesamt drei oder insgesamt zwei? Insgesamt drei. Dann eine Option Festnetz-Rufnummer, also die Home-Zone-Nummer, da kriegst du eine Berliner Rufnummer, wo auch immer du anmeldest, kriegst du halt dazu, die dann irgendwie auch weitererleitet wird. Auch schön. Jetzt aber den nächsten Punkt.
Telefon, Internet und SMS-Flat des Tarifs auch im EU-Ausland nutzen.
Also in ganz Europa 71,95 Euro?
So und dazu noch 100 SMS und 100 Minuten pro Monat ins Ausland telefonieren, was ja normalerweise auch ein Arm und ein Bein kostet. In Ländergruppe 1 und 2, das ist so ungefähr jeder außer Afghanistan. Also alle Industrieländer, egal, bis Australien runter und so weiter und so fort. Aber wie gesagt, diese anderen Dinge, Telefon, Internet, SMS, Tarif, also diese 5 Gigabyte, die sie verkaufen, in ganz Europa benutzen mit drei SIM-Karten. Und dann gibt es noch mehr, weil wenn du jetzt nämlich noch klickst unten auf Tarif-Date heißt, dann siehst du so Sachen wie du darfst auch Wolb endlich benutzen und Tethern darfst du sowieso. Da hat jemand einfach mal hingegriffen und gesagt, wenn man mal alle Optionen anmachen, alle Optionen, den Kunden nicht zu ärgern, mal ausmachen sozusagen. Und da haben das alle drin nicht geschmissen. Also wie gesagt, so blödsinnige Feste, die haben wirklich einmal so reingegriffen, da haben wir gesagt, da machen wir noch eine Hot-Spot-Flatrate mit drauf. Alle so drin und in die Kiste und so, da hast du.
Das ist der Leger-Tarif.
So, da hab ich mir, nee, noch nicht ganz, noch nicht ganz. Aber da hab ich mir gedacht, das ist doch mal ein interessantes Angebot. Und dann hab ich mal weitergeklickt. Ich bin ja eh schon als VDSL-Nutzer in Deutschland gerade auf dem Land ja an die Telekom gebunden. Weil da bietet da sonst keiner. Und da habt ihr mal geguckt, was dieses komische Magenta One macht. Das heißt, wenn du nämlich sowohl Mobilfunk-Kunde bist bei der Telekom als auch Festnetzkunde, dann kannst du dieses Magenta One klicken. Dafür musst du nichts bezahlen. Das ist sozusagen so ein Bonus, den du noch kriegst, dass du bei beiden mitspielst. Das bedeutet, dass sie dir nochmal 10 Euro abziehen auf dein Mobilfunk-Tarif. Was ich durchaus okay finde, weil der Magenta Mobil Plus ist ja schon noch relativ teuer. Aber wenn man da einen Zöner A10 abzieht, ist das wieder okay. Und sie machen dir auf deinem Festnetz eine Flatrate in alle Mobilfunknetze mit an. Und wenn man das jetzt alle zusammenspielt, dann ist das, finde ich, durchaus okay. Das ist immer noch teuer, aber ich bin jetzt sozusagen komplett sorgenlos. Ich reise ja viel, auch gerade eben Schweden oder andere europäische Länder.
Was machst du in der dritten und in der vierten Woche? Das ist dann 5 Gigabyte.
Ich bin von Kongstar jetzt jahrelang auf 1 Gigabyte im Monat dressiert gewesen. Und 5G. Außerdem kriegst du im ersten Monat doppelte Daten-Dinger dazu. Das heißt, ich werde jetzt nochmal schön knallen und dann kriege ich nochmal 5G für Oma und so, die ich auch schön in Schweden nutzen werde. Und das ist halt, das finde ich ein Feature. Und vor allen Dingen eben, du darfst jetzt VoIP benutzen, das ist mit drin. Musste mal gucken, wo steht das?
Stand da aber nicht.
Doch, doch, doch, steht da. Klick mal bei den Tarifdetails unten.
Machst du das geht noch weiter.
Und da steht irgendwie Internet-Telefonie, VoIP inklusive. Das heißt du kannst jetzt auch endlich mal FaceTime aus dem Ausland.
Wieso wurde denn das geblockt?
Nein, aber zerhackt. Wenn du im Telekom-Netz versuchst, irgendeinen VoIP-Dienst zu benutzen und nicht diese Option hast, dann kannst du zwar die Verbindung aufbauen, aber ganz... Doch, können sie machen. Da haben sie jetzt noch einen Bug drin. Wie gesagt, sie haben einfach mal diese ganzen Kundenärger-Features, die sie sonst drin haben in ihrem Netz sozusagen.
Also man bezahlt sozusagen für das Ausschalten der Features.
Sie haben natürlich extra Equipment im Netz, was sie teuer lizenzieren und betreiben müssen, um den Kunden zu ärgern. Und wenn du ihnen halt ein bisschen Geld dafür gibst, wenn du unten rechts klickst, dann gibt es sozusagen durchaus das, das funktioniert. Und das hat richtig Bums. Ich hab dann, wie gesagt, die Schweden haben ja auch super Infrastruktur. Ich hab dann da ein Orlander im Flugzeug gesessen und auf Abflug gewartet und auf meinem PETMA-Speedtest gemacht. Und der ist erstmal so oben so bei knapp unter 100 Megabit angeschlagen. Und dann nochmal im Uplink übrigens auch so bei 46 und so, nur so nebenbei. Und das ist schon okay.
Aber dann verkaufen sie nochmal 50 Megabyte für einen Euro.
250, ja, wenn du das machst.
Also wenn ich das jetzt mal auf meinen aktuellen O2-Tarif, den ich habe, hochrechne, oh mann, das ist aber zweier.
Tim, du kannst den auch höher klicken. Du kannst noch Datenoptionen dazu klicken. Du kannst den auch auf 10 oder 15 hochklicken. Das musst du nochmal gucken. Das ist noch so eine Option, die du da noch oben draufsetzen kannst.
Ja, bestimmt für einen 10er ist das zu haben.
Hier mein Telekom-Spion, der du mich vorhin angeschrieben hast. Du weißt das bestimmt aus dem Kopf. Schreib mir das mal. Wie viele Fenster machen die eigentlich auf? Diese Website ist fürchterlich. Also nochmal, ich empfehle das nicht. Ich werbe auch jetzt explizit nicht für die Telekom, weil es immer noch ärgerlich genug ist, dass man das so machen kann. Aber man kann solche Tarife offenbar anbieten, ohne pleite zu gehen. Also deswegen warum nicht eher so?
Aber wo steht denn hier, wie viel mal ordentliches Datenvolumen kostet? Ich meine, 5 GB, das ist doch prekär.
Nein, das ist noch eine Option, die da oben noch draufkommt, die heißt ja noch irgendwie Data Plus. Aber nur so nebenbei, auch die könntest du dann im Ausland mit benutzen. Also diese All-Inclusive-Geschichte macht, dass du alles, was du zu Hause an Flatrates hast, auch im EU-Ausland, aber das sind ja EU-Ausland übrigens plus Norwegen und Schweiz, da mit benutzen kannst.
Aber hier heißt es jetzt auf dieser Preisliste, heißt der Tarif schon wieder anders.
Ja, du musst den Fließtext lesen. L Premium ist immer so ein Ding, ist übrigens, ja, keine Ahnung, diese Premium-Tarife sind immer mit, du kriegst noch eh das Jahr von uns ein Drecks-Handy mit dazu oder so was. Aber wenn du ein eigenes Gerät mitbringst, dann lässt du diesen ganzen Quack sein, das will man ja nicht haben.
Ab dem nebenstehenden Datenvolumen wird die Bandbreite im jeweiligen Monat auf maximal 74 Kilobit.
Von NTE Max auf 16 Kilobit ist richtig böse.
Nur bei den Friends-Optionen. Also hier steht nichts von zusätzlichen Daten.
5 GB extra für nochmal 25 Euro. Okay, dann bist du halt mit dem anderen Ding bei 85, also mit diesen Dingern hast du halt 10 GB für 85 Euro, aber dann ist es doch gut. Dann kann man zum Beispiel auch selbst, solange die britischen Inseln sind noch in der EU derzeit, das heißt so, wing wing natschnatsch. Das heißt, ich fand's halt einfach mal nett, weil diese SIM-Kartenwechsellei, die ich immer sehr gerne betrieben habe, aber dann mittlerweile auch nervt, weil Apple mich jedes Mal auf allen Geräten informiert, dass ich jetzt meine eigene Mobilfunkrufnummer habe. Dann muss ich auf jedem Gerät sagen, ja ich habe die, woraufhin dann allen anderen Geräten gesagt wird, ja der hat jetzt angenommen, dass du deine eigene Mobilfunkrufnummer hast. Das war jetzt einfach mal relativ entspannend. Und vor allen Dingen maulte ich auch nicht an. Es ist ja normalerweise so, wenn du ins Ausland fährst, wird dir erst mal alle Datenverkehr geblockt und du kriegst erst mal eine SMS, eine Kurzmitteilung, die dann sagt, ja du bist aber im bösen Ausland und wenn du das wirklich willst, dann schreib uns hier einen Code und unterschreib ihn mit Blut und so. Aber das war jetzt nicht. Du fährst halt einfach hin und her, als wenn du zuhause bist. Das geht halt einfach weiter. Das ist ein Feature.
Wir nähern uns langsam an. Aber trotzdem, wo ist der Nerd-Complete-Tarif?
Was ist denn jetzt noch dein Problem? Die 5G sind dir zu wenig?
Der Digital Nomad-Tarif.
Ja, 5G.
Was brauchst du denn im Monat?
Mobil.
Zehn Locker.
Wie machst du das?
Ich benutze das Internet. Ich lade Sachen herunter.
Ich ja auch, aber ich schaffe das nicht.
Ich habe da kein Problem mit. Ich stüpsele halt meinen Laptop an und habe halt Netz. Ich mache halt Hotspot und da wird E-Mail gezogen. E-Mail, Attachments, Tralala, Gesünkte, Dropbox, Dropbox, alles Mögliche.
Die Gruppis checken ihm bestimmt ganz unsüchtige Bilder. Ich glaube, ich glaube auch.
YouTube macht das jetzt auch hier per GIF und so.
Ich will mir nicht erzählen lassen, wie viele Daten ich verbrauchen habe. 5 GB, das ist einfach nichts.
Es ist ein Anfang. Ich habe mir jetzt mal gesagt, ich gebe mir das jetzt mal.
Ich habe Dateien, die sind 5 GB groß.
Ich gebe mir das jetzt mal und bin wie gesagt als normaler iPhone-User da recht begeistert davon, weil es halt nicht mehr nervt. Ich kann halt zwischen den Ländern hin und her springen, ohne dass ich mir Kopf machen muss, dass mir ein Arm und Bein amputiert wird vom Insolvenzverwalter. Und das finde ich schon mal ganz okay.
Ich werde meine gehobene Auslandsnutzung im nächsten Jahr wahrscheinlich einfach mit so einer lokalen Karte und einem Hotspot-Device...
Hab ich auch hier lang gemacht, aber nervt halt eben auch. Ja, dazu passend gleich, dann bin ich aber auch fertig. Dann könnte er... Geht er über Minecraft? Minecraft finde ich immer sehr cool, der Leuchtturm war echt cool. Aber nur weil es wirklich passt, gab es gestern eine nette Veranstaltung von unserem Freund John Ledger. Der ist der Chef von T-Mobile USA. Übrigens meines Wissens nach der einzige Provider, der freiwillig und unaufgefordert den Leuten auch im Mobilfunk IPv6 anbietet. Aber das ist jetzt nur ein anderer Thema. Der hat so einen Werbeslogan, den er mal sagt, Uncarrier. Das heißt erst mal so untelekomisch. Und der hatte gestern mit dem David Polk von Yahoo da so ein Interview gemacht, wo er jetzt sein Uncarrier Step Number 8 vorgestellt hat.
Hast du da mal einen Link für?
Haben wir Google?
Wenn du das gesperrt, muss man hier noch extra bezahlen.
Die Idee ist, das ist einer der Punkte, den ich ja schon lange auch bei dieser ganzen Diskussion über Funktional kaputt und so weiter sofort damals schon mal angesprochen habe, dass man das Datenvolumen, was wir nur kaufen, das wird uns ja wieder weggenommen. Also diese 5 GB, wenn ich die nicht benutze oder so, dann kommt ja einfach einer am 31. Und nimmt mir die weg. Der gibt mir zwar 5 neue, aber die anderen 3, die ich noch haben umzulegen habe, die nimmt er mir weg. Das ist auch so scheiße. Wo man sich dann auch sagt, was soll denn, deswegen ja diese ganze Diskussion mit, ja eigentlich ist es ja eine Flatrate und du darfst ja weiter surfen, aber wir reduzieren halt nur nach dem Inklusivvolumen.
Stell dir vor, da würde am Ende uns einer kommen und dein Sprit aus dem Auto wegmachen.
Solange es wieder frisch auffüllt.
Ja, macht er. Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Er macht deinen Tank ja nicht voll, er macht deinen Tank halb voll. Aber wenn noch ein Viertel drin war. Ja und da wirft er jetzt damit, dass jetzt in USA bei T-Mobile, dass die Leute jetzt Data Rollovern können. Das heißt, das was sie gekauft haben, können sie auch einfach am nächsten Monat mitnehmen. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt mal einen Monat lang nicht dein Netz benutzt, weil du zum Beispiel im Urlaub bist oder so was, dann verfällt das nicht, sondern nimmst du es halt einfach mit.
Dann würden mir sogar 5 GB reichen.
Und ja, er gibt ja übrigens auch noch, wenn du im UT-Mobile-US-Kunde bist, gibt er dir jetzt auch erstmal so 10 GB. Damit fängt er mal so an, sagt, ich schenk dir jetzt mal 10 GB und nimmst du jetzt mittebisch, bis du das verbraucht hast und das warte monatlich dazu kaufst, das kannst du auch akkumulieren. Ich weiß jetzt nicht wie lange, aber immerhin. Das ist jetzt sein Move. Was ich daran sehr spannend finde, ist, offensichtlich kann man das anbieten, ohne gleich in die Insel Vents zu gehen. Und was ich sehr geil finde, er greift ja damit die anderen US-Carrier an, sagt, was das für miese Schweine sind, die noch anders abbrechen, also richtig aggressiv auch. Ja, und sagt, das sind alle fiese Abzocker und Betrüger. Und da ein Piepapoo.
Das kann er sich schon nur leisten, weil der Kleinst ist dort, oder?
Davon abgesehen, das Spannende daran ist, dass offensichtlich seine Konzernmutter wohl hofft, dass das niemand in Europa mitkriegt. Weil genau das, weswegen er seine Konkurrenten in den USA ja beschimpft, als fiese Betrüger, macht genau seine Konzernmutter und seine Schwestern und seine Stiefschwestern in Europa. Genau das, das finde ich halt so ein bisschen prickelter.
Das hat man bei dem anderen Interview da schon erzählt, wo er in Polen bei dieser, wie sagt das, Aktionärstreffen irgendwie gewesen ist. Und dann, was meint er, an wem es liegt? On me.
Er könnte ja hier sich kleiden und reden, wie er will, weil er hat ja Erfolg und das würde ja an ihm liegen.
Jaja, aber dieses Interview ist auch cool. Also meine Lieblingsszene ist, wo er zu David Polk sagt, also er sagt ja, der normale Nutzer weiß ja nicht, wie viel er benutzt. Ja, der fragt doch mal einen normalen User draußen, wie viel Megabyte oder was das ist. Ja, David, ich weiß, dass du das weißt. Also ich surfte auch seit Jahren Porn, da weißt du, wie groß so ein Gigabyte ist. Ist natürlich sehr viel Werbeblabla drin. Du merkst auch, dass er viele Sachen auswendig gelernt hat, weil er sich manchmal dann so ein bisschen in den Einheiten verhaspelt. Er redet dann immer von Megabyte und David Polk immer, nee, sind Megabyte. Aber trotzdem ist es halt, ich finde es schon mal interessant, dass sozusagen einer mal jetzt sagt, ich mach das jetzt einfach mal, mal sehen, was passiert. Ich bin ja mal gespannt, wann der nach Bonn gerufen wird und sich seine Papiere abholen kann. Aber ich finde es sehr interessant.
Solange der Laden da brummt und da tut es ja anscheinend, werden die da den nicht bekannt.
Ja, aber nochmal, er beschimpft richtig seine Konkurrenten. Und wen er implizit damit beschimpft, ist seine eigene Mutter und seine Schwestern. Also nicht Konzerne.
Na, er redet halt im Wesentlichen von Amerika.
Ja, aber der darf dich ja beschimpfen, weil er war ja früher auch selber bei AT&T, der kennt dich ja alle.
Du bist ein Ex-AT&T-Mann?
Ja, der ist richtig lange im Business dabei. Ich hab mal geguckt, der ist nicht irgendwie so ein Schlipsträger, der kommt und jetzt mal so eine Firma irgendwie...
Ein Schlipsträger ist der sowieso.
Aber nicht irgendein Manager-Typ, der da mal irgendwie kommt, um so einen Laden wieder so ein bisschen in Schuss zu bringen und der so ein bisschen Werbung kann, sondern der ist schon seit Jahren und immer irgendwie im Mobile-Business gewesen. Also vorher halt bei AT&T. Der war Chef von AT&T Asia oder wie sowas oder irgendwie so irgendwas riesengroßes.
Also auf mich wirkt er immer so ein bisschen wie so ein ältlicher Rockstar.
Er ist ja ein Rockstar, finde ich. Kommt am besten rüber. Macht eine gute Show, macht Spaß zu gucken.
Am Ende ist er halt auch nur so ein Bit-Verkäufer.
Aber das soll er ja auch sein.
Ich denke auch, dass er sich das nur leisten kann, weil er halt wirklich so klein ist, dass er sich halt eben keine Sorgen machen muss, dass er irgendwie zu wenig Geld verdient oder Kunden verliert. Weil er weiß, mit seinen Tricks, die er gerade macht, zieht er den anderen halt Kunden ab. Und das ist ja immer gut, er braucht mehr Kunden später. Wenn er die Kunden alle hat, wird sich das ganz schnell ändern.
Das ist auch ein anderes Problem. Wir haben es ja auch in Deutschland gesehen, O2 hatte ja auch jahrelang ein relativ brauchbares Netz, bis er halt das mit der Werbung oder den Tarifen so übertrieben hat, dass die Leute wirklich zu ihnen gekommen sind. Und dann haben sie es halt nicht mehr geschafft, den Kundenzuwachs, den sie bekommen haben, in ihrem Netzausbau zu reflektieren. Das heißt, dann kippt es jetzt sozusagen plötzlich, dass das O2-Netz so richtig umbrochen war.
Vielleicht wollten sie das auch gar nicht im Ausbau reflektieren, weil es ja auch kostet Geld.
Aber dann, wie gesagt, so wird halt eben auch aus einem Paulus eben relativ schnell ein Saulos, wenn er erstmal genau oder richtig viele Kunden hat.
Also ich denke auch, dass der das Spielchen weitetreibt, bis er so viele Prozente im Markt hat, dass er dann halt auch das nicht mehr macht.
Dann geht er zu Sprint und beschimpft die Telekom, weil sie ihr Netz nicht ausbaut.
Du meinst, er geht immer zu denen, wo er gerade schimpfen kann?
Ja, das ist doch ein super Ding. Du suchst halt jemanden aus, machst einfach nur ein bisschen was anderes als die anderen. Ja, und du kannst immer auf die anderen schimpfen. Das ist doch ein Plan.
Naja, aber so ein bisschen was anderes sind die ja nicht. Also ich meine, ich habe es glaube ich schon mal erzählt. Das letzte Mal als ich in Amiland war, da sind wir irgendwie bei AT&T rein und haben mal so gefragt, wie denn das ist. Wir wollten mal so für zwei Wochen irgendwie eine SIM-Karte mit Daten. Und da wollten die nur für die SIM-Karte, ohne alles, nur die SIM-Karte, ein Stück Plastik in die Hand, wollten die schon 50 Dollar haben. Und dann wollte er uns noch für einen Monat irgendwie einen Tarif von 70 Dollar in die Hand geben.
Sei froh, dass du überhaupt eine einzelne SIM-Karte gekriegt hast.
Dann sind wir rüber in den T-Mobile Shop und dann haben die gesagt, ja klar, könnte er haben, hier SIM-Karte kostet irgendwie, ich glaube 5 Dollar oder 10 Dollar.
Ich glaube T-Mobile ist drüben in USA der Einzelne, der einen Nicht-Prepay-Vertrag anbieten, der keine Laufzeit hat. Der Einzelne in ganz USA. Also einen regulären Plan, wo du jetzt nicht immer wieder aufladen musst, aber einen, der dich nicht gleich 24 Monate kettet.
Wir sind dahin und dann haben die gesagt, ja, wie viele Tage wollt ihr? Ja, 12 Tage. Und dann haben wir irgendwie 12 Tage 3 Dollar bezahlt. Und dann war gut. Gut, dann stecke ich die SIM-Karte rein, halbe Stunde später klingelt das Telefon, ruft einer an aus Texas und weiß nicht, was von dem. Also das ist irgendwie so. Also ja, nee, also ich glaube, die wechseln auch ihre, recyceln ihre Telefonnummern so schnell, dass irgendwie, also das fand ich ein bisschen strange, aber ich glaube, das ist auch ein Ding, was sie machen.
Ich sehe immer die Kollegen hier aus den Teams oder so, die Amis, die halt hier in Europa rumlaufen mit ihrer eigenen Nummer, was normalerweise ja auch ein Arm und ein Bein kostet. Und ich denke immer so, T-Mobile, alles klar. Aber die ganzen armen AT&T-Schweine, denen muss ich immer in welche lokalen SIM-Karten hier besorgen, wenn wir irgendwo 14 Tage rumtonen oder so. Aber die T-Mobile-Jungs, die lassen einfach gnadenlos ihr SIM drin und fertig.
Die 5 Gigabyte kosten hier 40 Dollar. Also mal locker die Hälfte von dem was.
Aber es ist jetzt nur Data, also ohne Phone und alles.
Und eben der nette Data Stash, also which rolls your unused 4G LTE Data into the next month. Also übrigens into the next month, ist auch noch so eine Geschichte.
Nur in the next month und nicht noch ein weiter oder wie?
Also kriegt man hier einen normalen Telefonvertrag und nicht so ein Data only.
Das Problem ist leider noch, dass T-Mobile in den USA leider bei der Frequenzvergabe so ein bisschen daneben getreten ist oder nicht powervoll genug war oder zu spät kam. Deswegen nutzen die leider Frequenzbändern, die man mit unseren europäischen Telefonen zum Beispiel nicht so gut benutzen kann oder jedenfalls maximal mit 3G. Außer jetzt glaube ich iPhone 6. Beim iPhone 6 ist es egal inzwischen, weil du so viele Bänder unterstützt. Wenn du bei deinem iPhone 5 dahin fährst, dann spielt sich der LTE-Messie nicht so viel ab.
Beim iPhone 6 gibt es noch viele verschiedene Hardwares.
Es gibt noch die CDMA-Variante für Verizon. Das ist ja nochmal ganz anders.
Aber bei LTE-Messie gibt es noch eine Version weltweit.
Oder noch eine so für China. Aber in jedenfalls nicht mehr so wie früher von den Fimbern, wo es so 20 Modelle von gab. Trotzdem ein Dutzend oder sowas. Aber von den iPhones gibt es nur noch zwei oder drei Modelle. Also abgesehen von der CDMA-Variante. Ja, übrigens wer jetzt in die USA fährt, sich dort ein Telefon kaufen will im Apple Store, was auch hier Chancen hätten zu funktionieren und auch drüben keine Sorgen macht und so wegen SIM-Locking, der soll bitte im Apple Store hingehen und nach einem T-Mobile-Phone fragen. Das ist nämlich die Variante, die im Apple Store verkauft wird, die einem Europäer am wenigsten Sorgen bereitet. Leider auch die, die am seltensten im Apple Store vorrätig ist. Keine Empfehlung.
Und man muss relativ, also man sollte überhaupt erstmal einmal in den Apple Store gehen und dann mit den Leuten reden, wann die ihre Telefone wahrscheinlich kriegen und wie viele Leute da ankommen, um die einzusacken und gleich nach China zu verschicken. Und dann muss man den richtigen...
Das ist immer nur in der Übergangsphase, wo es den China nicht gibt, aber die gibt es ja inzwischen in China und dann ist das wieder vorbei.
Aber es gibt irgendwie da so einen Blühendenhandel mit SIM-unlocked-phones und so weiter. Und da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen. Aber einfach erstmal hingehen und mal nachfragen. Und man kann dort auch einfach auf der Webseite irgendwie nachts, glaube ich, kommen die dann rein. Und dann kannst du dann klicken, hier reservieren. Dann kannst du am nächsten Tag hingehen und das abholen.
Das ist übrigens auch bei US-Stores so, dass du hier im Store und auch auf dem iPhone kannst du sagen, ich will jetzt gerne ein iPhone kaufen. Dann gibt's da so Buttons, zeig mir mal die in Läden in deiner Nähe, die das Ding im Lager haben. Das geht in Deutschland nicht, aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Hier musst du mal hingehen und die pollen oder anrufen. Heute haben wir voll die Telekom-Sendungen. Ich finde, die sollten uns jetzt mal was spenden dafür.
Ja, auch so ein Hasennussknacker oder eine schöne Samsung-Decke.
Ne, 5G für Oma oder so, jeden Monat. Ist egal, aber wir empfehlen das alles nicht. Wir weisen nur darauf hin, dass es sowas gibt. Und warum es sowas nicht eher gab und warum es zu teuer ist, darauf weisen wir hin.
Und warum das immer noch so scheiße funktioniert im Zug und diese Hardspots und diese Einloggerei und überhaupt, dann kommt mal klar. Und nennt eure Apps nicht Online-Manager? Online-Manager.
Echt. Bist du schon drin?
Online-Manager, das hat schon sowas...
Seit Borus Becker ist irgendwie nichts passiert.
Das war wirklich der letzte Meilenstein, den sich Deutschland noch auf die Fahne schreiben kann.
Wir sollten auch gleich nochmal ein bisschen über Kongress reden. Ich bin ja gerade so ein bisschen gehandicapt. Mir haben sie ja irgendwie mein iPhone geklaut. Mir wurde was entwendet.
Wie denn das?
Sehr Deppenklassiker.
Nehme jetzt mal so zur Kenntnis, dass mir was entwendet wurde. Unter anderem auch mein iPhone.
Das war bestimmt ein Fan.
Nein.
Der wollte Persönliches von dir. Der hat zu Hause ein Altar mit deinem Bild drüber. Genau, da steht jetzt dein ganzer Kram aufgebaut.
Dennis, meine Fans sind nicht so wie deine Fans. Ja, was weiß ich auf wieviel Kamin-Simpsons du da schon so Budoesk als kleine Tonfigur thronst.
Ich habe kaum Patronen. Dann gehen die Rechner besser. Du hast ja keine.
Ich bin Bogonoid.
Bogonen im Mittern.
Deswegen geht ja bei dir auch immer nichts. Bei mir geht nämlich immer alles.
Ja, ich teste die Dinger halt richtig. Derzeit teste ich wieder mein altes iPhone 4.
Und? Ist schnell?
Ja, ist mal eine ganz interessante.
4 oder 4S?
4.
Hattest du schon ein iOS 8?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Geht auch nicht, ne?
Nein, geht nicht. Das heißt, ich bin von iOS 8, von einem 64-Bit-2013-Device auf ein 20-10-32-Bit-Device mit entsprechenden Einschränkungen und einem OS davor, dem OS, was ich nicht mag, zurückgegangen.
Und wie fühlt es sich so an?
Es ist erstaunlich langsam. Also damals, als das ja rauskam, war das ja total rocket-fast.
Aber sowas von...
Und obwohl es irgendwie Retina hatte und so, es war ja einfach...
Das war das letzte Single-Core, ne? Kann sein, ja. Das 4S war das erste Doppel-Duel-Core, oder?
Ja, das Problem scheint mir hier vor allem speichert zu sein. Also die Anforderungen von iOS 7 sind natürlich etwas heftiger als die von iOS 6. Und das ist, glaube ich, das Problem. Und ja, also hier kann man also kaum zwei oder drei Programme gleichzeitig wirklich fahren. Also ich habe das jetzt zum Beispiel zum Laufen benutzt, so mit Runtastic. Und dann poppt irgendwie wieder irgendein wirrer Dialog, der mich die ganze Zeit erinnern möchte, dass ich doch mal bitte meinen Restore zu Ende führen wollte. Und er bräuchte jetzt mal unbedingt WLAN, während ich laufe. Dann tippe ich da halt irgendwie so, während ich laufe, drauf rum, panisch, weil ich irgendwie möchte, dass das alles weggeht. Und dann ist natürlich irgendwie die Runtastic-App mittlerweile schon hinten über gekippt, weil irgendwie zu wenig Speicher. Dann werden die Dinge ja einfach gequittet. Immerhin sind die schon ein bisschen darauf vorbereitet, dass wenn man sie dann schnell wieder startet, dass sie sagen so, oh, ich bin wahrscheinlich hier gerade gekillt worden. Möchtest du, dass ich jetzt hier mal grad deinen Vick neu interpoliere? Und dann hat er nicht wirklich die Daten verloren. Das war schon ganz elegant. Trotz alledem, es ist wirklich ein Krampf. Und natürlich kann ich jetzt auch meine ganzen modernen Devices hier mit Pulsmeter und so weiter nicht benutzen, weil kein Bluetooth 4 und so einfach erstaunlich, was das Gerät alles nicht hat, 5 Gigahertz hat es nicht und so weiter und so weiter und so weiter. Also ich frage mich halt, ob das so angemessen ist wirklich, ob so ein altes Gerät dann auch noch so ein neues OS drauf zu feuern. Das hätte nicht unbedingt sein müssen, naja.
Na ja, auf der anderen Seite, wenn es das nicht bekommen hätte, dann hätten wieder die Leute geweint, dass sie das neueste OS nicht bekommen.
Ja, aber es gibt ja auch keine Wahl, dass man sagt, hier ich mach mir ein 6er drauf, das geht ja dann nicht mehr, ne?
Du, ich hab erst letzte Woche einen Bug gefixt, der nur auf dem iPhone 4 auftritt, weil das so fürchterlich wenig Speicher hat.
Na ja, es ist ja nur eine Übergangsphase. Ich hab mir natürlich dann noch mal kurz in mich gegangen, durfte mich sozusagen noch mal fragen, welches Gerät ich eigentlich gerne haben möchte.
Und jetzt hast du dir einen 6 Plus gekauft?
Nee.
Ein 6. Ein 5S.
Ja, ich hab mir jetzt noch mal ein 5S auf eBay geschossen. Wie schon zuvor. Ich wäre ja auch sofort in so einen scheiß Apple Store eingeladen, schnell mir ein 5S gekauft, aber Apple verkauft es ja nicht in 64 GB, sondern nur noch in 32 GB. Warum auch immer.
Der 10 GB im Monat runterlädt, braucht auch...
Das hält ja dann sonst nur drei Monate. Nein, klar, ich will viel Speicher haben, weil, weißt du, dann filmst du mal was mit, dann machst du mal ein paar Fotos, da ist der Speicher voll, die Apps fressen einfach extrem viel Platz und dann willst du nochmal so 10 GB Podcast rumliegen haben, für alle Fälle, ein paar Videopodcasts, etc. Da kommt ja ganz schön schnell was zusammen. Und andererseits akzeptiere ich das jetzt einfach überhaupt nicht, dass das Gerät auch in mehr gibt und ich kann mehr jetzt nicht kaufen, nur weil Apple der Meinung ist, mehr wäre jetzt auf einmal nicht mehr angemessen bei dem Gerät. Und das ist vor allem insofern eine totale Frechheit, als das... Mir ist einfach das 6er zu groß. Und von dem 6 Plus will ich gar nicht erst anfangen. Das mit dem Frühstücksbrettchen, schön und gut. Klar, wenn man das als Mini-Tablet benutzt, ich verstehe das alles. Man kann das auch machen, das ist super. Ich will aber auch kein Telefon haben, dass wenn ich auf den Tisch lege, was wackelt. Ich meine, schämst du dich nicht? Ich würde mich schämen.
Ich meine es ist voll okay. Ich habe ein 5S.
Aber würdest du dich nicht schämen, wenn du so ein... Das ist doch schlimm.
Ist schon schick.
Ja schick, es wackelt. Und dann haben sie irgendwie... Dann machen sie es dünner, ohne Not, anstatt da einfach mal mehr Akku reinzumachen.
So, wegen dem Ding hier.
Ja, wegen der Kamera. Das wackelt einfach.
Die Kamera ist geil.
Aber du machst doch eh eine Hülle drum, oder nicht? Da wackelt auch nichts mehr.
Ja, da können sie auch einfach mehr Akku reinmachen.
Seit Product Red gibt es bei Apple auch ordentliche Farben. Nämlich Rot.
Und wie lange hält dir das Rot?
Das hält gut.
Geht so, guck mal, die ist erst drei Wochen alt.
Und der Rand ist schon schwach.
Nein, ich glaube, die sitzt... Ja, okay, die habe ich aber auch immer in der Hosentasche.
Also ich kann ja hier diese Hülle von... Was heißt das? Kawaii empfehlen, ja, so eine schöne Ledersteckhülle. Ich habe seit immer schon immer so eine Ledersteckhülle.
Ja, Steckhüllen kommen gar nicht in Frage.
Die sind für mich super, gibt es keine Kratzer. Wohl behütet.
Puckel macht keinen Touch?
Das ist mal ein Statement.
Und es ist wirklich so. Also er meint, das ist einfach zu geil.
Es ist euch übrigens mal aufgefallen, dass wenn man diese Touch anmacht, dass dann sozusagen man auch dazu gezwungen wird, intensiv zu bedürzen, weil dann kannst du nämlich nicht mehr diese Minimumzeit auf 5 Minuten setzen oder sowas, sondern gehst du fest auf sofort. Das heißt, wenn du Touch-Ding anmachst, musst du immer dein Telefon sofort mit Touch entsperren.
Wenn du es gelockt hast.
Oder wenn es sich ausgeht. Früher konntest du ja so eine Gnadenfrist einstellen. Wenn du dich ausgemacht hast, machst du jetzt innerhalb der nächsten 5 Minuten wieder an, denn nicht nach Code fragen und so. Diese Funktionalität ist halt disabled in dem Moment, wo du Touch benutzt.
Dann bist du so schnell wieder drin, also ich meine, das ist einfach egal.
Naja, das ist nicht ganz egal, weil es gibt ja auch Situationen, wo einfach dein Touch nicht gut erkannt wird.
Ja, wenn es regnet und du noch so Finger hast.
Oder wenn du so Handschuhe an hast.
Es gibt ja jetzt diese Handschuhe mit eingewobenen Metallfäden. Die funktionieren nicht mit Touch ID.
Im Winter kannst du Touch ID einfach nicht benutzen.
Ich hätte nicht dran gedacht, dass es woanders mal schneit.
Aus diesem Grund habe ich kein Touch ID. Wenn Touch ID nicht geht, geht auch das normale Touch ID nicht mehr so wirklich. Wenn mein Finger nass ist, dann ist sowieso vorbei. Weil dein Display meistens auch nass ist.
Mit Handschuhen geht Touch ID per Definition nicht. Und wenn du das konfiguriert hast, also ich könnte dir ja sagen, ich mache so einen 10-Minuten-Timeout, dann wärs ja noch so halbwegs zu vertragen. Du machst halt einmal einen Unlock, und dann kannst du es halt mal 10 Minuten benutzen, auch mit Handschuhen. Und wenn es dann einmal gelockt ist, dann machst du es halt wieder anders.
Man kann es im Winter schon los, auch oben schalten auf den Wintermotor.
Ja, Luxusprobleme. Wenn es so viel Grad hat, dann schaltet der Touch ID aus.
Toll, sehe ich schon die Liebe, wenn man das Telefon in den Kühlschrank legen.
Oder hier einer im Chat hat gemeint, auf Nasenspitze anzulernen.
Ah, wie geil.
Keine Ahnung, ob das geht. Vielleicht war das nur eine Quatsche.
Nee, das haben doch Leute im Ausfeld, die da Möche probiert haben, auf den Ding anzulernen.
Aber auf der Nase sind doch gar keine, da sind doch diese, wie heißt die, Papillen, oder wie heißen die Dinger hier?
Das ist eine geile Idee.
Aber wahrscheinlich geht es dann mit jeder Nase, oder?
Na ja, auf jeden Fall habe ich mir jetzt ein 5S geklickt und ich hoffe, das erreicht mich jetzt auch noch rechtzeitig. Sieht eigentlich ganz gut aus. Und dann bin ich wieder oldschool unterwegs.
Und dann kommt es erst nachdem du zum Kongress bist, genau einen Tag danach.
Nee, das kommt wohl hoffentlich morgen.
Ich wollte noch auf den Kongress schlenken.
Warte, ich will nur kurz hier meine tolle iPhone 6 Lederhülle noch in den Chat werfen. Wir sind ja hier zwischendurch für...
Wir haben doch letztes Mal schon ausführlich besprochen.
Ja, aber ich möchte gerne die vielen Klicks haben.
Das ist so in dem Preissegment für... Ist hübsch und kann man jemanden eine Freude machen. Und hier Geschenkidee, bitteschön.
Und ich wollte noch einen ganz kurzen Nachtrag sagen zu meiner Story mit Ich wechsle rüber auf die Dark Side, der Macht, da gibt es nämlich noch was zu berichten.
Die Magenta-Side.
Zu Magenta-Side der Macht. Ich war nämlich gerade in München, als mir diese Idee aufkam und dachte mir, da ich mich nicht so trauere, das mit irgendwelchen Hotliner zu besprechen, gehe ich doch mal zu unserem Hörer, dem guten Arno.
Da bin ich ja auch als Telekom-Opfer seit.
Und habe ihn dann da besucht in seinem Laden, im Telekom-Shop in Giesing, in Tegensea Platz. Das ist jetzt meine Empfehlung, weil der Knabe ist echt nett und kümmert sich. Das war nämlich so ein bisschen, nachdem ich mich jetzt schon für diesen Tarif entschieden hatte, was schon echt Überwindung gekostet hat, habe ich mir gedacht, aber stirbst du dich jetzt in diesen wahnsinnigen Wust von Papierkram und unterschreiben sie hier und melden sie da ab und kündigen sie dort nicht und portieren sie aber hier. Und da hat mich der Arno sehr gut betreut, gerade eben weil solche Sachen wie SitMagenta1 oder Magenta1 kannst du erst klicken, wenn deine SIM-Karte aktiv ist und bla. Da gibt es ja bestimmte Sachen, dass man das in der richtigen Reihenfolge macht. Da lohnt es sich also, einen solchen Profi zur Hand zu haben. Aber denn so die Wechselerfahrung, ich war ja erst ein bisschen misstrauisch. Ich hab also bei Conxter nicht gekündigt, sondern dachte einfach nur auf Leute, ich möchte gerne meine Nummer haben. Ist vielleicht auch ein Tipp, das wissen vielleicht noch nicht alle Hörer. Auch wenn euer Vertrag nicht abgelaufen ist, die Telekom oder wer auch immer, euer Mobilprovider, darf nicht mehr eure Rufnummer als Geisel nehmen. Das heißt, ihr könnt einfach hingehen und sagen, ich möchte gerne meine Rufnummer zu einem anderen Anbieter portieren. Ja, ich hab noch x Monate Rechtslaufzeit bei euch. Scheiß drauf. Ich möchte gerne meine Nummer haben. Dann wird die Vorvertragsende freigegeben und dann kann man die greifen. Ich hab zwar jetzt keine Vertragslaufzeit bei Kongstar gehabt, hab aber trotzdem nicht gekündigt, weil ich der ganzen Sache nicht getraut habe. Also bin ich hingegangen, hab erst mal gesucht, gibt natürlich keine Formulare für sowas auf der Kongstar. Es gibt jede Menge Formulare auf der Kongstar Webseite, wie du deine Rufnummer zu ihnen portieren kannst von jemandem an, aber nicht wie man sie von ihnen wegkriegt. Aber dann haben die so einen Kunden-Chat und ich dachte, okay, na das wird ja was. Auf denen krieg ich jetzt wieder blöde Ansagen und so. Und ich so, hallo, ich möcht gern meinen Provider wechseln, ich muss zu eurer Mutter wechseln und hin und her. Wie krieg ich denn meine Nummer freigeschaltet? So, wart, wart, wart, Minute später. So, deine Nummer ist jetzt auf der Freigabe, du hast zwei Monate Zeit, die abzugreifen. Ich so, okay, cool, das war einfach. Dann zum Arno, der hat ja den Vertragthaler schon da, hat gesagt, klick du mal Execute und innerhalb von, glaube ich, nicht ganz sechs Tagen machte das so, kurz nach Null Uhr machte das so. Plöng, der Kongstar schrieb mir, ich hatte beide SIM-Karten im Telefon drin, der Kongstar schrieb mir so, du hast jetzt eine andere Rufnummer, die haben, wenn du da nicht kündigst, deine alte Nummer wegnimmst, geben sie dir automatisch eine neue. Also ohne SIM-Wechsel, ohne dass ich Telefon gebootet habe, wie sagt einfach so, hier hast du eine neue Nummer, plöff, so kam so automatisch. Und die Telekom aktivierte einfach brav ihr Ding und sagte so, du bist jetzt da und hier ist deine Rufnummer und das war halt meine portierte Rufnummer. Also das kriegen sie inzwischen hin.
Ob das jetzt nur Mutter und Tochter klappt oder ob man das genauso gut zwischen O2 und T-Mobile machen kann oder wie auch immer, sei mal dahingestellt, aber die Prozeduren sind immerhin da und das geht. Also auch vorzeitig das Mitnehmen von Rufnummern geht. Kann ich also empfehlen, dass man das tun kann.
So zum Thema Geschenkideen. Ist mir doch eingefallen, ich hab hier noch was, was ich schon so ein paar, zwei, drei Monate jetzt hab. Nennt sich Ultra Thin Keyboard Folio M1 und ist so eine Hülle mit Bluetooth-Tastatur fürs iPad Mini.
Während Tim noch mit den Fingern tippt, tippt Roddy entspannt in die Tasten.
Mit Füßen.
Wie, das kann man dann hier so eindocken, oder? Mit Magneto und dann steht das da so.
Ja, mit Magneto und dann kannst du da tippen.
Ist sogar Tüskertastatur hier so mit Quarz.
Ist Tüskertastatur mit Quarz, genau. Ja, habe ich ja auch im Apple Store gekruft.
Das heißt ja nichts.
Nee, das heißt natürlich nichts. So, jetzt musst du das Ding mal irgendwie wieder angehen.
Aber du kannst deinen Gürtnisch eingeben, oder?
Doch, kann ich machen. Sobald der hier mal ankommt, kann ich meinen Code eingeben.
Und dann kann man da ordentlich drauf tippen.
Ich will jetzt kein Software-Update machen. Danke fürs Angebot.
Findest du auch mit Command-Tab zwischen deinen Ups hin und her switchen?
Gute Frage. Nee, das geht irgendwie nicht.
Schade.
Es gibt ein Home-Button-Dingens. Okay. Es gibt so einige Tastenkombinationen. Manche funktionieren komisch. Es gibt die Tastenkombination für die Spotlight-Suche. Aus irgendeinem bekloppten Grund aktiviert er aber nicht das Eingabe-Feld. Das heißt, er schaltet zwar die Suche an, aber du kannst nicht tippen. Gibt es auch eine Tab-Taste? Wir können es noch mal versuchen.
Wo ist die Tab-Taste?
Die Tab-Taste ist hier mit FN. Wenn ich Tab drücke, geht es tatsächlich.
Mich würde interessieren, das wäre eine echte Anwendung für diese Ding. Meine Server haben die Angewohnheit, dass sie super gut funktionieren. Ohne auch nur einen Mux, solange ich einen Laptop bei mir trage. Soweit ich es wage, den zu Hause zu lassen, gibt es irgendein Problem. Scheiß drauf, Festplatte voll oder irgendein Kack. Deswegen fände ich es echt mal ganz gut.
Der zählt natürlich auch als Rechner, dann gehen die auch immer. Murphy kann man nicht austrecken.
Nur solange eine Scheiß-Tastatur dran ist. Ich hab zwar SSH-Klines auf meinem iPad und sowas, aber das nervt trotzdem. Deswegen fände ich für sowas gerade die Tastatur sehr gut. Aber deswegen würde ich zum Beispiel gerne wissen, was so ist mit den ganzen Dingern, die Apple als Special ansieht. Etzeichen, Batslashes, ob das auch im SSH-Kline ordentlich geht. Im Großen und Ganzen?
Naja, ich kann dir das jetzt nicht 100% versprechen.
Schick doch mal einen Link.
Oder lass mich mal hacken. Wert mal hier Rute auf dem Rechner.
Du bist hier doch am Meta-Content. Die machen hier gerade Produktvorstellungen.
Ich bin total bei euch.
Ich will auch noch eine Sache vorstellen als Geschenkidee vielleicht. Für manche Zocker, die schon ein bisschen älter sind, die werden sich erinnern. Früher, C64, das Spiel Elite. Da gab es irgendwann in den 90ern noch mal einen zweiten Teil. Also das erste Elite war ja Wireframe. Dann kam im 90ern noch mal ein zweiter Teil. Der war dann schon mit gefüllten Flächen. Ja, du konntest dir ausruhen, ob du nur rumfliegst und andere Piraten killst oder Polizisten oder was auch immer da so rumfliegt. Und dann wurdest du halt gesucht da und hast irgendwie ein schweres Leben, weil irgendwann haben sie dich dann doch weggeballert. Oder ob du auch so ein bisschen Trading gemacht hast und du musstest immer Trading machen, um deinen Raumschiff irgendwie aufzubessern. Also, ja, die Welt war, ich glaube, auch damals schon ganz schön ziemlich, war riesig groß eigentlich, oder? So eine generierte Welt. Wie das Spiel in den 90ern war, weiß nicht. Ich hab's mir gekauft, aber ich glaube, richtig viel gespielt hab ich's nicht. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, auf welchem Rechner. War auf einer Amiga oder was? War nicht mehr so doll. Doch, genau, ich hab die Original-Sketten noch zu Hause. Ist egal, jedenfalls jetzt dieser David Braben, das ist übrigens auch der, der das Raspberry-Pie-Projekt gemacht hat oder mit gefördert hat. Das ist nämlich einer der Elite-Entwickler von damals. Der hat per Kickstarter wohl vor zwei Jahren das Voll an mir vorbei gegangen, hat jetzt Geld gesammelt für den dritten Teil. Und der ist jetzt, heute ist der 16. oder wann? Nee, gestern war der 16. Er ist gestern rausgekommen, heißt Elite Dangerous. Also ich hab das auch nur bei Heise gelesen, ist echt komplett an mir vorbei gegangen. Und das ist halt wieder Elite, aber in richtig schick, jetzt so richtig 3D und fancy Grafiken und Smooth und alles. Und sie haben da 400 Milliarden Sternensystem eingebaut, also generiert halt. Und das ist ein Multiplayer-Game, das heißt du spielst nicht mehr alleine, sondern du fliegst darum. Der Witz ist, der Weltraum ist so groß, du siehst eigentlich erstmal niemand, weil du bist halt auf irgendeinem von diesen 400 Milliarden Sternen und da ist halt kein Schwein. Also du musst schon irgendwo echt dich mit Leuten verabreden oder irgendwo hinfahren, wie Erde zum Beispiel, wo ein bisschen mehr los ist. Aber ansonsten kannst du halt auch in diesem Planet oder Sternensystem rumfliegen in diesem Universum und kannst halt noch Sterne entdecken. Und dann ist der Witz, dass die eine Beta-Phase hatten und jetzt haben sie gesagt, gestern oder schon letzte Woche, dass sie, wenn die Version 1.0 rauskommt, dass sie die Beta-Phase nicht löschen. Das heißt, der Zustand, normalerweise nach der Beta-Phase fängt man ja noch mal für alle, damit alle von vorne anfangen. Die haben gesagt, wir wippen nicht, wir lassen alles so, wie es ist. Und haben sich viel aufgeregt. Und dann meinten die aber, ja, wir haben hier 400 Milliarden Sterne. Davon wurde jetzt keine Ahnung, nicht mal ein Millionstel irgendwie erforscht. Also das fällt gar nicht auf, dass da schon Leute...
400 Milliarden Sterne.
Na, die ist wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht groß, weil sie wahrscheinlich eine Datenbank haben, die immer nur dann das neue Sternensystem angelegt wird. Wenn wirklich dann auch mal irgendwann einer hinfliegt. Vorher nicht. Also vorher existierte wahrscheinlich als ID oder als Position im Raum, aber noch ohne Daten. Und du kannst glaube ich hinfliegen, der Erste sein, der das entdeckt und kannst dem scheiß Sternensystem dann erstmal einen Namen geben. Solange das aber keiner macht, gibt's den Eintrag nicht. Das heißt, die haben keine Datenbank mit 400 Milliarden Sterne, sondern die haben nur erstmal 400 Milliarden Positionen. Und die, wenn sie ein bisschen schlau sind, man kann ja, du kennst ja so Random Seed, man kann ja, dass alle Spieler mit dem gleichen Seed starten und dann ist da sozusagen so eine generierte Welt, die man aber gar nicht haben muss, sondern man generiert sie sich dadurch. Einfach die Generation ist auf jedem Spiel bei jedem Player das gleiche.
400 Milliarden heißt ja so was wie, wenn du für jede nur einen Byte brauchst, hättest du schon irgendwie 400 Gigabyte.
Alter, wo ist das Problem?
Also wie gesagt...
Was lädst du dir einfach auf deinen 32 Gigabyte ein?
Die 400 Milliarden Sterne werden auch, wenn da hunderttausende Spieler spielen, die werden einfach nie alle komplett entdeckt werden, weil so viel Zeit gibt's gar nicht. Hat einer mal durchgerechnet. Also die könnten alle da jahrelang spielen und das würden trotzdem nur innerhalb der nächsten 10 Jahre 7% der Sterne da irgendwie erforschen können. Oder irgendwie so. Also es ist einfach so viel, es geht einfach nicht. Deswegen, die packen einfach das, was erforscht wird, das sind so ein paar hunderttausend Sterne vielleicht demnächst, packen in so eine Datenbank und das ist alles gar kein Ding. Ist egal, die haben das irgendwie gemeistert und das Coole an dem Spiel ist wohl, dass es so schick ist, dass da Leute das Spiel nur spielen, weil sie gerne durch den Weltraum fliegen, so flugsimulatormäßig und überhaupt gar nicht traden und auch gar nicht rumballern, sondern die mögen es von einem Sternsystem zum nächsten zu fliegen, weil es alles so schick aussieht.
Klickt doch mal auf die Webseite, da ist wirklich sehr schön, wenn die da in die Sonne vorbei fallen.
Ich seh ja keinen Link.
Na hier hast du sofort irgendwie...
Mein Sidekick macht das auch nicht.
Brauchst du hier im... Moment, morgen? Was ist denn das? Wo kommt das her?
Da.
Ja, gibt's leider erst mal nur für den PC.
Die Mac-Version...
Die Mac-Version kommt in wohl 2-3 Monaten oder so. Aber wenn man sich jetzt die PC-Version kauft, dann kriegt man automatisch, wenn die Mac-Version kommt, kann man auch die runterladen und benutzen. Also wenn jetzt jemand auch einen Mac unten einen PC hat, kann er sich's schon holen. Cobra MK3, ja das will ich. Nee, Viper MK3, yeah.
Geh mal eins zurück auf der Startseite, da scrollen so die Screens vorbei mit Animationen und so. Da gibt's auch das an der Sonne vorbei fliegen und das alles. So, so.
Und man muss immer noch in diesem Drehen in Thailand, was die übrigens von 2001 geklaut haben. Also ich hab ja dieses an der schönen blauen Donau, das ist der Song ja bei 2001, den hab ich ja zuerst kennengelernt bei Elite, weil da haben die das nämlich komplett geklaut, auch mit diesem Reindrehen. Und dann hab ich 2001 geguckt und dann dachte ich, ey, die haben das ja geklaut, aber es war natürlich andersrum. Aber ich hab's halt da zuerst gesehen.
Ja, und fliegen die jetzt nochmal hier an der Sonne, da guckt ihr das an, der Thunder-Schock.
Da muss dem aber ganz schön warm werden.
Also das Spielprinzip ist glaube ich relativ ähnlich wie bei dem ersten Elite, deswegen...
Waren die Raumschiffe Krach im Weltall?
Na, man hat ja schon gerade Explosionen da gesehen und so, also ich denke, so ganz...
Explodierend tun Dinge auch im Weltall, also man macht absolut keinen Krach dabei.
Ganz echt ist es glaube ich nicht.
Hört ihr ja auch gerade, liebe Hörer, ihr hört nämlich nichts. Wir gucken gerade voll die Action.
Ich habe auch vorhin bei John Ledger, bei deinem Video nichts gehört.
Hast du so einen Regler nicht gezogen?
Na, wir sind halt hier auch aus dem Weltall, also deswegen machen hier die Sachen keine Geräusche.
Gibt das sowas eigentlich auch? Wo läuft das jetzt auf dem Mac?
Nee, erst noch PC, Mac kommt aber.
Was ist denn hier mit iPad? Geht wieder nicht, brauchen wir wieder Controls für, oder was?
Das ist doch kein Spiel für das iPad. Das ist eher so ein Spiel, wo du dir noch so für 50 Euro so ein Joystick holst mit hier, vor Siehtback wahrscheinlich, und noch mit so einem Thrust-Ding ins...
Kannst du das hier nicht mit dem Google Earth-Knopf machen?
Na ja, und kann man das auch mit Bitcoins bezahlen? Klickt mal bei Elite Dangerous. Die ganzen Indie-Spiele machen das doch jetzt heutzutage.
Aber warum ist der Tim wieder bei Europe? Und ich bin ja noch im scheiß Ami-Laden, und die wollen immer irgendwie... Na nee, Pfund wollen sie haben, aber bei dir? Euros. Und warum hab ich das hier nicht? Ich kann ja nirgendswo das Land umstellen. 50 Euro, ist schon ein ordentlicher Preis. Aber als Fan kann man das immer machen. Man kann ja alle zehn Jahre mal ein Game kaufen.
So, kommen wir nochmal zu Preisen. Preisen? Ja, wir müssen jetzt nochmal über den Kongress reden. Weil das ist nämlich jetzt, steht ihn jetzt nämlich an. Genau, zunächst einmal hier gleich ein Tipp. Es gibt mindestens eine App.
Die wollen wir nicht empfehlen. Ich warte noch auf eine Antwort von Toto.
Warum?
Bevor wir das empfehlen. Weil ich noch nicht weiß, ob ich das toll finde oder Scheiße finde, dass das Ding wieder mal nicht im non-DE-Store zu kriegen ist. Wann glaubt der denn, wie viele Leute aus dem Ausland zum Kongress kommen? Ist es nicht. Also ich frage jetzt gerade nach seiner Rechtfertigung dafür. Ich hab dieses Affentum ja schon ein paarmal beklagt.
Tomato sagt Global Punkt.
Okay, dann weiß nur der Apple Store noch nicht.
Das wurde gerade rausgekommen, gerade.
Okay, gut, dann sei ich ihm verziehen. Aber wie gesagt, ich kenne das ernsthaft. Nee, nee, nee, aber das ist ja in der Tat so. Ich hab das ja schon ein paarmal beklagt, dass gerade Leute, die so eventbezogen sind, was ich BVG abgibt, das nur im deutschen Store. Wahrscheinlich auch die, die ab von dem Hamburger Verkehrsbetrieben. Da fragt man sich so, what the fuck?
Die andere Frage ist, warum läuft es nicht auf dem US7?
Die Portland-App nur im US-Store. Also ich meine, das ist so. Pelixbus heißt die.
Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall. Es gibt sogar zwei 31C3 Fahrplan-Apps. Ich hab nur die von Toto jetzt ein bisschen getestet. Es gibt aber zwei, glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ich hab mir die andere, glaube ich, runtergeladen.
Und Toto, du musst nochmal an dem Logo was machen. Das geht nicht. Du kannst nicht das 31C3-Logo auf zwei Zeilen machen. Das sieht einfach scheiße aus. Das geht einfach nicht. Das Design von Sven, das ist so großartig. Das kann man nicht, das geht nicht.
Ja, dann musst du mal Apple beibringen, Icons anzubieten, die breiter als hoch sind. Ungefähr doppelt so breit.
Dann macht man das halt kleiner.
Dann kannst du das nicht mehr sehen.
Es gibt ein schönes Logo. Das ganze Kongressdesign ist wirklich schick. Da kann man das Logo nehmen, das geht alles.
Wo sieht man das Design?
Das ist noch nicht so richtig ins Web gehoben worden.
Doch, ich glaube, neulich auch ein Tweet, wo das rumging.
Also, es sind ja nur ein paar Tage vor der Veranstaltung.
Ja, ja, es ist furchtbar. Und es gibt keine ordentlichen Hodis.
Ich brauch zwei Stück, weil letztes Jahr war ja so scheiße. Das heißt, ich muss dieses Jahr zwei kaufen. Bei mir gehen meine Klamotten aus.
Ich hab letztes Jahr gar keinen abgekriegt. Na ja, sagen wir mal so, ich war irgendwie nicht in der halben Stunde bis ausverkauft war irgendwie an der Schlange angestanden. Das war ein bisschen nervig.
Ja, das gibt es in der Tat im US-Store. Wenn man weiß wo, findet es bloß nicht. Apple findet es nicht. Aber wenn man einen Link drauf hat, gibt es den doch da. Ja, das ist schick, ne?
Also man kann aus dem Kongressloge auf jeden Fall was machen. So geht es auf jeden Fall nicht. Toto, ich würde das nicht benutzen, wenn eine kleine, ordentliche...
Problem ist, er hat das wahrscheinlich ohnehin gerade so noch geschafft durch so einen Scheiß-App-Review bei Apple. Das heißt, wenn er das jetzt noch mal anlangt, dann kriegt er das eh nicht mehr bis zum Kongress durch. Weil die freezen nämlich. Die Apple-Leute freezen um Weihnachten und sagen, jetzt wird hier nichts mehr erproft und fertig.
Aber in über einer Woche, die freezen erst nach Weihnachten.
Übermorgen.
Submit, kann er jetzt now. Der Dick war jetzt schon expeditiv.
Nee, nee, kannst du vergessen. Übermorgen ist der letzte Moment, wo du in diesem Jahr noch einreichen kannst. Und du kriegst in diesem Jahr nichts mehr durch, auch wenn du jetzt einreichst.
It's over now.
It's over.
Wenn ich weiß, dass zumindest versucht wurde, dann ist es was anderes. Aber wenn man einfach sagt, egal, so geht's nicht. Es sieht aber nie aus.
Brauche ich da einen Direktlink? Also ich finde den zumindest.
Du bist auch nicht im deutschen Store, oder?
Ich bin im deutschen Store.
Da gab's ja den Link. Also die Suche findet's nicht.
Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum aus dem Design keine Webseite geworden ist. Das ist alles ganz flurchtbar.
Den deutschen mitzuhaben?
Stattdessen hat man immer noch dieses alte Seguin-Logo da. Das ist echt toll.
Ja, so die Webpräsenz der Veranstaltung.
Der Kongress ist super und der CCC ist toll. Aber wenn nicht bald mal was passiert im Bereich Web, das ist echt peinlich.
Das war schon immer die große Stärke für CCC.
Ich den Club kenne, ist einfach das Thema Webpräsenz ein Drama.
Aber du warst da mal selber involviert und du leckst doch immer an einem.
Aber ich weiß auch woran es ist.
Wie konnte das passieren, Tim?
Vor allen Dingen an diesem...
Wie konnte jemand, der ästhetisch so engagiert ist, wie du das geschehen lassen?
Ich weiß woran es liegt.
Ich habe da auch durchaus was dagegen getan. Ich habe auch eine ganze Reihe von Webseiten gemacht, die ganz ordentlich aussahen für ihre Zeit. Ich habe auch irgendwie mal aus diesem www.ccc.de mal einen Blog gemacht für eine Weile.
Wow, du Revoluzzer.
Ich bin so total fisch.
Und dafür haben sich bestimmt alle gehasst, ne?
Ja, ich fand das irgendwie komisch. Und ich würde ja da mit dem Internet sprechen und so.
Mit dem Web.
Das Einzige, was mich an der CCC-Seite immer wieder stört, ist, dass sie irgendwie diese, weiß ich nicht, free Software, was weiß ich, Dings da zertifikat haben. Und du klickst es an, irgendeinen Link klickst du an aus dem Twitter, auf dem iPhone, und du kriegst nur eine leere Seite. Geht halt nix.
Wie ich schon sagte, es ist ein Drama.
Das müssen so, weiß ich nicht.
Das ist, weil die Web-Entwickler, die genug Kassen liegen, die lernen das mal programmieren, und dann haben sie keinen Bock mehr auf Web.
Das Einzige, was ich an der Web präsent des Clubs mag, ist gar nichts.
Aber das ordentlich.
Das magst du sehr.
Das ist einfach scheiße.
Ja, aber es sind halt...
Nein, es ist einfach eine Scheiße. Es ist eine glorified Pressebeteilungsschleuder. Es ist einfach null Kommunikation, null Geschmack, null Design, null Affinität, null Community, null Envolvement, null Check, null überhaupt gar nichts, nichts. Das ist einfach schlecht. Da ist der ADAC besser, da ist alles besser auf diesem scheiß fucking Planeten und in Deutschland besonders. In diesem ganzen verkackten, internet-hassenden Deutschland ist jede Webseite, jeder Company besser als die vom CCC. Das ist die Wahrheit.
Ich muss mich jedes Mal durchklicken, um das scheiß Top-Event 30C3 zu finden, wenn ich mal so was gucken will wie Fahrplan oder Online-Streaming.
Ich mach einen Link auf den Event. Der Club schafft es doch nicht mal, seine eigenen Events anzukündigen. Link! Einer! Nichts! Gar nichts!
Es gibt halt keinem, das da sich schreit.
Schämen! Schämen!
Das weiß doch jeder, dass man den unter eventccc.de findet.
Am besten machen wir nächstes Jahr irgendwie nur eine Datenbank, die nach außen offen ist, und dann gibt es da ordentliche schicke Webseiten. Wir müssen einfach nur die Daten sauber zur Verfügung stellen.
Tim, das Ding ist aber auch, es funktioniert ja auch ohne, ne? Also der Kongress ist auch so voll.
Es geht nicht darum, dass er voll ist oder nicht. Es geht darum, dass er einfach auch in der Ästhetik wahrgenommen wird, wie er es verdient hat.
Die Logo ist schon worden.
Und so ein Design, wie wir dieses Jahr haben, das einfach so links-liegen zu lassen, das ist einfach schäbig. Wen das stört?
Ja klar, mich alle stört das. Aber nicht genug. Nicht genug. Also zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, dieses Jahr sind in der Hinsicht so einige Sachen liegen geblieben, wo ich dachte, das hat man doch jetzt, aber das ist schon mal so organisatorisch im Griff. Aber wir brauchen halt mehr ästhetikaffine Menschen im Club. Na ja, vital wird das schon hier noch.
Nein, nicht in dem Segment.
Nein, nicht in dem Segment, ja. Aber ansonsten.
Jaja, man kann sich da gut rausreden, aber es gibt da einfach keine Entschuldigung dafür. Es ist einfach schlecht. Es gibt einfach 0 Punkte dafür. CCC, Web, 0 Punkte, Ende. So, jetzt reg ich mich wieder ein bisschen ab.
Wenn ihr euch berufen, fühlt ihr draußen.
Aber davon mal abgesehen. Kongress findet statt, kommt alle. Wie sieht es mit euch aus? Dennis, du setzt dich wahrscheinlich wieder irgendwo hin und wirkst. Krasse. Na, wirst ja wieder an deiner Stimme erkannt werden.
Nee, ich mache Hinterzimmer.
Aber deine...
Ich bin money back-end, nicht front-end.
Aber deine Tafel ist schon in Hamburg.
Die ist gestern verladen worden. Und ich glaube, der LKW soll heute hinfahren oder spätestens morgen früh. Ja, war irgendwie der Plan, aber irgendwie dann doch und überhaupt. Ohne Nebel. Da muss spätestens morgen Abend da sein oder irgendwie so. Aber Display steht schon drin, ist schon vergottet, ist schon Decke drüber, ist schon festgemacht und Kissen dazwischen zur Wand usw. Soweit ist alles schick.
Haben wir uns eigentlich überhaupt schon mal jemals über dieses Display hier ordentlich unterhalten?
Ich glaube schon und weiß nicht genau. Also immer nur kurz, glaube ich, wenn dann, weil dann immer so eilig und hetzen und schnell mal.
Das ist ja auch nicht so richtig im Web-Stokumentiert, ne?
Wieder gibt es keine Webseite zu.
Aber wir haben jetzt Fortschritt im Gegensatz zum letzten Jahr, weil letztes Jahr war es noch so.
Du kannst noch mal kurz einen Management-Summary machen, wovon wir reden.
Na, der Andy Müller-Margun hat vor, keine Ahnung, fünf, sechs Jahren oder so ist es glaube ich jetzt inzwischen schon her, bei Ebay mal so ein Riesendisplay gekauft, was aus 448 x 160 LEDs besteht, also immer so ein 8 x 8er-Blöckchen, wie man die halt so als Modul so kaufen kann. Und das hatte so einen uralten C64-Chip auf einem Master-Controller drauf, also so eins und so ein ähnliches, vielleicht doppelt so schnell, aber es war alles relativ langsam per Serie angesteuert und du konntest so zugucken, wie er den Text ins Display malte, weil schneller ging es halt nicht. Das war wahrscheinlich so 300 Baudspeed oder sowas. Und das haben wir halt im Club irgendwann mal genommen, also ich hauptsächlich, und haben das alles mal neu gemacht und dann wurde erst, weil einer kannte sich gut mit Admin aus, haben wir alles auf Admin umgebaut, dann kam noch einer und meinte, ja hier, ne, Master-Controller, müssen wir jetzt mal mit Arm und mit Linux machen und mit Ethernet und richtig und schick und schnell und alles und das haben wir alles gemacht und jetzt ist das Ding so schnell, dass es halt auch Videos in flüssig anzeigen kann und ich glaub, ne Menge von den Hörern hier vielleicht oder ein paar zumindest, waren schon mal im Berliner Club und da wird es ja auch öfters immer vorgeführt, ich mach das immer gerne an, wenn irgendwie neue Leute kommen, damit sie was zum Gucken haben und so und das ist schon immer beeindruckt. Auf den Kongress dachte ich auch, ist jetzt gar nicht so spannend und so, aber ich hab dann auch immer, ich lass immer gerne Coins Katzi laufen, weil ich find den Film einfach super und dann kommen die Leute schon und dann stehen die erstmal da und sind hooked, weil die tatsächlich anfangen da diesen Film zu gucken. Also irgendwann merkt man auch gar nicht mehr, weil es ist eigentlich knallgrün. Irgendwann ist es den Leuten egal, sie gucken einfach, weil das Bild ist so flüssig, dass es einfach funktioniert. Jedenfalls, letztes Jahr haben wir die Eintrittspreise nochmal so angezeigt und so und das hieß immer, ich muss mich auf dem Ding einloggen, muss den Text im C-File dann bauen und starten.
Und ich musste das Ethernet-Kabel reinstecken zwei, drei Mal und wieder rausziehen, damit keiner dazwischenfunktet oder wie war das?
Ja, irgendwie so, weil wir die nach außen halt offen haben. Da waren auch so ein paar israelische Hacker, die haben ja das dann gleich geowned und gehackt und haben ihr Zeug da selber anzeigen lassen und so. Und die wollten dann aber...
Ah, hier guckt, da haben Leute ein Video in den Chat gepostet vom CTCB.
Die wollten dann irgendwie T-Shirts haben, wenn sie das richtig hacken können. Hab ich gesagt, ja okay, T-Shirt, das können wir irgendwie klar machen, haben sie dann aber doch irgendwie nicht richtig gehackt. Und ja, jedenfalls dieses Jahr haben wir schick einen Web-Interface auf dem Ding. Das heißt, das Ding spielt jetzt selbst Web-Server und da ist dann eine Web-Seite, das ist jetzt aber aus dem Club direkt, wo es noch an der Wand hängt. Haben wir ein Web-Interface, wo sozusagen das Display optisch nachgebildet ist und wo man direkt live drin tippen kann. Und ich weiß nicht, ob wir es noch hinkriegen, weil da war noch ein Bug. Wir haben es sogar so, dass mehrere Leute da tippen können und die dann gleichzeitig den Text auf dem Display editieren. Ja, so Isapad-mäßig, genau. Und das Gleiche aber auch mit Grafik, dass man so malen kann. Es kann sein, dass es noch nicht ganz fertig ist und das mit dem Synchronisieren noch nicht klappt, aber eine Person kann es auf jeden Fall locker machen. Und dann brauche ich eben diesen Kongress nicht mehr C-Code irgendwie editieren und bauen und starten, dass irgendwie da die T-Shirt-Preise angepasst werden, sondern man kann das jetzt einfach im Web-Editor machen oder im Browser machen.
Da, ist nur noch ein anderes Video tatsächlich. Guck an, was die Leute nicht so alles hochladen.
Das kenne ich ja sogar noch nicht mal.
Da gibt es kein Video von Video-Daten-Video.
Ach so, vark Anhalt. Ja, da sieht man ja auch schon, dass es relativ flüssig ist. Habt ihr auch schon einen Chat gepostet?
Ne, noch nicht.
Ja, das Problem bei Zeichentrick oder bei Animationsding ist, dass die meistens mit 12 Frames die Sekunde nur arbeiten, weil die dann sich das Malen sparen wollen ein bisschen.
Dann macht doch mal von Kojanis Katzi mal ein schönes Video, wo auch so die Lichtverhältnisse etwas...
Ja, also ich habe hier auf meinem Laptop, Quatsch, auf meinem Phone habe ich hier was drauf, aber ich warte noch, bis das AirDrop mal so richtig funktioniert. Sonst kriege ich das ja nicht runter. Doch, kriege ich schon runter, aber...
Was, AirDrop für das Display?
Was ich schon immer machen wollte, aber ich bin irgendwie dann doch noch nie zugekommen, was ich noch haben will, ist, dass ich auf meinem Phone mir eine App schreibe, dass ich die Kamera benutze, durch die Gegend laufe und das Bild live auf dem Display landet. Und das ist nicht so schwer, aber es müsste eigentlich gehen.
Ich habe schon vor Jahren mal eine App gehabt, ich weiß nicht, ob die jetzt überhaupt noch funktioniert mit iOS 8 und dralala, aber da konntest du, die hatte einen Counterpart auch auf dem Mac und du konntest deine iPhone-Kamera als normale OS X-Cam benutzen, also wie die Dingsen-Cam hier, wie heißt die, die Ice-Hide oder sonst was. Das heißt, mit allen Tools, die halt eben auch benutzen, wie Skype, Facetime, Lala, Pipapo, kannst du halt eben dann...
Dann schalt das Eingebaute vom Laptop das, dein iPhone benutzen und durch die Gegend gehen.
Genau, und da kannst du vorher noch, weil die sich Auflösungen wiederholen, raten und so was einstellen. Und das geht halt eben auch über WLAN, dass dein iPhone dann an deinen Mac liefert und da tut das halt so, als wäre das ein normales Video-Device.
Ich hätte gern, dass das iPhone ja direkt mit dem Display spricht, weil das macht der UDP, hat ich ja schon mal erzählt. Übrigens habe ich jetzt auch UDP Lite eingebaut, funktioniert wunderbar. Also es geht einfach, hat man schon erzählt, letzte Woche UDP Lite, ja?
Vor zwei, drei Sendungen.
Nee, es funktioniert, es war einfach ganz, ganz easy und das geht. Ich wollte mal halt den neuesten Scheiß auch probieren und das Display macht genau so, wie man das findet.
Hast du jetzt einen Treiber, dass du Sachen, die auf deinem Mac spielen, als Video auf das Display bringen kannst?
Auf meinem Mac, das habe ich auch, aber es geht gerade nicht. Aber ich habe einen, für FreeBSD und Linux habe ich so einen Player.
Dann könnte es, es war ein kleiner Umweg, aber dann könntest du diesen Mechanismus benutzen, dass du halt diese Kamera auf dem Telefon erst zu einer Kamera deines Mac machst. Cool wäre er halt ohne Rechner.
Und das kann ja YuiYui verschicken, also so schwer kann es ja nicht sein eigentlich. Wenn du noch Power hast aufmachen.
Dann musst du aber erstmal abschreiben für das Ding wieder.
Web kann er nicht abschreiben können.
Um an die Kamera zu kommen, musst du eh eine App schreiben.
Ja, nee. Gibt es ja nicht auch so Web-Dinger? Kann der Safari schon diese Extensions?
Ich nix Web.
Web-Verso hier, Koden auf dem iPhone ist ja noch nicht so schwer. Das krieg ich schon hin.
Ich sitz das aus.
Na ja, gibt's auf jeden Fall alles nicht. Wer Lust hat, damit zu haken, kann sich ja...
Also was ich noch brauch, das könnte man ja als Aufruf machen, wenn es so Leute gibt, die gerne so ein kleiner Falk werden möchten. So ein Videokünstler, die vielleicht noch in den Startlöchern stehen, weil der Falk ist ja schon ein richtiger Profi.
Oder ein großer Falk.
Oder den großer Falk werden wollen, genau. Und was ich bräuchte, wäre so eine Art Democoder, so wie früher, nur dass er halt nicht jetzt auf dem C64 seine Demos laufen lässt im Bildschirmspeicher, sondern dass er halt sein Demo im RAM laufen lässt und dass diesen RAM in halt diese 9 Kilobyte, so groß ist unsere Bitmap, nämlich per UDP-Paket einfach an unser Display schickt und dann könnt ihr da richtig fett bis 40 Frames die Sekunde, könnt ihr da alles Mögliche anzeigen lassen. Und was ich gerne hätte, sind so kleine Miniprogramme, so wie die von den Demoscene halt immer so ist, so 10K groß oder 5, keine Ahnung, die schicke Sachen machen, die man startet und die da stundenlang geile Sachen irgendwie auf dem Display anzeigen. Und sowas hätte ich gerne, sowas gibt es mir nicht. Weil Videos anzeigen ist ja eine Sache, ist aber auch ein bisschen lame, aber so ein kleines Tool, was nur irgendwie 5K groß ist, was da stundenlang schöne Sachen macht, das wäre immer richtig cool. Oder wenn ihr andere Ideen habt, so wie mit dem Flip-Dot-Display da letztes Jahr, wo die Leute sich da vorstellen und dann dieses Flip-Dot-Display da so sich ändert, sowas könnt ihr natürlich auch machen, aber ich brauch halt ein bisschen was anderes als nur Videos und ich mach halt nur Display und Backend und ich brauch noch ein bisschen was für Frontend. Also wer da Ideen hat, kann auf den Kongress auf mich zukommen. Ich bin, wenn man an einer Kasse nach mir fragt, dann bin ich da, irgendwo.
Ich stroh mal da so rum. Von Vortrag zu Lounge zu Floor zu...
Party-Szene.
Vortrag zu Fischrestaurant zu Vortrag zu...
Du hast nichts zu tun? Vielleicht dockst du ja mal bei uns im Sendezentrum an.
Ja, ich bringe halt auf jeden Fall ein paar Leute mit und einige Hörer auch von dem anderen Podcast haben sich da irgendwie schon angekündigt und wollen mal ein Bier loswerden bei mir. Du bist bereit abgefüllt zu werden? Ich bin von Kopf bis Fuß auf Socializing eingestellt.
Das heißt, du lässt dich von Groupies umgeben und mit Bier gefüllt?
Das klingt jetzt ein bisschen falsch, ne. Aber wer Bock hat mal Hallo zu sagen, dem stehe ich offen gegenüber.
Eigentlich habe ich noch nichts geplant so groß. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass ich auch wieder viel im Sendezentrum abhängen werde. So in Ermangelung einer anderen Homebase. Und ansonsten bin ich hoffentlich, also eigentlich immer ansprechbar, hoffentlich dann tatsächlich ansprechbar.
Du könntest dich mal hier mit den anderen Breitschwert-Trägern aus dem Ultraschall-Projekt zusammentun.
Und dann was tun?
Da wird gerade das gehackt, was wir schon besprochen hatten, die Wiedererweckung des Soundflower sozusagen neu. Das ist jetzt gebaut worden.
Kannst du dein Software-Design-Wisdom einbringen?
Ja, das Soundflower war ja so meine ersten zarten Versuche, mal Kernel-Hacking zu betreiben.
Aber der Ansatz ist ja jetzt sozusagen deplicated.
Ja, das war auch nur so eine mittlere Idee. Es hat zumindest teilweise keine Bluescreen erzeugt oder keine Kernel-Panic, aber es hat nicht das getan, was es sollte insofern.
Naja, das steht jetzt auf jeden Fall bei Ultraschall.
Ich guck euch zu. Ihr habt jetzt offensichtlich, was da angekündigt wurde, jetzt wird jetzt alles in HD gestreamt. Auch Sendezentrum, ne? Ihr werdet auch dauernd HD gestreamt. Oder?
Also ich hab gehört, dass alles jetzt HD sei.
Und wurde wie gesagt genannt, die Vortragsräume und das Sendezentrum. Das heißt, ihr werdet auch permanent überwachen.
Also ich weiß nicht, in einem Hörer-Treffen werden wir jetzt wahrscheinlich kein dediziertes machen.
Das wird nicht hinhauen.
Aber wer will, kann mich natürlich ansprechen.
Ja, also Sendezentrum.
Wer mich erkennt, meinst du ja.
Aber auf Twitter kann man ja auch einfach sagen, ey Jo, bist du gerade im CC?
In Saale 1, ja. Mit mir alle gerade voll leise sind alle. Alle Freak Shower mal aufspringen und freien.
So ein kleiner Freak Show-Flashmob.
Kann ich noch mal kurz was zum Sendezentrum. Also Sendezentrum, wie im letzten Jahr, ist halt so ein Bereich, der sich so mit Medien, Podcasting natürlich im Schwerpunkt, Radio etc. Wir haben wieder eine Bühne. Die Bühne wird hoffentlich etwas größer sein als beim letzten Mal. Der Publikumsbereich wird etwas kleiner sein als beim letzten Mal. Das müssen wir mal gucken, wie sich das da ausgeht.
Fandest du beim letztes Mal die Bühne zu klein?
Ja. Ja, die war halt so, dass man da so drauf sitzen konnte. Aber eine Bühne ist etwas, wo man auch von links nach rechts gehen kann. Das ist eine Bühne. Ich rede nicht von einer Bühne, ich rede von einer Bühne.
Dem Panther ist der Geldweg zu klein.
Ich will Saal 1.
Da würden alle Podcasts der Deutschland sein.
Wie auch immer. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich es letztes Mal schon erzählt habe, aber unsere Idee, wir sind noch nicht programmatisch noch nicht komplett durchgeplant, aber wir wollen tagsüber Workshops machen und wir wollen am Abend irgendwie Shows machen. Und teilweise werden da andere Podcasts auftreten, teilweise werden wir da unsere Sondersendungen machen. Vielleicht machen wir auch noch was anderes. Ist irgendwie alles noch viel zu früh. Ich kann mich da gar nicht festlegen. Was wir auf jeden Fall brauchen, sind Leute, die Bock haben, bei uns so ein bisschen mitzuengeln und zu helfen, das Sinnezentrum zu fahren.
Wie ist denn, weil jetzt jemand im Chat fragt, die Akustik, wird es diesmal besser? Also ich meine, als letztes Mal, letztes Mal war es ja doch ein bisschen kritisch.
Auf dem Kongress?
Ja, Sinnezentrum.
Ich hoffe das.
So mit Feedback und wo die Lautsprecher standen und so weiter?
Okay.
Dann darfst du noch ein bisschen Bauschaum und Eierkartons mitbringen.
Wir haben einen, na das ist ja nicht das Problem.
Eierkartons, Eierkartons ist so ein Quatsch.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, Sinnezentrum ist auch der Ort, wo das PodLav Projekt ist, die Show Notes sind da. Wir haben halt einen Tisch, wo man auch Podcast-Produktionen machen kann. Dazu muss man sich aber vorher einen Slot reservieren. Also sozusagen einen Tisch, der fertig mit Recording und Headset ausgestattet ist. Das heißt, man muss nicht sein eigenes Zeug mitnehmen und kann da Sachen produzieren. Das war letztes Mal eigentlich sehr gut angenommen worden. Deswegen gehe ich davon aus, dass es über kurz oder lang da andauernd irgendwelche Produktionen haben wird. Und das Abendprogramm werden wir noch genauer bekannt geben. Wie gesagt, falls jemand Bock hat, uns dort zu helfen, sprich einerseits den Aufbau vielleicht noch ein bisschen mitzubegleiten am 26. beziehungsweise an den vier Tagen mitzuhelfen, da die Technik zu fahren, sprich Pult bedienen etc. die ganzen Audioaufnahmen durchzuführen etc. Dann wendet euch an uns. Ansonsten bin ich selber auch sehr gespannt, was der Kongress alles so mit sich bringen wird dieses Jahr. Ich hab da ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht, was man von diesem Kongress erwarten soll.
Ein Improvement im IPv6-Netz.
Noch eins? Was denn?
Es ist sehr komisch, da es ja nur hinreichend bekannt ist, dass ich der Enzi hier weit und breit bin, der den Kongress nicht besucht, aus Gründen. Trotzdem hat mich jemand am Montag angetwittert, ob ich denn wüsste, warum denn sein Android-Telefon nicht funktioniert hätte auf dem letzten, also neben IPv6-Only-Netz auf seinem letzten Kongress. Und ich hab mich der Sache mal angenommen, hatte auch eine Theorie dazu, die mir dann auch bestätigt wurde von einem Nock-Mitglied, dachte ich, die gebe ich jetzt mal mit, weil da wird sich nämlich auch was ändern. Der hat nämlich sein Android-Telefon eingebucht in das IPv6-Only-Netz, was es ja auch gibt auf dem Kongress, was ich sehr löblich finde. Und er meinte ja, er hätte da keine Adresse bekommen. Das konnte ich bezweifeln, zu Recht auch. Er hat nämlich eine Adresse bekommen, er hat bloß keinen Nameserver bekommen. Und ohne Nameserver macht das Netz halt nicht wirklich ernsthaft richtig viel Spaß. Insbesondere bei dem verwendeten NAT64, was da auch eingebaut wird.
Du meinst, der DNS-Server hatte keine V6-Adresse, oder was?
Nein, er hat keine gekriegt. Es geht nämlich so, dass du normalerweise in einem gemischten Netz mit V4 und V6 fällt dir das nicht auf, weil über einen Nameserver, ein V4-Nameserver per DHCP V4 mitgeteilt wird und wenn du den nach Sachen fragst, drückt der dir auch V6-Adressen raus. Das heißt also, diese Dual-Stack nochmal geht. Aber wenn du IPv6-only bist, benutzt du ja kein DHCP. Normalerweise. Weil du kriegst ja deine Adresse in der Regel so zugewiesen, weil der Router seine Router-Advertisements raussendet. So nach dem Motto, hier gibt es einen Adressbereich, such dir halt selber eine Adresse raus, guck, ob die schon belegt ist und wenn nicht, dann nimmst du die einfach. So ein bisschen selbstverwaltungsmäßig. Stateless Adress-Auto-Assignment nennt sich das. Nun ist es aber so, dass dieser Mechanismus, so wie er ursprünglich spezifiziert wurde, nichts über Name-Source verrät. Der sagt bloß, hier hast du eine Adresse. Ich bin übrigens dein Router, einer von deinen möglichen Routern und hier gibt es einen Adressrange, nimm dir doch selber eine Adresse daraus, viel Spaß. Aber in dieser Info sind keine DNS-Information drin, also keine Name-Server und Domain-Namen und so weiter. Was aber schon immer drin war, war so ein Flag, nämlich Data Configuration Flag, wo der Router sagen kann, übrigens, wenn du noch mehr Fragen hast, wie zum Beispiel Name-Server oder NTP-Server oder wie auch immer, dann frag doch mal bitte einen DHCPv6-Server. Den gab es auch auf dem Kongress letztes Jahr, nur dummerweise kann das Android kein DHCPv6, jedenfalls nicht das, was der Kollege auf seinem Telefon drauf hat. Deswegen hat er zwar eine Adresse hatte, aber ohne DNS, wie gesagt, kein Spaß. Das ITF hat das auch schon verstanden, ungefähr so eine Dekade, nachdem sie IPv6 sich ausgeknüpft haben mit den Router-Advertisements, haben sie gesehen, dass das auch ein Problem sein kann. Dass man, ja, wir machen ja total Adressasignal mit Name-Server, ist dann ein ganz anderes Problem. Das war so ein bisschen ignorant. Deswegen hat man eine Erweiterung nachgeschoben, in der der Router auch in seinem Router-Advertisement Name-Server bekannt geben kann. So ein richtig so kept-obvious-mäßig, wo wir sagen würden, ja, hallo, das hätte da gleich dran denken können. Aber nein. Ja, aber witzigerweise hat es dann noch mal eine ganze Weile gedauert, bis die ganzen Router-Hersteller das kapiert haben. Und die Router, die da im CCC eingesetzt werden, in diesem IPv6-Only-Netz oder überhaupt in den Netz, konnten diese Erweiterung der Router-Advertisements, Feature-Netz nicht, übrigens RD-NSS, konnten das nicht bis vor ein paar Monaten. Das selbe Problem hatten wir auch im IMTF-Netz. Aber wir verwenden übrigens da dasselbe Gerümpel wie der CCC, nämlich Juniper-Router und für das IPv6, also für das NAT64 so A10. Und zumindest die Junipers haben das jetzt mal eingebaut. Das heißt, man kann jetzt hoffen, wenn das noch richtig konfiguriert, wovon ich mal ausgehe, dass sie das tun. Die sind nämlich recht fit, die Kollegen da in Hamburg. Oder die, die das dann in Hamburg machen. Kann das also sein, dass man jetzt ein noch besseres V6-Netz hat, nämlich jetzt mit Nameserver-Advertisement in den Router-Advertisement.
Wie ist das mit iOS-Devices?
Die können beides. Die können beides.
Aber können die überhaupt in so einem V6-Only-Netz komplett leben?
Ja, wie ich schon mal in einer früheren Show schon mal sagte, ja und nein. Das ist so, dass die unteren Schichten das Betriebssystem nicht sehr gut kann. Allerdings, da muss jetzt Roddy noch etwas zu sagen, es gibt irgendwie so ein API-Mechanismus, wo eine Applikation fragen kann, habe ich jetzt Internet oder nicht? Und diese Funktion, die baut da drauf, dass das Gerät selber eine IPv4-Adresse hat. Das muss jetzt nicht notwendig sein. Nein, nicht ganz. Also was passiert ist folgendes, der Telefon bucht sich einen IPv6-Only-Netz, kriegt sofort eine v6-Adresse, aber kriegt keine Antwort auf seine DRCP-Requests. Und was dann passiert, ist, dass nach einer Minute oder so timet der Telefon mit seinem DRCP-Versuch aus und gibt sich dann selber eine Link-Local-Adresse, nämlich eine von diesen 169254er-Adressen. Und in dem Moment erst glauben die ganzen Applikationen, ah, okay, jetzt habe ich Netz. Was blöde ist, weil IPv6 schon 60 Sekunden vorher funktioniert hätte.
Nein, nein, nicht ganz. Das Problem ist ein anderes. Der Mechanismus, der funktioniert, aber man muss ihn richtig benutzen. Und der Sample-Code, den es von Apple gibt, der macht diverse Dinge falsch. Unter anderem so Sachen wie, du darfst sie nicht auf dem Main-Thread benutzen. Steht auch im ReadMe drin, tue das nicht. Deine App könnte 30 Sekunden lang blockieren, wenn er keinen DNS-Server findet. Machen sie im Sample-Code trotzdem. Was passiert natürlich, alle Leute, die sich diesen Sample-Code kurz angucken, benutzen ihn so, wie Apple das auch tut.
Nämlich falsch.
Nämlich falsch. Ich bin darauf gekommen, weil in unserer App, also irgendwie die PMs sind so ein bisschen der Meinung, die haben so einen Wettbewerb. Wer kann am meisten Third-Party-Libraries in die App reinschmeißen? Und wir hatten jetzt das Problem, dass in manchen Situationen die App nicht mehr hochkam, weil die wird nämlich beim Hochfahren nach 10 Sekunden gekillt, wenn sie sich nicht rückmeldet. Also wenn die länger als 10 Sekunden braucht, sagt iOS, oh, das wird nix mehr. Tschüss, hau mal ab, geh weg.
So.
Und das lag unter anderem da dran, dass zwei der verwendeten Libraries diesen Mechanismus falsch benutzen und keinen DNS-Server gefunden haben. Okay, wir haben ihn auch falsch benutzt.
Doch, wie gesagt, unter Umständen ist ja einer da, aber ist halt keiner der aus x.y.z.q. Sondern so komische Hex-Zahlen mit Doppelpunkten dazwischen.
Du darfst den Scheiß, also Netzwerk macht man einfach nicht auf dem Mainthread, macht man halt nicht. Brauchen wir nicht diskutieren. Das muss man immer irgendwo im Hintergrund machen, weil das kann dauern oder es kann auch komplett schiefgehen und es kann lange Timeouts haben. So. Und ein anderes Ding ist, dass sie in dem Sample-Code hatten, sie nur den Code für V4 drin. Genau.
Gut, aber du sagst uns jetzt die tolle deutsche eBay ab. Von der red ich nicht. Du bist ja da, buch die doch mal. Nimm die doch mal in dem IPv6-Only-Netz in Hamburg, nimmst die mal an und guck mal, ob die vernünftig mit dir redet.
Ich kann da mal ein paar Apps ausprobieren.
Es ist aber im Übrigen so, dass der Apple macht ja diesen komischen Militafilter da oben, der dir die Verfügbarkeit von WLAN anzeigt. Den macht das auch erst dann an, wenn du glaubst, dass das alles koscher ist. Und wie gesagt, das dauert halt eine Weile. Wie gesagt, jein, es funktioniert. Wenn du erst mal drin bist und sozusagen dir das Telefon aufgegeben hat, sich per DHCP V4 in der Adresse zu erbetteln, dann ist es in dem Zustand, wo es funktioniert. Aber in dieser Zwischenzeit, wo du noch glaubst, es könnte vielleicht noch eine V4-Adresse erhaschen, ist es irgendwo so in so einem Lingo-State.
Ich hab übrigens noch zwei Predictions für den Kongress.
Apple hat ein, was man früher mal Glas A-Netz nannte. Slash 8.
Seit 1993 sagen wir dazu Slash 8, Rudi.
Ich sagte doch, was man mal früher...
HP hat das übrigens auch und das MIT auch.
Es könnte damit zusammenhängen, dass die dieses Problem IPv4-Adressen könnten ausgehen, noch nicht so auf dem Plan haben, weil die selber haben ja noch irgendwie 2 hoch 24 davon.
Wer hat der kann?
Jedenfalls hab ich noch zwei Vorhersagen für den Kongress. Erstens glaube ich, dass dieses OS X gerade so kaputt ist, dass es so doll kaputt ist, dass es auf dem Kongress eventuell so doll einen Ärger macht, dass nichts geht im WLAN. Weil ich glaube, dass die WLAN-Probleme, die diese Yosemite gerade hat, liegt ja, wenn man den Updates glauben darf, weil es kommt nämlich andauernd neue Bluetooth-Treiber da dran, dass es Bluetooth dem WLAN dazwischenfunkt, weil die ja ihr Handover und ihr Continuity machen und so weiter. Und wenn das Update von Apple bis zum Kongress nicht draußen ist, dann werden auf dem Kongress die ganzen, und ich weiß nicht, ob es das iPhone auch macht, aber die ganzen Macintosh- oder Apple-Laptops, die werden alle irgendwie Bluetooth rumfunken wie ein Continuity und werden das ganze WLAN runterdrücken. Das ist ein Problem, falls sie kein Update bringen. Und das Zweite, was ich glaube, ist, dass es ganz schön knapp werden könnte mit dem Platz auf dem Kongress.
Also ich hab ja mit 10, 10, 0 Massivprobleme mit dem WLAN gehabt und hab mit dem 10, 10, 1 jetzt Massivprobleme mit dem Bluetooth.
Ja, vielleicht haben sie das Problem ein bisschen verschoben, aber es gibt ja schon ein 10, 10, 2 Beta und da ist der Bluetooth-Treiber nochmal geändert worden. Das heißt, sie haben es nicht komplett gefixt bekommen. Und ich bin da noch so ein bisschen skeptisch.
Ich habe gar kein Yosemite. Deswegen hoffe ich...
Du machst immer noch 10, 9, ne? Mutig.
Ich auch.
Na, weil es alter Scheiß ist.
Ja, alter Scheiß funktioniert.
Dieses Yosemite ist wirklich furchtbar. Ich hab das irgendwie auf meinem Tess iMac installiert und benutze das da von Zeit zu Zeit. Und es ist einfach unläsbar alles. Es ist so weichgezeichnete Scheiße. Dann hab ich irgendwie diesen Kontrastmodus angeschaltet, um überhaupt noch was auseinanderhalten zu können. Dann starr ich da so drauf. Es sieht aus wie System 6. Also sie haben es wirklich geschafft, jetzt eher OS X designmäßig wieder System 6, also wir reden von 1990, dahin zu führen, designmäßig. Schwarz-Weiße-Icons, alles ganz klein.
Ja, wenn man natürlich den Super-Kontrast einschaltet, ist es natürlich alles schwarz-weiß.
Die kommen alle wieder. Die kommen alle wieder, sind alle ganz, ganz nah. Heinz-Rudolf Kunze. Ich hab jetzt System 6 nicht mehr drauf.
Aber ich verliere mich da. Ich verliere einfach die Affinität zu diesem User-Interface.
Also ich hab da kein Problem mit. Ich finde immer, wenn ich wieder auf Mavericks bin, dass es irgendwie so all aussieht.
Das ist geil.
Ordentlicher Font, etwas lesen.
Überall diese komischen Gradients.
Ich finde die extrem leitend, weil ich einfach unterscheiden kann zwischen Chrome und Content. Und bei Yosemite verwischt das alles. Das ist alles so schwappig.
Das muss ich nicht. Ich habe Chrome nicht installiert.
Ich rede nicht von dem Chrome.
Das war der Versuch eines hinterhältigen Rants über den bekloppten Namen eines bekloppten Browsers.
Ich muss auch sagen, so richtig...
Mich überzeugt das überhaupt nicht.
Ich finde meinen Mavericks auch immer noch hübsch. Ich gucke ja bei den ganzen Kollegen immer hier Yosemite an und denke mir, ja...
Ich benutze ja zwei Laptops, ein so und ein so. Es gibt immer noch Gründe, beides zu benutzen. Die Gründe neu zu benutzen sind, weil man neue Features benutzen will. Was ich durchaus sehr gerne mache, ist, dass ich immer noch Leute kenne, die kein Apple-Device hatten. Zugegebenermaßen nicht viele. Aber dass ich jetzt aus der Messages-App endlich normale Kurzmitteilungen verschicken kann, im Mobilfunknetz, ist ein kleines Feature. Aber es ist ein Feature, das ich sehr häufig nutze. Deswegen kann man das mal erwähnen.
Ja, die ganze Continuity-Kram.
Die ganze Continuity-Kram ist schon, wenn das auch am Ende des Tages mal...
Die Features habe ich nichts. Mich stört einfach nur die Optik.
Da sind wir wieder bei dem...
Ich habe auf dem alten...
Sieht so furchtbar scheiße aus. Allein schon diese...
Wie nennt man das?
OCD, ne? Was heißt das nochmal ganz genau?
Obsessive-Compulsive-Disorder.
Genau, wenn so Dinge so ein bisschen falsch sind und du musst sie irgendwie sortieren, so einen Streichhölzer auf dem Tisch legen und du musst sie irgendwie so gerade machen und so. Stackeblocken heißt das.
Wie ich neulich in Frankreich unbedingt das Kabel aus der Klappe ziehen musste.
Weil im Safari sitze ich immer da vor und dann will ich immer diesen Vor- und Zurück-Button irgendwie auseinanderschieben. Diese Pfeile, die sitzen auf so eine Art und Weise zusammen. Die sind nicht eins. So wie vorher. Wo es klar war, da so ein Button mit zwei Teilen. Aber es sind auch nicht zwei Buttons. Sondern da fehlt irgendwie ein Pixel oder zwei oder vielleicht auch drei.
Ich weiß nicht, diese ganzen Kontraste und so, ich finde das alles hässlich. Nee, ich sag's jetzt wie es ist. Ich finde das hässlich.
Und auch dieses Helvetica. Ja, schalte ich ja eh alles gleich ab.
Ich muss sagen, Transparenz habe ich allerdings auch ausgeschaltet. Das habe ich wahrscheinlich auch bei IOS erstmal ausgeschaltet.
Wir freuen uns jetzt nur noch auf Updates für die Fritzbox. Bei Apple ist vorbei mit Updates.
Transparenz reduzieren, so heißt es. Den Bedienungshilfen.
Interfacetechnisch die absolute Apple-Bankrott-Anklärung, was User Interfaces angeht. Da bin ich mittlerweile auch fassungslos. Ich kann es echt nicht glauben, dass sie es immer noch schaffen, kontinuierlich mit jedem neuen Release von iTunes das Interface noch unbrauchbarer, noch beschissener, noch grausamer zu machen. Ich sitze jedes Mal davon und denke mir, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, benutzt das keiner. Wie sie jetzt gerade diese Devices, wenn du da irgendwelche Devices ransteckst, bis man das findet.
Wo ist denn überhaupt diese Frequenzaktivität, wenn man Musik abspielt? Ich meine, das war doch immer in Archiv und das hast du gesehen. Das ist das Fakt, oder?
Also ja, diese Anzeige davon halt.
Analyzer.
Die Frequenzbänder, die halt mal zeigen, was für...
Das ist doch Brollkram.
Nein, das ist nicht Brollkram.
Doch, das ist Brollkram.
Nein, das ist einfach, wenn es nicht abspielt, dann will ich einfach wissen, dass da auch Audio kommt und das Ding nicht gerade eine leere Datei abspielt oder so. Ich will einfach Audio sehen.
Das ist jetzt auf jeden Fall ein Nischen-Feature, aber ist ein valider Punkt, aber ich fände es viel schlimmer, so diese ganze...
Das ist einer der Hauptgründe, warum ich überhaupt iTunes zum Beispiel für Musik benutze.
Diese ganze Navigation, oder wenn du steckst dein iPhone oder irgendwas rein, dann klickst du da drauf, dann kannst du aber nichts machen, dann musst du erst aufklappen und dann irgendwie da drin suchen und auch der App-Store ist jetzt in irgendeinem Submenü versteckt. Das ist das...
Das finde ich, da finde ich die Logik aber besser, weil vorher war es, du bist entweder in deiner Bibliothek oder du bist im App-Store. Und in diesem App-Store musst du dann nochmal alles machen. Jetzt kannst du sagen, und dann kannst du sagen, meine Podcast oder im App-Store. Also du gehst sozusagen von einer anderen Denker. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz okay, weil meistens kümmere ich mich erst mal um dasselbe. Das ist nicht der Ort entscheidend, sondern das, womit ich jetzt eigentlich gerade arbeite.
Du siehst dieses Interface, wo ist der App-Store. Das primäre Interface, wo du da irgendwie...
Zu finden ist es nicht. Ich sage nur, die Logik ist an sich besser, ja, aber zu finden ist nichts besser. Das sieht aus wie Windows.
Das ist furchtbar.
Das sieht aus wie Windows.
Und jede Version bisher, sie haben echt so einen Track-Roll. Es wurde einfach immer schlimmer. Das ist auch so ein Ding, das... Ja, ich weiß nicht, es mutiert. Das ist so ein...
Und da haben wir noch gar nicht über YouTube geredet.
Und das richtig Schlimme ist, überall sonst ist es noch schlimmer.
Es gibt ja nichts Gutes mehr.
Ja, es ist vorbei.
Es gibt ja nichts Gutes mehr auf dieser Welt.
Das ist schon schlimm, ein bisschen. Andererseits schafft das wahrscheinlich auch wieder so neue Gelegenheiten.
Ich hab gehört, der Hannes macht jetzt ein neues OS in Okaml.
Weckt mich, wenn sie einen Blog haben.
Was ist das denn für ein Message im Chat?
Das ist doch bestimmt wieder nur so ein Troll-Mehl. Ja, nee, warten wir. Ich habe ein Verdacht. Ich glaube, wir sind durch mit unseren Themen. Echt?
Das ist dein Verdacht?
Tschüss. Ich könnte dir das nur noch ranten, aber wer will denn das schon hören?
Ach, die Hörer, ich glaube schon.
Ach, das ist alles so grausinnlos.
Den Flash-Updater, du hast hier irgendwie extrem viele Punkte dazu aufgeschrieben. Ja, das war so ein Wahn irgendwie. Das kennt doch jeder. Da brauchen wir doch nicht drüber zu reden.
Ich fand das bloß mal irgendwie so absurd.
Ich habe keinen Flash-Updater. Ich benutze nur Chrome, da ist kein Flash-Updater.
Ich bin so fasziniert davon gewesen. Also das passt insofern jetzt ganz gut ins Thema. Wie kompliziert manche Software Dinge machen kann, wo man sich denkt, das geht doch auch einfacher.
Kann noch nicht so schwer sein. Aber es geht noch schlimmer. Der, wie heißt das Ding, Scan-Snap-Manager, der irgendwie alle paar Tage hochkommt mit so einem Request. Du musst updaten. Schließen sie ihren Scanner an, um abzudaten. Und dann sagst du aber, weiter irgendwo in dem Text steht drin, wenn du jetzt weiterklickst, wird irgendwie abgedatet, ohne dass du den Scanner angeschlossen hast. Dann klickst du weiter und dann kommt, es wurden keine Updates gefunden.
Das ist auch so ein Stück, ja. Ich mag zwar den Scanner, aber diese Update-Nummer ist echt der Kracher.
Der Scanner ist super, die Software.
Da hast du wahrscheinlich noch nur als Software. Alle zwei Wochen ihren Scanner an, um dann zu erfahren, dass es keine Updates gibt.
Nee, macht das nicht. Wenn du jetzt eine funktionierende Software hast, dann trittst du nämlich genau diesen neuen Online-Updater ein, diesen Online-Update-Manager ein oder so was. Der poppt echt alle paar Tage hoch. Macht voll den Alarm. Und wenn du dann sagst, dann mach doch ein Update. Nee, nee, nee, es gibt keine Updates.
Und die haben jetzt auch einen Online-Manager eingebaut.
Ich hätte ja noch was zu erzählen als Update zuletzt, aber ich habe mein Volumenkontinent schon verbraucht, bin deshalb gedrosselt.
Warte, lass ihn mal kurz das Ventil noch aufmachen.
Du musst den Dump ablassen. Also ich fand das wirklich so faszinierend. So eine Firma wie Adobe.
Ist eh ein Drecksladen.
Ja, klar ist das ein Drecksladen. Aber ich meine, was ist so deren Ding? Ich meine, dieses Flash ist irgendwie tot eigentlich.
Außer für Adobe selber, weil die es ja benutzen.
Ja, aber warum gibt es immer, wenn man Flash benutzen will, ein Update davon?
Weil es halt löchrig ist. Weil es halt löchrig ist wie...
Aber das ist mehr Loch als Käse.
Ich könnte ja damit leben, wenn sie in der Lage wären, Updates mal so installieren, wie Google das macht. Einfach updaten.
So Hintertürchen-mäßig.
Ja, einfach den Rechner routen und irgendwas draufspielen, wenn sie gerade Bock haben.
Wie wäre es mit, es liegt ein Update vor, soll installiert werden? Ja. Und dann drückst du drauf und dann updatet er?
Ja, Sparkle nennt sich das.
Tim, das Problem ist, du siehst da zwei Mächte miteinander kämpfen. Du benutzt ja Flash im Safari. Und immer dann, wenn der Flash dir dein Netzerlebnis wieder repariert hat, kommt nach ein paar Tagen der böse Apple und sagt, ne, das ist aber scheiße, ich mach dir das aus. Das ist nämlich der Apple, der das ausmacht. Das ist nicht der Adobe, der selber sagt, oh, ich bin aber löchrig, ich gehe mal, ich funktioniere mal nicht.
Darum geht es ja gar nicht.
Der Apple macht dir den Flash aus. Und deswegen musst du ihn immer wieder neu installieren. Weil es immer wieder kaputt ist. Ja, ist ja richtig, aber...
Nein, nein, wenn der Apple den Flash nicht ausgeschaltet hat, dieses Ding ist nicht in der Lage, sich ordnungsgemäß zu aktualisieren, auf eine Art und Weise, wie es irgendwie sane wäre.
Adobe-Produkte sind noch viel mehr nicht in der Lage.
Ich hab das mal aufgeschrieben, also. Jetzt kommt das Ding hoch, auf einmal hast du so ein Alert-Fenster da, sagt ja, hallo, es gibt eine neue Version. Er sagt mir natürlich weder, welche Version ich gerade verwende, noch wie die neue Version ist.
Das hasse ich übrigens auch bei WordPress.
Geschweige denn irgendwas, wie...
Und auch nicht, was gefixt wurde.
Ja, oder warum man das jetzt installieren sollte, was genau, was da irgendwie passiert ist.
Das Problem benutzt ja nur Tim.
Jaja, genau. Deswegen machen sie es ja so. Und sagen einfach nur, es gibt was Neues. Dann kannst du da sagen, installieren, oder was kann ich öffnen, keine Ahnung, den button habe ich mir gerade nicht notiert. Was kommt dann? Dann kommt eine Webseite.
Ja.
Warteschleif erstmal, bevor der Download losgeht.
Auf dieser Webseite musst du dann auch nochmal den Button drücken, um es runterzuladen.
Kann nicht sein, dass du vorher 20 Haken ausmachen musst, damit sie nicht gleich sicher noch die Yahoo-Toolbar mitinstallieren?
Dieses Faser haben sie hinter sich gelassen.
Vielleicht auf dem Mac, aber nicht auf BT.
Ja, das kann sein, ich rede jetzt hier nur für den Mac. So, dann wird ein DMG runtergeladen, wie wir alle wissen, User lieben DMGs, weil sie A, genau wissen, was es ist, und B, weil sie auch genau wissen, was sie damit tun müssen.
Candidate, wenn ich immer so an einen Mac jeden von irgendwelchen Benutzern rangehen muss, muss ich erstmal die ganzen DMGs ejecten, die ich in den letzten zwei Jahren so runtergeladen habe. Gehen wir noch im Download-Orner-Link. Die starten die Applikationen. Die haben im Download-Orner ein DMG, klicken da drauf, wenn ich Skype starten muss, muss ich erst auf dieses Ding klicken, dann geht diese Fenster auf, und da ist dann das Skype-Programm drin.
Die meisten Programme sagen, es geht nicht, weil es ist ein Read-Only-Volume, und du musst es erst rüber gucken.
Den Code kenn ich auch, den hab ich auch schon mal eingebaut.
Genau, wir sind bei Schritt 2, eigentlich ist es schon Schritt 3, wenn ich genau sagen soll. Also da lädt dieses Ding runter.
Aber warte, man muss noch ein Detail erwähnen. Und zwar bevor das runtergeladen wird, kommt da ja diese Webseite, oder lädst du den direkt runter? Jedenfalls, wenn man es über die Webseite macht, dann kommt da erstmal so geschummelte 10 Sekunden, die er so tut, als wenn er voll nachdenken muss. Und erst dann geht der Download los. Der geht natürlich nicht sofort los, nein, nein. Sondern da dreht erst hier diese Babas-Roll, oder wie die heißt dieses, wie heißt das Ding?
Baba-Poll, glaube ich.
Baba-Poll, genau, das dreht er erstmal eine Weile. Und dann geht irgendwann der Download los. So ein bisschen wie früher bei Feil, diese Feil-Hoster, diese billigen, die so...
War das nicht sogar so, dass Adobe dir sogar anbietet, erst einen Download-Manager runterzuladen?
Was da runterlädt, ist dann eine Datei mit dem klangvollen Namen. Adobe Flash Player Installer unterstrich 16AU unterstrich ltao.sxd unterstrich aaa unterstrich aih.de.
Was, geil, gibt's schon 16?
Versionsnummer, ich seh da keine Versionsnummer.
Ich hatte noch 15 letztens.
Ja, das ist einfach ein wilder Mix von irgendwelchen Buchstaben und das Ding hätte er aber...
Nee, das aih.dmg, also hinten, das ist seit einiger Weile stabil. Nobody does even care.
Mach mal weiter hier, sonst sind wir morgen noch hier. Wir sitzen schon morgen hier.
Kein, kein, nicht nur das ist kein Interessiert, selbst wenn es einen interessiert, niemand würde wissen, was damit irgendwie auch nur am Ansatz gemeint sein könnte. Egal, ich sag ja nur, wie man es schön machen kann. So, dann liegt das Ding da.
Ja, da muss man es anklicken und mounten und ja.
Genau, man muss wissen, dass man, versetzt sich doch mal einfach in die Situation eines normalen Benutzers. Das ist doch wirklich, also jetzt schon einfach fünf Schritte zu viel. Jetzt musst du also ein Disc Image mounten. Dann mountest du das, dann öffnet sich ein Ding mit dem klangvollen Namen Adobe Flash Player Installer. In dem befindet sich ein Install Adobe Flash Player. Was denn nun? Wie heißt denn dieses Programm? Heißt es Adobe Flash Player Installer? Oder heißt es Install Adobe Flash Player?
Da guckt eh keiner drauf, die klicken nur aufs iPhone.
Jetzt musst du noch mal doppelklicken. Um dieses Ding zu starten, da kommt natürlich erstmal ein Dialog hoch, dass du das jetzt vom Internet runtergeladen hast und dass das natürlich total unsicher ist. Ja, das ist Apple, aber auch das hätte man sich alles ersparen können. Also es würde auch alles nicht stattfinden müssen. Sparkle heißt es.
Es heißt Sparkle. Einfach auf GitHub forken und einbauen. Und dann hat man alles mit Schafe und so.
Dann startest du dieses Programm. Und dann wird es wieder geil. Jetzt kommt auch noch ein Dialog hoch, wo du noch dein scheiß Passwort eingeben musst. Grund. Install Adobe Flash Player. So heißt das Ding jetzt. Wants to make changes. Da fühlt man sich doch richtig zu Hause, oder?
Einmal komplett Hose runter, dann.
Ja, das ist so, als ob so jemand bei dir an der Tür klingelt und sagt ja, ja guten Tag, ich muss jetzt hier rein. Ja, warum? Ja, ich möchte Veränderungen vornehmen. Jetzt kommen wir an meinen Lieblingsteil.
Dann gehen wir auf Live bis Flash.
Weißt du übrigens, warum der Max uns nicht zuhört? Der podcastet selber gegen uns Andi Sau.
Bei dem vollsten Vertrauen. Was macht man dann?
Alles schnell wieder weg natürlich.
Man gibt jetzt sein Passwort ein. Dann kommt irgendwie ein Ding. Das Fenster heißt Adobe Flash Player Installationsprogramm. Jetzt heißt es auf einmal Installationsprogramm. Mit einem Inhalt, da steht nochmal Adobe Flash Player, als ob man das nicht jetzt schon tausendmal gelesen hätte. Es gibt hier noch einen Teil zum Progress Bar, der dann erstmal so völlig innoviert, so hochzählt. Installation wird ausgeführt 79%. Was passiert dann?
Er hält an, weil Safari ist noch offen.
Genau, er hält an, der Progress Bar verschwindet natürlich wieder bei 79%. Er ist jetzt einfach weg, du siehst ihn nicht mehr, sondern er sagt, schließen Sie die folgenden Anwendungen, um den Vorgang fortzusetzen.
Unter anderem die Systemeinstellung, wo ich mich hier...
Ja, weil er da heute auch was rein installiert. Naja, nur der Punkt ist, warum kann er die denn nicht selber schließen?
Er hat doch schon Ruth.
Er braucht doch, er ist Ruth, er ist alles. Er braucht den Dinger nur ein Quittevent zu schicken. So nein. Dann gibt's einen schönen Button rechts unten und der heißt erneut versuchen.
Aber du hast das Beste ja eigentlich ausgelassen. Also seit einiger Zeit ist er ein bisschen intelligenter geworden. Es gab ja eine Weile lang, gab's ja den Installer so, du hast ihn angeklickt und wenn du nicht Admin warst auf der Kiste, dann hat er es irgendwie erstmal versucht und hat dann aber den Authentifizierungsdialog hochgeschmissen. Aber im Hintergrund lief der Progress Bar weiter, bis er bei 95 Prozent war und blieb dann hängen.
Geil, das heißt er ist auch nur so zeitmäßig.
Das ist nur Fake gewesen, klar.
Das ist einfach nur Fake. Jetzt kommt erneut versuchen, wo ich mich natürlich als erstes frage, habe ich eben schon mal was versucht? Ich wollte doch nur den Flash Player installieren. Was soll denn jetzt erneut versucht werden? Der ganze Installationsvorgang? Naja, nicht, dass er einem sagt, er sagt einem schon, ich soll den Safari beenden. Dann beende ich diesen Safari, dann kommt Installation, wird ausgeführt, jetzt kommt dieser Progress Bar wieder, ist dann bei Obscuren 97%, wo er dann eine Weile verbleibt, nachdem wir vorher bei 79 waren, jetzt 97, wahrscheinlich drehen sie einfach nur die beiden Zahlen um, da halte ich nur diese beiden Zustände, 79 und 97. Jetzt wird diese Installation ausgeführt, das dauert dann noch mal eine ganze Weile, dann wird sie ausgeführt und dann irgendwann steht da Installation abgeschlossen, mit einem geilen grünen Hickchen noch rechts da dran und es ist so richtig so, verstehst du, so ist es einfach alles geil, fertig, abgehakt, super und deswegen gibt es da auch rechts unten noch einen Button, wo drauf steht Fertigstellen. Das finde ich überhaupt am besten. Also 100% Haken, Installation abgeschlossen, ist genauso fertig wie Medon. Und der Button ist Fertigstellen. Was soll denn jetzt bitte noch fertiggestellt werden? Wir wissen alle, was fertiggestellt werden muss. Die einzige Fertigstellung, die jetzt noch stattfindet, ist das Aufrufen ihrer bekloppten Scheiß-Webseite, wo sie einem dann noch irgendwelche anderen Produkte anbieten wollen.
Nee, sie tun's.
Thank you and enjoy Adobe Flash Player. Der ganze Bildschirm ist grau.
Aber sag mal, warum bist du denn von deinem Konzept abgewichen, nur noch Chrome als Flash-Browser zu benutzen und ansonsten Flash von deiner Plattform fernzuhalten?
Das ist nämlich mein Konzept, was sich sehr gut macht.
Ja, das hat sich bei mir irgendwie dann...
Du hast sogar meinen Usern aufgedrängt.
Irgendwann war es ein bisschen sehr anstrengend, weil ich da wirklich permanent... Also ehrlich gesagt, ich bin etwas überrascht. Und also wie stark öffn ich einfach bestimmte Webseiten nach wie vor auf Flash setzen.
Ja, dann nimmst du halt Chrome.
Und was ich halt am schlimmsten finde dabei ist YouTube. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie jetzt in den letzten Monaten da noch was dran getan hat.
Wenn du da einmal die HTML5-Beta da geklickt hast.
Wenn du einmal Click to Flash installiert hast, dann kriegst du immer...
Wenn du Click to Flash installiert hast?
Ja, dann kriegst du immer die MP4s.
Aber Tim, also ich gucke YouTube eigentlich ausschließlich auf Safari mit HTML5. Das geht bei mir super. Seit wann? Seit...
Menschen gedenkt?
Ja, oder seit Mavericks.
Also ich hab da noch am laufenden Meter immer wieder Files gehabt, wovon er meinte, dass die nur als FLV vorlagen.
Ich krieg das, also ich würde sagen, vielleicht einmal im Monat finde ich ein Video oder vielleicht alle zwei Monate finde ich ein Video, wo tatsächlich dann, das sagt aber eigentlich so die ganzen Content-Creators, die ich so auf YouTube verfolge und auch irgendwie alle möglichen Videos, keine Ahnung, ich brauch's schon viel auf YouTube und komm damit im Safari eigentlich immer recht weit. Was jetzt gerade nicht geht, ist ja, dass YouTube hat jetzt 60 Frames per Second-Videos, jetzt Support drin und diese ganzen Minecraft-Streamer, die releasen ihre Videos jetzt in 60 FPS bei einem 8-Bit-Spiel, das ist super geil. Aber man sieht den Unterschied. Ja, ist alles viel flüssiger. Und die 60 FPS-Versionen, die kriegst du nur mit dem Chrome. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das dann Flash ist oder ob sie das nur für ihren Browser freischalten oder keine Ahnung, Safari, gibt's diese Optionen in dem Settings-Menü, nicht?
Also ich bin auf jeden Fall dieses Gefühl nicht losgeworden, dass sie einfach bestimmte Videos nicht konvertieren. Weil sie einem dann einfach FLV, vielleicht hat sich das jetzt in den letzten Monaten zu Ende gespielt, das Ding, ich hab jetzt länger nicht mehr gemacht. Ich werd das nochmal ausprobieren, weil ich möchte eigentlich dieses Flash gar nicht mehr auf meinem Rechner haben. Das nervt, aber was ist hier mit Spiegel?
Kennen wir keinen bei Spiegel online, also wenn du im Safari im Developer-Menü sagst, du bist ein iPad, dann kriegst du ja die ohne Flash. Na ja, kannst du einstellen. Aber es ist halt auch scheiße, weil dann kriegst du den Rest der Web-Version. Aber letztendlich haben sie jetzt alles da, warum sie den jetzt im Browser auf Flash forcen.
Es ist lizenziert und muss jetzt auch gefälligst abgeschrieben werden, ordentlich.
Abschreiben können sie es ja von mir.
Auf jeden Fall soll sie dir was schämen.
Dieses Click to Flash, geht das damit Yosemite in Mavericks noch? Weil die Version, die die da auf der Seite haben, ist nur bis 10.6.
Ne, du musst es als Erweiterung direkt von Apple installieren.
Click to Flash. So läuft's.
Ich hab das hier installiert, das tut. Erweiterungen.
Click to Flash ist übrigens eine gute Sache, wer es noch nicht gehört hat. Mal ausprobieren.
Click to Flash 3.0 steht hier.
Ja, aber es ist noch besser, wenn man gar keine Flash hat.
Ja, eben, finde ich ja eigentlich auch. Ich würde auch gerne ohne Flash aufstehen, aber ich war der Sache ein wenig müde, Friends zu dem, dass ich Friends.
Ja, mich nervt es halt auch, wenn ich dann doch mal den Chrom aufmachen muss, aber ich nehme es hin dafür, dass ich halt nicht diesen Scheiß-Flash-Updater kriege und sonst nicht dieses Giraffel da die ganze Zeit im Browser rumdödeln hab.
Mich mit einem, ja, da hast du vorhin gesagt, ich soll da was drüber sagen.
Weiß ich nicht. Muss ich nicht. Kannst auch sagen lassen. Kannst aber was anderes Schönes sagen. Was dann noch so einfällt.
Roddy, du warst nicht zum Kongress, oder wie?
Doch, ich komm zum Kongress.
Er hat doch gesagt, der lungert ja in einem Senderzentrum rum.
Genau. Mal gucken.
Ich kann auch hinter der Kasse rumlungern.
Du kannst ja eine Privat-Freak-Show machen, nur für so...
Da bringt er mal die besten Themen, wie letzte Mal DNS, ihr Schweine. Hallo, ich hab gesagt, ich mach auch remote mit, aber das ist dem feinen Herrn Pritloff ja nicht qualitativ. Trip-Love. Remote-Participation. Macht jeder andere Scheiß-Podcast in Deutschland nur du, mich.
Wenn ich auch noch remote, dann werden wir dich ja überhaupt nicht gebremst.
Doch.
Unterregeln, genau.
Ich find, das ist hier schon alles ganz richtig hier so mit dem Angesicht des Schweißes.
Deswegen mach ich dir jetzt beim nächsten Mal auch gleich wieder die Hölle heiß. Ich fress wieder am Morgen ein Provokant und dann komm ich her. Den Knackhasen bringst du dann wieder mit.
Mit dem Knacker war er nicht schlecht, da hat er sich gut abgerackert, da war die Energie irgendwann verpufft.
Komm, knack noch ne Hasennuss.
Genau, schmeißt doch hier schon mal die Outro-Schleife rein, damit wir gar nicht auf die Idee kommen noch irgendwelche...
Irgendwann ein anderes Thema anzufangen. Können wir mal machen. Wir haben mal wieder die vier Stunden rund gemacht, glaube ich, war. Also, die Freak Show geht und wir sagen Tschüss, bis bald, bis nächstes Jahr.
Oder bis zum Kongress.
Genau, kommt auf den Kongress. Tschüss bald.
Bye bye.
Sie ist von Paris geboren und wird von den Amerikanern Little French Doll genannt, kleine französische Puppe. Sie hat immerhin schon einen Preis aus Montreux in der Tasche und einen Grand Prix Eurovision. Franz Gall singt Computer Nummer 3.